provides a unique service to the
academic community at the lowest
possible cost
[Music]
once again c-span
goes back to vietnam for the next five
days as promised for those of you who
watched portions of it earlier over
memorial day what you're seeing on your
screen
is video taken back in april the week of
april the 18th in hanoi
and this is called barbers row which is
a street in hanoi where
barbers set up outside with their
chairs and
mirrors and
barbering equipment
lots of other
individual
street side vendors
all in this area as is common in that
part of the world
we're going to watch uh this for a few
moments and we will be back here with
kathy murphy to talk about our viewer
response from
our last
showing of vietnam revisited a look at
the people
and the country of vietnam and later in
the week of course and we'll give you
the schedule in a moment we'll talk
about the mia pow situation
[Music]
does he always cut your hair
how much does it cost to have your hair
cut um
four thousand done
how often do you have to have a cat uh
one week every week
are all the barber shops
on the street like this
always get your hair cut on the street
me
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what do you think
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
sticky
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
how long are you
wow
[Music]
wow
[Music]
oh
[Music]
go
[Music]
scenes of the barber street in hanoi
taken last april
a hot day in hanoi as awful lot of days
are in vietnam probably close to 100
degrees fahrenheit
one of the many scenes we'll see during
the week as we once again look at the
vietnam trip for you those of you many
of you who have asked that
we re-show this it's been scheduled now
for some time for this time period
in august when things are a bit quieter
at least here in washington although
they're not quiet in the united states
as many of you know from watching the
activities in south florida and
louisiana
we've got a lot to show you before the
week's over and we want to give you some
sense of what the schedule is going to
be in a few minutes
the bottom of the hour our guest will be
the author of this book a year in saigon
katie kelly which we'll talk a lot about
she's going to be with us for the rest
of the afternoon to talk about her year
of experience in vietnam
teaching amerasian children
how to speak english and a lot of other
things that she learned while she was
there but for the moment let's take a
look at what the schedule be for the
rest of the day and the rest of the week
for today by the way those are scenes of
saigon river
for today coming up in just a minute
kathy murphy will join us
to talk about
what we learned the last time around
over memorial day about this 30-hour
special on vietnam katie kelly will be
with us for a live call in at 12 30.
and at uh 1 15 east coast time the
amerasian transit center in saigon
that's the center where
children who are of
american fathers and vietnamese women
born many years ago often
and some of their
grandchildren
go to this center in saigon to transfer
to the united states
and we'll
katie kelley can give us plenty of
background on that william fleming one
of the
gentlemen at the state department
dealing with the american issue and
refugees will be with us again at 1 50.
he'll be here uh in person he joined us
before for call-in show
then we'll go to the university of ho
chi minh city
at 2 30
and watch an english class being taught
after that at 3 30
our own jacqueline pham who is
a producer here at c-span and a native
of saigon and vietnam
will be here with us on tape and in
person to talk about her experience
going back to vietnam and then at 4 30
american students in hanoi going to
school there and living on the economy
and finally
vietnamese students
here in the u.s at 5 15. this is a focus
all day long today on
the people of vietnam
on tuesday
we shift to the mia pow
issue
senator john mccain
former prisoners of war senator john
kerry
deputy assistant secretary of defense
for pows and mias affairs and open
phones
a lot of you who saw the program back
over memorial day will have seen a lot
of this but there will be
fresh call-in shows with among other
folks representatives from the defense
department and john kerry the senator
who is the chairman of the mia pow
select committee in the senate
on wednesday
focus on
the politics of vietnam
ho chi minh mausoleum in hanoi
the
tudu
obstetrics hospital
in saigon
the prosthetic research center
in
north vietnam
fred downs will be back with us and tren
van ka
to talk about
their experiences in vietnam fred downs
with us all day long
over the memorial day weekend
who fred downs who was in the united
states army has written several books on
his experience in vietnam
we'll be back to
bring us up to date on what's been going
on since april and then of course plenty
of open phones
on thursday
we take more of a look at the economics
of that part of the world james clad who
is an associate
at the carnegie endowment and a former
journalist who wrote for dow jones
publications among others and has lived
over in that part of the world and
he's originally a new zealand citizen
and now back here in the united states
he's been with the carnegie endowment
for a year but
talks through the economics of that part
of the world including singapore
and korea
china
thailand cambodia and of course vietnam
open phones for the day other guests and
finally to wrap things up on friday
the
trip of the senate pow mia affairs
committee their arrival in hanoi their
tour of the army museum
the hanoi prison tour that
they took while they were there back in
april and finally
a couple of hours once again going to
the mekong delta
john kerry senator bob smith returning
to
vietnam
and parts of the country where they
actually were stationed
during the vietnam war especially john
kerry who was down in the mekong delta
on the river patrols and stationed at
the fuqua island base
that the americans used to maintain
there and you'll get to go back and see
it once again in case you missed it
back
on our
30-hour special over memorial day that's
by the way the continental hotel there
in the background and the american
embassy
there right below that uh
the top of your picture there that's the
famous helipad where the helicopter left
back in april of 1975 with the last
americans stationed there at the embassy
in vietnam
and here in our studio kathy murphy who
is responsible for among other things
the viewer services
and in particular
during that time period back on memorial
day you heard from a lot of people or we
heard from a lot of people out there off
our viewer response line
and mail and other ways what did you do
in order to keep our viewers involved
and so we could hear feedback from them
well going into it we knew that
our viewers tended to be vocal about
vietnam and we knew this because
whenever there were house or senate
hearings about vietnam we would get more
calls than usual wanting to find out
were we going to cover the hearings or
if if we were when they'd be on and so
forth so going into the vietnam weekend
memorial day
we were a little concerned that we were
airing such a concentrated number of
programming hours about one topic and it
was a holiday weekend we wouldn't have
people manning the phones on saturday or
sunday or monday so we decided to set up
a comment line and
not really knowing what the response
would be and we were very pleased we had
over 3 000 calls to the comment line and
what would people
do when they call that line well we had
it set up so that someone you'd have up
to 30 seconds and basically when you
called a viewer would either
be able to register whether they liked
or disliked the programming and then
they were able to to leave comments and
overwhelmingly the response was that the
viewers liked the vietnam coverage and
then it was a kind of a across the board
their responses uh lots of people
actually i think a third of the callers
to the comment line were veterans
majority of the calls were men
and there are lots of lots of veterans
who hadn't really thought that much
about vietnam since they've been gone it
they enjoyed they said they enjoyed
seeing some of the video
people there were college students who
hadn't really studied that much and were
able to see
just
a lot of it and get a lot a lot of
information about vietnam if
that percentage roughly how what was the
percentage of people that didn't like
the special
oh it was under eight percent and at
least the ones that called right uh and
when they didn't like it what were they
most often unhappy about
uh there some were angry angry veterans
you might say that
just didn't like the attention that we
were giving to vietnam
and
just
that that's probably most of it but more
more of the response tended to be people
who really enjoyed the programming now
during this week you're going you've
you've
come up with a synopsis or at least
video i mean audio voices of what you
heard back in april or back in may uh
how does this work uh what we tried to
do is just uh
we wanted to give other viewers the
opportunity to hear some of the comments
that that we got in and we are not doing
a comment line this time around because
we have people manning our phones during
the day as we do normal
weekdays so that if viewers have
comments they can write to us at the
c-span address or they could call us
it's it's interesting the reason that we
are re-airing
and adding some new programming about
vietnam now has a lot to do with the
response we received over memorial day
because it was just there was it seemed
to be a tremendous interest in seeing
elements
someone who may have tuned in on the
last day missed the first three days and
so that's that's kind of what we're
doing now and another thing i know
because i've looked at the schedule for
the week a number of you pointed out
where we might have had a lack of
balance in some of the views and we've
tried to compensate for that this time
around so there will be people as you
see during the week who fill in those
gaps that we may not have heard from
back there
over memorial day weekend
let's uh
look at uh what is i'm not sure how long
this is but it's a brief two three
minutes of hearing your response from
what you saw
vietnam revisited back over memorial day
weekend
yes my stepmother came from vietnam six
years ago she's a vietnamese and she
told me there are people being
uh prisoners over there if you know the
asian mind they do not want to lose
honor or lose faith and so therefore
when our people go in there to
investigate it's going to be well
prepared ahead of time
that um they're not going to find
anything well i've enjoyed your program
and i think we still need to be very
suspicious uh cautious about
vietnamese uh it's not beyond then even
now i think to
to kill whatever americans they
have in captivity i guess uh i have seen
a c span
a whole bunch of lying about the
information about the mia
and the communist party that they have a
lot of lying they cover up everything
that all the information about bow and
mia even the remains i think is the best
way that you have to get in touch with
other people because the rebound they
keep a lot of information and they get a
lot of remains
i'm a vietnam vet from georgia
it appears the senators as well as fred
uh
have been hoodwinked by the vietnamese
again uh
they're just as clever as they always
were why wasn't the uh select committee
allowed more time in vietnam
that's all i'd like to know
they seem to be uh pushed
they don't get in-depth information yes
i'd like to know if there's any plans
anywhere in the government
uh as is there a budget and uh how many
men it would take and how much resources
it would take to go in
and finally resolve this this issue
how many men would it take to scour all
of vietnam and the whole
what would it take
the only way we're ever going to find
out the truth is to send an undercover
delta squad or special forces team
into vietnam we're not going to find out
the truth from the vietnamese official
kathy murphy these uh segments are
produced by beth glatton and john uh
batzler uh what again did we just see so
and we're gonna see more of that as the
week goes on right what what you were
watching a video from vietnam listening
to viewer comments that came in during
the the weekend memorial day weekend on
the viewer comment line and what beth
tried to do is just provide a cross
section of some of the comments that we
received
i mentioned that we aren't we don't have
a comment line during this week but the
call-in segments really are the viewers
opportunity to give additional
information
provide that balance if they think that
there's some things that we're talking
about that uh that they don't agree with
or or what have you so there's there's
really a lot of opportunity during the
programming for viewers to comment now
are you selling tapes again last time
you sold tapes uh the whole thing right
what we did was something different with
our tapes the last time
we had a special deal where we were
selling the entire package 35 hours of
programming for 250 dollars we're doing
the same thing this time i think this
time our total programming hours is 29
and for 225 dollars if someone wants to
get a vhs copy of the entire
span of programming they can do that and
if they just want to call our office or
write to us we can work out
how you actually do that the response it
was interesting we tended to get
people who were buying tapes
veterans groups that wanted to have
meetings and share some of the video
even a veterans hospital ordered the the
tapes and there's just a tremendous
interest in
going back and looking and listening to
some of the programming that we had on
for people that hear that rather
whopping 225 dollars do you make money
on this no we actually are losing money
and it's so
right for people who are used to going
to the local video store and buying a
tape it seems expensive but what we have
here is a one-person dubbing operation
it's more or less we make dubs custom as
the orders come in and so it's not a
money-making venture at all kathy murphy
is head of our viewer services
department and uh i'm sure if you have
any other questions that uh might be
confusing over this week that you can
call her at that at our main number or
one of the people that works with her by
the way in just a few moments we're
going to have the lady that wrote this
book katie kelly many of you have seen
her on nbc television in a few years ago
at the today show where she was a critic
of movies and she wrote about her year
in vietnam and saigon teaching american
children
english
but for the moment
here's some video taken back in april of
andong market
in vietnam
[Music]
hey
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i am
um
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
okay
[Applause]
huh
okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
tv
[Applause]
this is a new market in saigon ho chi
minh city called the on dong market and
as far as i know and katie kelly is with
us now she can tell us differently that
this may be the only market in our only
place in vietnam where there's an actual
escalator and you use there's a
in order to get up to this floor you
have to write an escalator when you see
these shots of uh
saigon
after
how long you've been away from there uh
a year and a half
i got back uh last year ago february
what do you think i get a little
nostalgic
seeing the people and seeing uh seeing
some of the sights especially when you
get out out out and about in in saigon
all right here's the book it's called a
year in
in saigon
and right on the cover is a picture of
katie kelly
what in the world were you doing over
there for a year
well believe it or not i was teaching
english i had
been a schoolteacher back in the 60s and
i remembered that i had done that and
loved it very much
and
decided that was the only thing i could
do what's the time frame that you were
there i was there most of 1990 and then
thought i was finished with it and
had to go back one more time and ended
up coming back home in february of 1991.
what led you to go there in the first
place and what were you doing right
before you left well i'd go on there on
vacation
and i have kind of a reputation among
friends and family of taking kind of
what they consider them weird i consider
them exotic vacations and because i love
to travel
and um
nbc sort of bankrolled all these these
trips with this high salary they've been
paying me all those years
and so i've been checking my way through
the world you know mali and tibet and
china and russia and new guinea and in a
sense vietnam was just another
another checkpoint on the travel list
until i got there and oh my god
1988 1988 you were doing what full-time
for a living i was a full-time
entertainment critic
for
nbc in new york loving it thinking i'd
spend
another few years there
and very happy
at my job the best job i've ever had and
certainly that i think the best job
anybody could have i was one of only
three or four people in new york city
doing that as i tell people i mean i got
paid to sit around
i got paid to sit around at the movies
and sit around at broadway open nights
and sit around watching television and
you can't get much better than that
as they say no heavy lifting
and
as i said i uh this this
started out very innocently just as a
vacation and
i flew from bangkok into hanoi and
worked my way south
took a couple weeks to get south from
hanoi to saigon
and
was in saigon and one day and i was
actually trying to i was walking down
the street
trying to do two things at once
which as some people can tell you was
quite dangerous i was trying to walk
and load my camera
and i got the film in and i looked up
and got completely
disoriented
i knew that i was in saigon but i saw
this american face in front of me this
teenager
i mean she
looked like a
kid on her way to the mall or
cheerleading practice or something and
it was just one of those
moments of revelation this was an
amerasian
and oh my god i forgot about them
and i i spent probably another couple
weeks in and around saigon her name was
kim just
turned out to be a fabulous girl and it
turns out her mother and i are now
very good friends
but that that led me to notice that at
that point
saigon was absolutely carpeted with
admirations now there's a picture of kim
on the screen oh yeah who's she with cam
is one of the lucky ones that's her
father here in the united states
ron was a gi
in vietnam
and did not know when he left when his
tour of duty was over that his
girlfriend was pregnant
and
got back to the states and realized she
was heard she was pregnant and that
she'd had a daughter and by that time
chaos had broken out
in
vietnam oh that's my friend chow and his
mother has nothing to do with kim and
her father anyway to get back to
to ron
he went back as soon as he could which
was probably 86 or 87
and walked the streets of saigon
armed with nothing but a birth date
in the name of his daughter
and walk the streets of saigon until he
found her
and then it took another i think five
years
to get her out but that's one of the
happier one of the happiest stories
and their fathers they're in
fayetteville north carolina
and she's going to school
and we hope to get together real soon
again
she's she's she's doing marvelously you
do say in your book though and you write
a lot about this that if i remember
correctly that her mother was quite
distraught after she left
her mother had another amerasian
daughter a black amerasian daughter
and
when they all went to register
to get permission from the vietnamese
and then from the americans
to leave vietnam there's kim and her
mother nyet
kim and her mother were given
permission but the other admiration was
not given permission yet's other
daughter
because the vietnamese officials
proclaimed her to be mentally [ __ ]
and
new yet had a terrible choice
either keep everybody in vietnam or send
kim out
first
to be reunited with her father while he
had stayed and tried to push through
some paperwork on her other daughter
and
she made the kind of sacrifice that
many vietnamese
mothers of americans were constantly
being called on to make she let kim go
and stayed behind in saigon
we're getting a little bit ahead of the
story you and you were talking earlier
about 1988 you had the camera you saw
the amerasian in front of you
how long were you in saigon in 88 just a
couple of weeks
but that was enough you could not you
simply could not escape
seeing amerasians all over saigon there
were just there were thousands of them
the blonde
blue-eyed girl selling cigarettes up by
the cathedral the
kids who lived american kids who were
living
in a park behind the cathedral so many
american
teenagers
were living in that park behind the
catholic cathedral in downtown saigon
they actually called it amerasian park
and when i walked into that park
and saw
what
were essentially hundreds of american
kids
that might have been the moment
that the seed was planted for me i
couldn't leave that that day i mean i
just stayed in the park that whole day
with those kids
um talking to them some of them had
learned a little english that their
mothers
had had taught them
and
i was i was appalled at the number of
kids there
and i was appalled at myself for having
forgotten that of course there would
have been american kids in that country
now you came back
to uh your job at nbc oh yeah but you
know okay so fine good i was appalled
but i came back to this
fabulous job in my la di da lifestyle
and i thought that was it
i really honestly in all innocence
thought that that was the end of the
story that i'd bore all my friends with
my slides and
that was it
but it wasn't
i simply could not stop thinking about
these kids
and it finally occurred to me that
well maybe i should do something but
with the embargo
there are no none of those traditional
agencies that would have been there or
were there before
red cross and save the children and
pearl buck and
catholics orphanages and what have you
they're not there so i you know i
couldn't do the i couldn't take the easy
way out i couldn't write a check and and
send it off to somebody
and the more i thought about it the more
i thought well
i have to personally
go do something
and
the only other thing i can do besides
review movies is teach school
and i had seen in just in the short time
that i was there
i had seen how important it was
to a lot of these kids to learn how to
speak
english and when i asked them about this
they they it was very simple that was
the language
of their fathers
and this was the language they wanted to
learn
so that all kind of made a great deal of
sense to me
a lot more to talk about you're going to
be with us all afternoon let's look at
some of the pictures of some of the
other kids and the mothers and
so that the audience and just tell us a
little bit about them so that our
audience can get the flavor
not well this is okay that's the gang um
that just happened to be in the park the
day a photographer uh
took a picture
and uh you got a granddaughter there in
there yeah some man has a granddaughter
this is a this is ciao pearl when he was
a little baby
and his mother
and um taken in in saigon
pearl is now a handsome young man this
is pearl when he's a little bit older
and this is the kid who absolutely hated
the way he looked thought his nose was
too big he's got a very american nose
until one day he came in and said that
someone told him he'd look like bruce
springsteen where is he now he's in
rochester minnesota
he somehow got separated from his mother
and it took another year and a half to
get her out but she's in
rochester minnesota this next picture
you have is the first picture in your
book yeah
this is a young man who calls himself
briner after his american fathers
b-y-n-e-r b-r-y-n-e-r after his american
father's last name
and that
picture as a child he figures he was
about three years old in his little
batman t-shirt if you remember back in
the 60s batman was a big
big tv show now here's a few years later
this is breiner 20 years later
in saigon
oddly enough wearing another batman
t-shirt because that was the year that
the michael keaton batman
came out
this is jim
holding a picture of his american father
and
i i think it's it's time to point out
that i think people have the idea that
all the
american fathers were gis
and that's not quite true most of them
were but
we have to remember that there were a
lot of civilian workers and construction
workers and aid workers and uh jim's
father worked for rmk construction which
was one of the biggest
um private companies that was in
morrison and
where is he now jim well
jim is still stuck in saigon a friend of
mine
vietnam vet called him a couple of weeks
ago
and hopefully he's getting out in
october there were some terrible medical
problems with with one of his sisters
but the other thing i'd like to point
out is that jim's father lived
with jim's vietnamese mother for five
years
so
another
misconception about these relationships
is that they were
one-night stands or
short-term affairs and jim was married
his father was married back in this
married had a wife and two children
another american son named also named
jim and has there been much contact
no contact none have you tried to
contact i've tried to contact him i
can't i had an a i had an address in
in nevada and was unable to find anybody
we'll get back to some of these photos
as the afternoon goes on
you quit your job your your high-paying
job at nbc oh
quit my job without a moment's
hesitation although
i'm you have to understand i'm very
middle class and so i just didn't want
to walk away from it so i negotiated my
way out of a contract
and it took about six months to
negotiate my way out of the contract but
i did i
i didn't want to leave any bad feelings
at nbc when
i started in a probably about july of
1989. and you left first of the year i
left the first year
left nbc the end december of that year
you're not married uh divorced but you
had no nobody but your cats to worry
about i just had my cats to worry about
and believe me that was the tough part
oh laying in all that cat food and all
that kitty litter i thought the floor of
the kitchen was going to collapse
hundreds of pounds of cat litter i still
have an apartment in new york still have
my house yeah all right
when
what was arranged for you when you went
back in
january of 1990 well as i said i'm very
middle class so i wasn't just going to
quit this job and go over there knowing
that there was nothing over there
and i had heard about a halfway house
that an american a vietnam vet
had set up just basically to to shelter
these kids and i thought well gee this
is great so i contacted him and said hey
look why can't i just slip into your
program and teach english
and he said hey swell so i
got shoehorned into or thought i was
getting shoehorned into his program
well
you've heard of luck of the irish brian
uh i get over there and there is no
halfway house
gone gone closed down
boom don't even ask any questions i was
told
so i didn't
so i got to wander around for about
three or four days feeling real sorry
for myself as you're talking let's roll
some videotape of actual landing over in
tonsina
airport quite different i think than
landing say in 1968.
so i got to i got to wander around as i
said and feel real sorry for myself
because i had no place to go
and
then
an amerasian kid named raymond
suggested that i try something called
the amerasian transit center
and you're going to be having some some
tape on that later on
so i tried that that lasted for a few
days and then that was closed down
and essentially uh what happened was jim
the
kid we saw holding the picture of his
father
came up with the perfect solution
but i would just go talk to his mother
and
teach school in his house so that's hold
on just let me tell the audience that we
were looking as a take-off from hanoi uh
this is on a trip that we took from
hanoi down to saigon this is some of the
landmass between hanoi and saigon and as
we're watching still see some of the
bomb craters you did we did as a matter
of fact and as we they made them into
fish ponds
as we continue watching this uh be
landing at tonsino in a few moments what
um
so where did you stay over there i
stayed in a in a real sleazy hotel
real sleepy real sleazy
shared the top floor with um
two other well i didn't share the room
but there were there were three rooms on
the top floor which we shared with um
an extended family of bats
which had occupied the hallway i get up
every animal bats animal bats
i it
you know that as as twilight falls
saigon was probably once a very
indescribably beautiful city parts of it
are still quite pretty
but as twilight falls
and the sun begins to set over the
saigon river the swallows come in and
start flying around in downtown saigon
you
sit up on the terrace bar at the rex
hotel and have your iced coffee or your
cold beer and you see the swallows and
it's really it's quite lovely and quite
beautiful you see the sun
turn the sky all shades of pink and
violet and lavender and set over the
saigon river and i just oh i would just
get poetically carried away by all of
this
and i went into the hotel
the first night and i was climbing the
three flight three wooden flights to the
top
and i got to the top floor and i thought
look look at these
beautiful romantic poetic swallows
flitting around my head
gee
i didn't know they had webbed feet
gosh
i didn't know swallows stuck to the wall
well they were bats
i almost lost my mind
what you're seeing on the screen
is the
arrival in tanzania oh there's the
saigon river right saigon river the
airfield
um
taken back in april on c-span's trip
there
katie kelly when was your last time in
vietnam uh february 1991.
so this was since you had been yeah
and being in april do you remember what
the weather was like then oh it's hot
you talk about that a lot in your
building oh well i see you know i'm i
keep referring to the back back to the
fact that i'm irish anything over 55
degrees is hot for us
and i i was
i was doing okay i thought because i
cannot translate fahrenheit to celsius
or vice versa until someday one day
somebody translated the temperature and
i thought i was going to melt right on
the street it was something like 110
degrees in saigon
with humidity
we're going to open our phones up for
katy kelly and the numbers will be on
the screen in a moment or two
six
202
eight
two five two five i believe we'll see
the numbers in a second two oh two seven
eight three two seven two seven
if you live on the eastern in the east
and central time zone
that's the first number there on top and
then on the bottom it's the number for
the mountain pacific time zone watching
a landing what it looks like today
see some of the condensation on the
window landing in saigon or ho chi minh
city
did you ever get used to calling it
saigon or ho chi minh city or did you
change it well everybody refers to it as
saigon and so i just called it saigon
and you were there for a year living in
this
in this sleazy fleabag hotel what did it
cost you a night ten dollars a night
ten dollars ten dollars a night they
couldn't give you a deal cheap at any
price
what do you get for ten dollars a night
you i got a huge room with tile floors
two beds
with
rather assertive mattresses
a paddle fan
two chairs covered in what appeared to
be
bright yellow linoleum
a flush toilet
which actually did work and um
a hand shower
and um i
i just figured i was lucky to get cold
water in it for about six months
realized i could have asked for hot
water but hey
so sue me do you have a phone
no are you kidding
although they did install one a little
bit later on
and it was a show phone
it didn't work i could i could call down
and have long loud conversations with
the front desk but
then a few weeks after that they they
did figure out how to get it to work
what's your overall impression this is a
terrible question of the vietnamese
well i'll let me this let me tell you
the thing that surprised me
the first time i went and as i said i i
came in by way of hanoi and i'd been to
other communist countries
i was not prepared
for the friendliness of the vietnamese
people by the way you write about
the fact that so many people go to the
airport it's just it's one of the
biggest social events in saigon is going
to the airport and either watching
people come in or watching people
leave
and i i and i say in my book well we
didn't have an airport i was born and
raised in nebraska and we didn't have an
airport
we just stand on the lawn and watch the
planes go over they never landed at
least in saigon they land and take off
we stand there and watch the planes cool
you were commenting and i interrupted
we're gonna have to take a call in just
a second about the vietnamese people
at how friendly they were and how much
and again let's separate the people from
the government how much the people
truly like americans
and remember all the good things that
the americans did for them i mean they
would come up on the street and
just ordinary people and recall
incidents of
you know veterans setting up clinics or
veterans coming to visit orphanages or
throwing christmas parties for the kids
and
they remember all the all the kindnesses
of the american people
our guest is katie kelly she's going to
help us get through this first day which
is about life in vietnam and pow mia
issues tomorrow meaning tuesday here's
what her book looks like
i gave up my glitzy job in television to
have the time of my life teaching
amerasian kids in vietnam a year in
saigon is the name of the book how long
has it been in the bookstores i saw it
by the way you'd be very happy in our
mall where i live great over the weekend
great and you actually bought it display
i've had it for a while and it was
displayed several in the in the front
window all right it's been on a couple
months now how's it doing i think pretty
well
and it costs if you buy it full price 22
bucks isn't that obnoxious isn't that
terrible i'm getting some pretty good
feedback from
from a lot of people 22 dollars in
vietnam if you worked there and lived
there would go for how long would that
cover that's two months practically
west point nebraska go ahead please oh
my gosh yes katie
katie this is gwen lindbergh oh hi gwen
how are you and i guess
my pr um
i'm hearing two people
just turn your television set down
you're getting the feedback all right uh
my question would be how can we help uh
is there an agency that we can
help with i went to vietnam in 88 also
right a group of journalists journalists
from nebraska right i remember that but
i i guess i would just like to know
where do you think we could put our
money or our time or efforts
before we lose our caller where
where do where is west point nebraska in
northeast nebraska above omaha and
lincoln about 60 miles katie kelly's
from nebraska that's where you know this
is i know exactly where west point is
west point's what about uh 60 miles from
johnny carson excuse me norfolk
hey thanks for calling
well there are there are a lot of of
humanitarian efforts going on in vietnam
that vietnam vets have put together
but quite honestly and quite selfishly i
you know one one way to start is to
start at home and find some agencies
that are working with amerasians
in america
there are a lot of amerasians in lincoln
nebraska for example they come through
catholic charities or lutheran family
service or church world service most of
the mainstream religions
are sponsored are acting as sort of
group sponsors for the amerasians
wheelersburg ohio for katie kelly go
ahead please yes uh i just wanted to
mention that i thought that
mrs kelly was a miss kelly is very very
wise lady
and actually through her trip and her
journey
you know in the year that she spent
there
it's just real refreshing i'm latin
american i'm mexican-american
and it's just so healthy to see that
people are going to other parts of the
country and experiencing that
that type of response have you have you
read contrary to the political things
that go on in the united states have you
read her book
no but i would love to give her my
address so my wife and i could put a you
know
could send an i mean
put us on her put her on our mastercard
and i'd love to get that particular book
okay thanks uh the best thing i think
would be just for you to check with your
bookstore yeah yeah we're looking at the
saigon river
uh ho chi minh city uh did you spend any
time on that river
not too much
but you know it certainly surrounds the
city and it's certainly a centerpiece of
the city i know we could a lot the kids
and i go down there a lot and
sit and drink coke and have english
lessons down there taught english in a
lot of strange places how many children
did you teach over the year well a few
hundred out of the transit center for
those few days that i was out there but
um we're going to see the transit center
before the afternoon and jim's house i'd
say we probably couldn't pack in more
than 25 or 30. every day
trying to do it every day yeah and moms
a lot of moms came a lot of sisters came
so you know we didn't turn anybody away
for katie kelly we go to marion iowa go
ahead please yeah my name is jonathan
robinson i spent about 18 months in a
place called tui vietnam which is
probably nothing but a sand dune
in about 18 months at a place called
clark air force base which is nothing
but ashy but i understand now
and you know i think that experience in
vietnam has stopped us from doing the
things we need to do in the horn of
africa and sudan
i think it has stopped us from doing
what we need to do in yugoslavia which
is just
insanity i mean there's sometimes you
need to use
military force
but i think one of the things that
really stops us is our
you know kind of cultural savagery we
are intolerant
for the most part of other cultures and
i think if we could put that behind us
that would make it a little bit easier
for us to deal with problems we don't
need to deal with because the problems
of vietnam yugoslavia and czechoslovakia
and the things in the horn of africa are
things that we're going to have to deal
with now and i think we need to get a
president that's able to deal with this
because i don't think george bush is
able to do that all right sir um
what about his point of view about
vietnam impacting the way we deal with
the rest of the world i think vietnam
was was one of those
forces in all our lives that will just
never leave us we're looking by the way
at saigon from the roof of the there's
our famous rex hotel i actually i
actually taught some of my classes
on that
rooftop that's the rooftop terrace and
under that circular thing in the back is
a very nice place to sit and listen to
caged birds sing and watch when you read
your book you refer to that rooftop many
times many times many times it was a
haven and you could take these american
kids up there yes and as long as they
were with me
they could come up there you even talk
about going into the
bathroom of the rex hotel and splashing
water on you is it oh i got i just got
so overheated one day we we'd come from
lunch and they oh the rex hotel was
fabulous i couldn't afford it it was 40
a night i still couldn't afford it but
they had great
porcelain flush toilets oh that's
the cathedral in in saigon and didn't
you say the american park is right
behind right behind those double spires
is amerasian park is the catholic
cathedral there in saigon open for use
yes and it has been open
it was opened during the war and since
the war
[Music]
and still has still has the
bomb guards or
grenade guards on the outside of the
windows and you describe inside that
there is a neon
well it looks very much like st
michael's catholic church in albany
nebraska which is where i grew up and
it's it's red brick and it's very
european
and you go in and it has that old
churchy smell of incense and it's dark
and it's quiet and
i walked in and
thought gosh this is just like home and
then i looked up on the altar
and there's a neon cross
and then the halo circling the blessed
virgin mary's head
is yellow neon that's the continental
hotel oh yeah now where was it graham
greene wrote his book well you they've
they've enclosed it but there was an
open air um
terrace
bar
that they used to call the continental
shelf that was a book quiet american he
wrote there yeah yeah and that was
rather notorious during the war because
they used to lob
hand grenades the vietcong used to run
by motorcycles and a lot of hand
grenades in there but they've closed it
in and it's now a real high-class uh
pizza parlor
american embassy
oh yeah do you spend any time around
that there's that helicopter deck i
walked over there and
it's all
it's all closed up
at least there was a big padlock on the
door
and leaves blowing all over and there
were some chickens pecking in the yard
it's kind of a sad end for probably one
of the ugliest buildings in town once
again a skyline view of ho chi minh city
or saigon new orleans louisiana you're
on the line go ahead please yeah this is
uh rick koch fell from
new orleans i spent three tours there in
retired air force
i'm wondering how much was left
to
thompson newt when the
when charlie left
thanks how much
was left there's only
one runway operating right now
out of i don't know how many um
they've added on they've added on to the
terminal
but it was it was very eerie
coming into tonsinode
because if you you know remembering uh
newsreel footage i mean that was one of
the busiest airports
air bases airports in the world in the
late 60s and the early 70s
and it's dead quiet now but then looking
over and seeing
helicopters and warplanes and you know a
lot of the materiel is still and the
revetments are still there we're talking
with katie kelly you're looking at ho
chi minh city as recorded back in april
on our trip there to among other things
follow the mia pow story which you'll
see later on in the week mostly uh
tomorrow on tuesday we'll talk with
senator kerry and others and officials
of the bush administration
looking at an area of town that you
spent a lot of time
when you read your book you read a lot
about the rex hotel the caravel the
continental the cathedral yeah the shot
before this was taken from the deck of
the uh the caravel and if you if they
had panned just a little bit further
left you would have seen the fabulous
kim doe hotel kemdo hotel you recommend
it for anybody going to vietnam oh sure
we had a lot of fun there a lot of good
a lot of good people stay there
i'll bet it's more than ten dollars a
night what about miss congeniality oh
bless her heart oh she was boy she kept
those troops in line who was she she was
the receptionist there were there were
actually two hotels and believe it or
not i was in the better half she would
not even let me go to the back half you
kind of had to go through a kitchen and
around
and then there was another hotel in the
back
and it had it had elevators
well i mean that appealed to me i had to
go up these three wooden fire trap
flights to get to my
bad infested room
and she wouldn't let me go back there
they reserved that for
vietnamese coming in from the
countryside and she kept saying well
it's just for peasants you don't want
that oh she was tough minneapolis
minnesota you're next
yeah this is charles dwight
hi
yeah uh katie i was exactly uh i was
over in vietnam in 1967 and i was a
combat photographer over there
and i've got a number of slides from 67
of the people in the countryside and
and i'm just i'm getting
teary-eyed just watching oh i'll bet you
are and it's a beautiful country isn't
it oh it's gorgeous i mean it's the
people over there
and the is the did you get to go to the
saigon or to the zoo at all
yeah but
uh it's it's pretty sad now is it yeah i
remember it it was just uh one of the
most beautiful zoos i've ever been in in
the world well the zoo part of it isn't
so good now obviously because i mean the
poverty in that country now but the the
little park-like area around it is still
there oh it is oh oh yeah and people are
still out in those funny little paddle
boats that i don't know look like ducks
and fishes and everything and it's it's
just a place to go on sunday that part
of it is still wonderful oh that is so
oh i just i think about that and i think
about you know
part of my
thing is i've over the years i've had
you know problems with the with
post-traumatic stress and so on and i
keep remembering back that the children
that were over there and how they were
treated and orphan agents and so on and
i think maybe
we didn't do enough or we're still not
doing enough and we've got to do more
for these these kids over there thanks
minneapolis thanks
you're looking at uh
actually the drive
uh
through saigon
coming up on that what was used to be
called tudo street
and it's called
can you remember donald john coyster
right now and uh you spent time up and
down there but it's a lot different than
it was during the war until well oh it
was notorious during the war this is
where all the bars and the brothels were
and it was tudo street
and i mean that street was just humming
it's there's the continental on the left
and it runs from the catholic cathedral
straight down to the saigon river the
continental is on the left the caraval
is on the left across the street the
girl restaurant which was another one of
my hangouts is on the right g-i-v-r-a-l
g-roll it's an old french restaurant and
the communists
took it over
in 1975 but they allowed some of the old
retainers and old waiters to stay
stay on in about 10 minutes we're going
to
show you the
uh amerasian transit center
uh that we visited uh back in april but
for the moment we have a call from
sacramento california as we look at
trudeau street go ahead please hi brian
i can't believe i've gotten through let
alone on your show i enjoy you so much
thank you welcome ah thank you um i'm
nervous um katie i just wanted to tell
you that i really appreciate what you're
saying
and i'm too i am also trying to write a
book about vietnam
i'm in contact with as many vietnam vets
as i can possibly be
my husba my uncle i'm sorry was a career
marine and served two and a half tours
in vietnam two years two of his tours he
gave me the years the other one he
refuses to tell me
the point of my book is that
vietnam was so horrendous it it cost the
lives not only of the people that died
but look at the effect it's had on the
people still living
and i it seems that we have not really
learned the lesson of vietnam
which is how not to go to war
how not to have to point a gun to make a
point
and i just was wondering if you felt
there was any validity to even
going forth with this book because there
are a lot of people that are saying
there are already so many books out
about vietnam and it just seems like
this just hasn't come out yet thanks
yeah i'm um i'm an associate member of
the vietnam vets veterans of america and
i was talking to them one night and
i mean it's just it's very this is you
know 20 25 years later this these are
very
emotional
issues and i think i got very
teary-eyed and one and then apologetic i
mean i wasn't a vietnam veteran i wasn't
there
and one of the veterans just grabbed my
hand and he said you know katie we're
all
veterans of that war
and that's
that put it into perspective for me and
for what this woman was saying how hard
was it to get your book published it
wasn't really all that difficult had you
talked to a publisher before you went
there no and again
it was
it honest to god never entered my mind
but i got back and i realized that that
there was a story here that really
hadn't been told
because these were really
i have this terrible nightmare vision
of that
last
evacuation helicopter leaving the roof
of the saigon embassy with the last
american
and there were
tens of thousands of americans that we
left behind and they were babies
you say in your book there are 30 000
american admirations left behind that's
an estimate i think there are more how
many of those have been moved over here
i think the last figure i saw was 12
000.
now see the official the original
official estimate was ten thousand
well already they're they're over that
they hope to get them out by the end of
next year
and we'll see that uh transit center
what is the transit center just quickly
well it was built as a transit center so
when the amerasians who come from the
countryside come into saigon on their
way out they have a place to stay and
just open though it opened about the
time i got there
january of 90. we'll see that in about
eight minutes pinebrook new jersey go
ahead please yes good afternoon hi
uh do the people there
uh talk differently since
the year what usr ussr has
disbanded or do they have
or it seems to have just as much
influence and also whether
the people there still would like to
leave thanks
i had the feeling that communism was
pretty much in dis
disregard disrepute and disrepair we're
looking even when i was on the screen
while you're talking by the way
you know it's certainly still a
communist country and certainly there
are a lot of hardliners and they
certainly get their way in many in many
areas
but um i its days are certainly i feel
are certainly numbered and the people
seem to especially in the south and
especially in saigon have so little
respect and regard for
for communism what's the difference in
what you see in the south and what you
see here in the north the contrast
between the north and the south and
particularly hanoi and saigon
it it just reminds you it's still two
countries
it's two countries economically
socially culturally politically
the north is much poorer
than the south
the south
had an entrepreneurial spirit that
was able to to take root and last for
years
they
they know how to make money
and and one of the most shocking things
was to see the reaction of russians who
would come over there you know there's
no food in russia nothing to buy
and there's food all over the place and
they sell it and they make it and they
there are things in the market
and
i mean this is their
little shopkeeper
spirit you say the vietnamese do not
like russians oh god no they hate them
what's the reason well the russians were
never
i mean they explained it to me in very
simplistic terms that they just weren't
nice people
they were never nice to the to the
vietnamese people and besides they had
no money
but they you know oh aren't they great
but see this was their way of
contrasting
the vietnamese contrasting the
difference between americans and
russians
that you know americans come and we sit
down we talk to them and we tell them
their babies are cute and
buy them a beer buy them a coffee or
something and the russians kind of kick
them out of the off the sidewalk it's
the metropole hotel you were looking at
there which is the
was it like the democracy hotel where
you stayed
i thought that was another actually that
one the democracy was even worse than
the kim doe
it had a bathtub but i kept falling out
of it actually the metropole when you
were there in hanoi was not rebuilt like
it is now no it was it was a tonight you
paid a hundred dollars a night yeah but
that's oh my but you know that's one of
those famous old
french
villa hotels 40 owned by the pullman
company and the rest by the vietnamese
onalaska wisconsin thank you for waiting
yes my name is gary griniwalt i'm a
vietnam veteran retired navy
i think it's very admirable here what
katie has been doing
there in the philippines where i spent
quite a few years of my military career
they have the philippine refugee center
at marong bataan
there in marong
there are quite a few amerasians
and i have spent considerable time there
with them during my time in the
philippines
but i'm also wondering here
are we doing anything at all
for the filipino
amerasians
a lot of these people would like to come
to the united states also and i find
that uh they're not getting out
well the diff i mean this brings up a
very good point there are we have been
creating amerasians throughout asia
in korea okinawa thailand and especially
in the philippines
but the difference
between those amerasians and the
vietnamese amerasians
was that
oh god aren't they cute i love those
kids the vietnamese amerasians
grew up under communism
and so that i think gave a
you know a special
spin
if you will to to anyone's feelings
about the vietnamese admirations he
meant he mentioned the philippines and
you write about the orderly departure
program moving
people out of vietnam the amerasians to
the philippines yeah can you explain the
orderly departure program the orderly
departure program is is
run by the state department and the
amerasian homecoming act which
congressman bob marasik co-sponsored
is part of the order
makes the amerasians part of the orderly
departure program and and simplified if
you want to use that word they're
getting out of vietnam
and when they are finally processed
between the two
bureaucracies of vietnam and america
they go to
prpc uh philippine refugee
processing center
and spent six months there
ostensibly to learn english and have a
little cultural orientation
this is what katie kelly's book looks
like for those of you who are interested
in learning more about her year in
vietnam she's going to be with us for
most of the day we're repeating at your
request
our vietnam revisits visited special
from memorial day we go next and we're
going to then
we have time maybe for two quickies uh
orange county california go ahead please
hi i'm pauline with the county of orange
in california
and
i'm one of the vietnamese refugees here
in california i saw your tv program on
here
i um
we um represent the vietnamese here
which is impressed my thank you to you
that you can do helping them the vietnam
and the thing that you do very deeply
touched my heart
i would like to say
um
with the vietnamese here what can we do
to help the vietnamese over there caller
how long have you been here in the
united states um 12 years 12 years and
how did you did you come
from saigon area
um yes so yeah i always grew up in
saigon and how did you get here what was
the reason for coming
um well to my well my dad is one of
those um he's a city council there so we
have to flee to here to them get some
freedom
and um we we
placed by the boat and um
so
we're here in california now and um
it's very
touched my heart that's all the thing
that kelly does for us
okay thanks a lot for calling come on
what is
what what are the you know when you got
back to this country after your
experience and you hadn't you didn't
have your book written and you started
telling your friends about it what did
they think about your whole idea then
of having gone having done this having
done it well
i think that there was a certain point i
think they were actually rather bored
with me because i absolutely couldn't
shut up about it
um
i think to begin with they couldn't
believe that i was going to do it and
then couldn't believe that i'd done it
i think people were fascinated by it and
that was that was one of the
the
reasons that i thought maybe i really
should write this book you said you had
trouble with re-entry
i had a terrible time it was a lot
easier for me to go from new york to
saigon
than to come back from saigon to new
york that was hard all the stuff we have
here
bothered you all the stuff all the
conveniences the ease with which we can
do things
and
i
i really i freaked out for about 24
hours i mean walking into an american
supermarket and seeing what i mean that
is living proof
of what we have
that vietnam certainly doesn't have and
most of the rest of the world doesn't
have last call for this segment from
middletown new york go ahead please oh
hi my name is jack engel i'm a vietnam
veteran and i worked with katie at
channel seven and channel four and uh
yes how are you welcome back to the
world cup thank you how are you i'm
quite well thank you
it's really nice to see uh
someone who has had a very successful
career in new york kind of just kind of
like put it away i don't think many
people realize this that
katie was a very popular television
personality in the new york city market
and
it's just really nice to see somebody
take walk away from an extremely
successful career and to go over to a
place like she did doing what she's
doing
we shed a few tears about admiration
kids one time on the corner 10th avenue
i guess 19th street we did yeah we
remember that ride
and i just wanted to say i'm looking
forward to reading the book i haven't
yet but uh you can be rest assured i'm
running down to barnes and noble right
now oh thank you jack give me a call um
yeah as a matter of fact uh yeah i'd
like to get in touch with you yeah oh
thanks all right listen i won't let
another quality through thanks katie
thank you be good bye-bye
now uh we're going to go to the
we can just kept that one going for a
little while longer we're going to go to
the amerasian center
we were there just for a short period of
time how long did you spend at this
center
i think it probably wasn't any more than
two or three weeks
and he got kicked out yeah
and
no reason
given communists run it yeah oh yeah
americans paid for it we paid for it i
i think we kind of split the cost with
somebody but basically
we'd pay for we paid for it and
they seemed
rather interested and intrigued with the
idea of setting up something an english
program
because
the young people who come in
from
you know dunang or whey are out in the
boonies
and stay there for their final
processing before they get out they
really are sitting around with nothing
to do
and it
it seemed an obvious choice and at first
the the director was a little bit
reluctant and then he relented and and i
got going and he actually had
put up a little bullet in bortney or a
chalkboard and
had some seats arranged
but
it seemed within moments
that was over and i never could
understand why
and if you're dealing with a communist
bureaucracy you'll never you'll never
know why this is vietnam revisited we're
going back to what we showed you on
memorial day updating it a little bit
we'll have bill fleming with us who's
from the state department can tell us
more about the amerasian program from an
official point of view in about 35
minutes katie kelly's agreed to stay
with us all day long down from new york
for the day which we really appreciate
and those of you who haven't seen this
book that we're talking about here's
what it looks like you can find it in
your bookstores and it's all about her
year
in vietnam in the year 1990.
we'll be back in about 35 minutes with
more calls and more discussion
and by the way on friday of this week is
our trip to the mekong delta that those
of you
who missed over memorial day might want
to watch the mia pow committee stop at a
number of bases down there but for the
time being here's the amerasian center
transit center in saigon
can you tell me what this place is
since january 1990
funded by the u.s government
and
we are responsible to provide
the accommodation and food for the
region and relative
to
preparing to leave vietnam under the
homecoming act
of the u.s government this whole
facility you say is paid for by the u.s
government
how how many people are here oh first
i'd like to say about the
capacity
it's about one thousand
and
sometime in high level
we must receive about 1 400 people stay
here stay here at this yeah but now it's
only about 400 people why are there so
few here now
because it depends on the
interview and time
of the us interview
who work here in the city
yeah and so people come here who are
considered amerasians
are they on their way to the united
states yeah
how many of them will stay here or how
long will they stay here oh there are
two kinds of the emulation of the
resident here
the first the admiration who have their
family
they can stay here a short time about 20
days divide two states
first
after interview they come here
and make some physical examination
and then they
come
come back home and the second stage
before they
get their flights
they stay here and wait they apply
including
tuesday
about 20 days
and the second kind
and
they are the emulation often
and harmless
they must stay a long time
maybe about
six months or a year
so
we are responsible also to provide them
some
skill
training program and
educational
what did these people do before this
center was built where did they live
another place sometimes they must
stay on the street you know
because
in that time we have got some
some problem in this program
so
then
we have agreement between the black
german vietnamese government and the u.s
government
we build this center
to provide them the accumulation and
food
yeah
it's very it's really a convenience for
this program
i'm responsible to
handle
the
administration
is a director an american or a
vietnamese vietnamese
do the americans have anything to say
about how the place is run
it's totally up to the vietnamese yes
beyond the
now all of these folks here
consider admirations all these people
that we have here
because they only
come here after interview
how do you decide whether someone is an
amerasian or not i mean what's the oh
mixture of this is the business of the
us interview team
but i know about this matter
it's only
they can decide them on the america the
emulation or not
depends their appearance
and some paper if they have uh they have
got
so it's appearance more than anything
else
very complicated problem
do you have any idea what the total
number of admirations
were from
the american involvement here
i know ali about remember since january
1990 since we opened the center
it's about
20 000 people including admiration and
their relatives
how many of the amerasians are
now the sons and daughters of
the children that were the
responsibility of american fathers in
other words how about the kids here
they're obviously
from the mothers and fathers of uh the
original animals
how many are second generation animals
ah the second generation
i think
there are a lot of second generation
emulation here
because
it matter
it's really better if we opened this
program since
10 or 15 years ago
because in that time
they were the children
it is a long time since
these little folks right here obviously
second generation americans are they all
no
some of them are the vietnamese relative
of the immigration
so these are these young folks are not
considered americans yeah they are or
not
some of them are the second generation
and some of them are the
their father
their sisters
because
the most of the mother of the emigration
gets married with
another vietnamese husband
vietnamese husband do you think that the
americans have done enough for these
people
yeah
have they spent enough money and have
they been concerned enough for of course
their future because most of them are
the victims of the world you know
in the world time
a lot of vietnamese women
must
get married with the
gis for example
and sometimes they are victims
now are there many american
soldiers coming over here
to look for their children still
[Music]
really
i i know about this complicated
situation of the
veteran
because if in this time they can tie
down some
their children but they cannot receive
them
into their family now because the
most of them have got a new family with
other women
american women in their country
very difficult to receive the children
here
how much does it cost
to run the center for a year
how much american dollars come here
every year to run this do you have any
idea
you know what a lot is
yeah you don't know what the figure is
though
how about you know what it cost to
build this facility
[Applause]
more than
500 000 usd
and how long how long did it take to
build it
only five months five months built by
vietnamese
what kind of facilities do you have here
where do they stay and i see that
there's they're doing something here in
the background what are they doing in
this room
so what kind of work are they doing here
does this work or not this is a kind of
skill training program
and we operate each program
only one side vietnamese time because
there's a lot of animation of them to
stay a long time
and so there are some complicated
problems
emulation and the other people around
them are you trying to train people
train people to do jobs
here
how many people work here
the stop
yeah about
50
people
and what kind of training do they have
what kind of are they teachers or are
they
demand
and beauty of the staff here is only
providing
the food and the accommodation for the
regional delivery to stay here
but because we have got a space on kind
of the
evolution they are they often must be a
long time
and they have got a lot of free time
they don't know how to do anything
because
they mustn't do buy them some food for
their life here
and they have got a lot of free time
if there are if they are orphans yeah
and no one claims them
what happens to you
they stay here forever
yeah they can live here for the rest of
their lives
oh you can't um
go downtown to tie down some siblings
no what i mean is how long how what age
do they have to go out and live on the
society do they stay here until they're
18 or is there a certain
no no in other words if you're an orphan
yeah
and no one
takes you into their home can you live
here to a certain age
the most of the orphans live on the
street
on the street now but i'm talking about
the ones that come here yeah can they
stay here for a long time okay
how long
some of them
stay here about one year
then what happens
yeah because where do they go after a
year
it depends on some complicated procedure
from u.s government because that most of
them
are interviewed
by the usd team
but because they are the orphans
they have not any paper
they have only their appearance
and sometimes very difficult to decide
if they are the emulation or not
they can be taken from them okay let's
let's if they are determined to be
amerasians
and they are orphans
what happens to them
in other words where do they go do they
go back to the united states do they
stay here forever do they go out and do
families here in vietnam
see what i'm saying in other words
what happens to them can they stay here
forever
jacqueline helps you again what happens
to uh if they can't go to the united
states
yes in other words
[Music]
if they are denied by the u.s government
to enter the us
it depends it's up on them if they want
to stay here or if they want to leave
the complex complex
at what age do they have to leave the
complex
could they stay here for the rest of
their lives
there is a five year
grace period
with the us government
for their files and if they're not if
they're not considered
if they were denied the first time they
would look at their files again within
the five-year period
again i'm not clear on the objective
though the government our american
government pays for this center
they bring young people in here that
appear to be amarantine
they then try to find out if they in
fact are by interviewing what is the
ultimate goal of the american
interviewer
[Music]
the purpose of this complex is for all
of these kids
[Applause]
and what about these kids can we ask
them whether they want to go to the
united states
can we ask them why they want to go to
the united states
[Music]
oh
what about this lady back here
because she wants to look for her father
in the us and also she has a son and she
wants a better life for him how does she
know that she's an amerasian there's
such a victory
she has a picture of her dad so she
knows who her dad is
she tried to write him and she know
whether or not he would even
support
her mother died a long time ago she was
young and she left a picture with his
name on it but she doesn't know the
address so she's never contacted me
what about you what's your name
[Music]
hello
[Music]
oh
details
so she's trying to get over there using
her brother's
status
what about you two do you want to go to
the united states
[Music]
his brother is amerasian but he's not
is his brother in the united states
no he's not in the united states he's in
this conflict
he lives here
do you consider yourself to be an
american
[Music]
you know who your father is no i don't
know when i'm keeping a picture of my
parents
you have a picture of him yeah and how
long have you been here
nearly two years
two years yeah
have they done a good job with the
facility do you like it here
sometimes
[Music]
has life been difficult for you
yes for me why how old are you by the
i don't way what kindness i bought you
understand my mind
i'm sorry i didn't hear you i don't know
what can i say for you and this time
how old are you how many years i am i
was born in 1917
1970 so i am 22 years old
what chances do you have of going to the
states you know
yeah what do you think your chances are
of going to the united states i think
that is um this is the country my father
so i think
if i go to genetics day as soon as i
must learn english more potentially
and i want to study something at this
day and i love it too much you see you
have a bag there where did you get the
bag it's got the u.s army and u.s navy
and airport something
bad it's bad yes that is offering of my
my friend he's from united states and
now i'm keeping uh his threats
do you know where your father is
i don't know but i don't but i already
do know about his name
jim stewart my father
how about your mother where is she
sorry you know where your mother lives
but i know the name of my mother
and i have to keep a picture
what's your name
my name is
[Music]
how do you know his name is
[Music]
can you tell me who you are and what you
do and why you're here in vietnam
my name is
and
i'm working with unicef i'm the resident
project officer
and we
follow up and monitor all the programs
of unicef in the southern provinces of
vietnam where's your ace
ho chi minh city but the major office in
hanoi how long you've been doing this
in vietnam two and a half years where's
home originally
and what is unicef
united nations children's fund
and it is responsible for women and
children in the
is there any sense of how can you give a
sense how large unicef is how much money
is spent every year on
in vietnam we have quite a large program
from the general resources we have now
8.8 million dollars a year
and we have special funds which we need
around 10 million dollars but we don't
have all that money last year out of 10
million we were able to get only 3
million and this is mainly because of
the embargo so
countries are not willing to give yet
to vietnam
in your name and your organization
michelle jordan human rights project
washington base what's the human rights
project it's a 501c3 uh
foundation i guess
the legal
term for it um we carry delegations
to various places in the world it's my
first trip to vietnam how big an
organization is financially uh small few
hundred thousand dollars a year who pays
for it yeah private contributions and
some foundation
you're based
washington all the time i mean is that
the only place no we have a new
hampshire office portsmouth new
hampshire and
you two know each other before you came
here
we're both lebanese but no we didn't
know each other
through a mutual friend i got abla's
name we brought some pharmaceuticals
into the country and otto helped us get
them in uh pediatric pharmaceuticals
that were contributed to the human
rights project from sharing plow
pharmaceuticals
and uh habla
did some magic and helped us
why are you two here at the admiration
center
actually i was invited to commence in
the center and i think it's a good
opportunity to have a look at it what's
your what's your feelings about what
you've seen
i've heard about emulations and i've
seen them on the street and usually they
leave a tough life they cannot easily
find jobs and
it is
for them they all look forward to
immigrate and find another life
and so it's not easy for them here
what's your reaction
to here
i heard about it before i came here i
knew it wasn't going to be
pleasant and apparently it isn't here
uh we were briefed when we first got
here and we were told that people
come here on their way to the united
states for their interviewing process
and that's a matter of days or weeks but
a lot of the folks we spoke with have
been here for two years
so
pretty sad you mentioned the embargo
what impact do you think the american
embargo trade embargo
on vietnam has had
it has limited funds that can
improve the situation and improve the
lives of women and children
and
as soon as it is lifted most probably
the chances of
money coming in uh having much more
development going in the life will
improve the income of the people will
learn better and then
the situation in general will be much
better
what do you see that you do here that
makes a difference
we have several projects and programs
one is the water program where we are
assisting in having once dug and
providing clean water
and
we have reached 20 so far
by the year
2000 we are hoping to reach
80 percent
and then we have a big
uh health plan
mainly vaccination of all children
control of diarrheal diseases active
respiratory infections which are
some of the child killing diseases
there is malaria and that has helped a
lot and then we have an education we're
developing the curriculum and assisting
the schools but the need is so big and
our funds are really limited so that
will take some time before if it is
it is
done the nutrition in some of the
provinces especially in the central
areas you have very high rates of
nutrition and this is mainly due to the
kind of
diet that they have it
and is is they don't have the protein
and the vegetables so we have one of the
programs where we are encouraging family
gardening where they will have much more
protein raised
vegetables
and so
we hope that will have a better impact
so we choose the families with the many
large children to help them and assist
them how do you see your work
resulting you actually see a benefit
this is a preliminary trip for us um
i had heard a lot
about vietnam from the vietnam veterans
foundation who actually helped do a lot
of the communications for us to to get
us here and they've been working here
for a lot of years and told me a lot and
given me a good education so i feel like
i came in here knowing a lot
i feel as obligated the lifting of the
embargo
is the best humanitarian act that can
happen
between the united states and vietnam
what's your impression otherwise about
vietnam in general how far behind
yep
[Music]
probably not as far behind as it seems
if the embargo was left
i think that opens up a whole new world
you know five years from now if the
embargo is lifted tomorrow
this place won't
won't have water problems it won't have
malnutrition problems a lot of that
stuff goes away
you've lived here for two and a half
years
have your impressions of the place
changed during that time oh it's
changing very rapidly yeah
it's possible that
man will be another bangkok
hello
and people are very hard-working
so given the chance that this place will
be developing very quickly what does it
mean to be another banker
is
these resources are not really
exploited how often do you see america
i see americans they're passing through
their
visitors as consultants as
people who are trying to come and find
out how they can help and what can be
done
in the two and a half years you've been
here what have you
learned that you didn't like about
bothers you about what you see here
a little bit
a lot of lots of bureaucracy
and changing your fools
changing your rules
is there much law
there are rules and here
sometimes they change
and um
and finally you get used to it and you
have to accept it
just like many other
the countries will be clearer and will
invite much more investors
to encourage them to develop the future
we ask you both the general question
about what kind of work you do
how did you get interested in it in the
first place
it's a long story because i have been
there for the past 20 years are you
still a lebanese citizen i'm still a
little mr president and when you first
got into unicef did you have to come to
the united states to the u.n to begin it
all no i started in oman
in 1917
michelle
changing to issue oriented
interest
and i figured instead of
going after or helping elect politicians
who i thought were good on the issues
people are going to get elected you have
to teach them about the issues
who would you work for
for myself um i'm sorry and uh
politicians did you work actually for a
politician before no i helped a lot of
campaigns anybody that we recognize
no need to mention it
is that because this is a non-political
position
how many people work at the
at your foundation um we are
there is no uh
payroll uh anybody who works with us
does it voluntarily i have uh from
members of congress to private sector
people who
do a lot of things for us
travel with us
do all sorts of things paperwork
mailings
thanks
over there
um
oh
bill fleming is the man at the u.s state
department uh who worries about things
like american kids what's your reaction
to this
well i had seen it
uh one time before and it gives a good
view of the kind of the situation you
find at the uh at the amerasian transit
center most of the children
you see there i think the majority of
them are probably not
amerasians they're members of the uh the
families of the americans
but it's uh it gives a view of just what
you would find today if you walked in
yes who's paying for that
the u.s government paid for its
construction was about a half a million
dollars
it was finally opened in early 1990
and we pay now
per capita for each amerasian and family
member
that leaves they get a we give a per
capita payment of the eighty dollars
and there's also a per capita for uh two
other fees twenty seven dollars and
thirty dollars so combined
that every month whoever leaves every
month we provide that amount of money to
the vietnamese to the vietnamese
government right for that purpose that
provides well the one per capita deals
with the administrative costs of the
government and contacting the local
areas and having people registered and
such that the 30 dollar per capita is
meant for paying for travel and the fees
of the americans and their family
members for the paperwork and the 80
per capita is meant strictly for the
american transit center which is the
upkeep and the utilities and such we're
going to chat for about 12 minutes and
have the phones open for you to join us
as we look back at a special that we
first ran over memorial day called
vietnam revisited we took a trip over
there in april meaning a c-span crew of
five and the principal reason was to
follow the mia pow's select committee in
the senate as they
investigate the possibility of living
m.i.a still in vietnam and as the week
goes on tomorrow tuesday will devote a
lot of discussion to that very issue
katie kelly with us for the day
author of this book which is in your
bookstores what was your reaction to
seeing the amerasian center where you
used to teach english for a couple of
weeks well i'll tell you it's probably
one of the best new buildings uh built
in saigon it's fabulous it looks i i
tried to describe it to someone in it
it's somewhere between a midwestern
motel and a singles complex
and it's beautiful it's clean it works
and believe me
light years better than the top floor of
the kim dough hotel
if you've just joined us katie kelly
lived in vietnam in 90 1990 and stayed
at the kimdo hotel for 10 whole dollars
a day 10 a day or was that 10 a night
the thing that frustrated me about the
transit center and it it sounds like
they're
getting a few more programs when i was
there there absolutely was not anything
for these kids to do
and as as the gentleman kept pointing
out when you had the homeless kids and
the orphans coming in they would stay
there upwards of
you know six months a year two years
and to to give them something to do i
think
you know or to try to give them
something to do in the way of either job
training or language training is really
a step in the right direction may as
well give them something to do bill
fleming will those children we saw there
end up in the united states
that's
that's hard to say
many of them have come down
for interviews
perhaps they haven't been interviewed
yet and maybe perhaps they'll be they'll
be rejected
but it's safe to say that a good number
of them will very likely
end up in the united states yes what is
your job at the state department right
now
up until a year ago i was
with the director of the orderly
departure program for the last two years
of my stay in bangkok
and uh that's that's when i was involved
with this since last year i've been in
the office of asian refugee assistance
and the bureau for refugee programs in
the department of state
dealing with uh not so much with the
admissions which involves the amerasians
and the re-education people and the
family reunification but dealing with
assistance to
the refugee refugees still in the camps
in southeast asia those in first asylum
countries and dealing with the the
comprehensive plan of action voluntary
repatriation and all the
difficulties involved with that
he mentioned the orderly departure
program from reading your book you
tangled with him a couple of times when
you lived in vienna a couple of times
why would you tangle with well
it's very complicated over there and
for the amerasian and his or her family
dealing with two bureaucracies the
vietnamese bureaucracy and in a sense
the american bureaucracy that's
difficult enough
but i think the the basic problem is
that
so many records were destroyed
that people are having to go back and
either
find old records or get new records and
there is a lot of shall we say uh
fabrication of documentation and this is
you know the by the amerasians well
nobody
people in in vietnam who want to get out
and i had a friend
who
took i mean they all went in for their
interviews
and it was
an amerasian in her vietnamese husband
and her vietnamese mother
and the ameration was approved
her husband was not approved and her
mother was not approved and so this just
turned the family into a complete
turmoil
they did not believe that the two people
were married
and the reason giving was they thought
that the vietnamese husband was too old
so i mean i just they were just in an
absolute panic you're talking about the
the family the the husband was like 48
and the wife was about 24 23 or 24.
and so they odp had the home odp
approved the amerasian girl did not
approve her husband and did not approve
her mother
so this just tore the family apart but i
wrote mr fleming a number of letters and
uh their case was reopened and they're
all living happily ever after in
hartford connecticut now how many
amerasians are there total
that's
no one knows for sure we know that about
to date almost 80 000 amerasians and
their family members have have come to
the united states and we know that there
are perhaps
20 or 30 thousand
more amerasians and family members still
in vietnam on lists that we have to to
get to
but uh as you might i guess you could
say i mean one american uh
might have an average family of four
people with them so i guess you divide
that by
four divide the 80 by four at the moment
and uh
that'll give you an idea of how many
there are but there may be many still
out in the countryside that have not
been able to access the program you've
been working for the state department
for how long
uh for the department of state itself
since 1980
as a foreign service officer in the
government yes and before that what'd
you do
before that i was with
the u.s agency for international
development which is which is an
independent agency also the us
government agency and that's i was in
vietnam with usaid
katie kelly for 12 years worked for it
the nbc organization in new york city
nbc and then i took a brief
brief hiatus and went to abc for a few
years but the last job you had before
you wrote this book was with nbc
and you spent as we said the year 1990
over in saigon teaching children english
teaching admirations in english many of
them that were there when you were there
here now in the united states
all of the ones that i knew are here
with one exception and
the last we heard was that jim was
getting out in october
do you see them oh yeah oh yeah i
stopped in chicago a couple weeks ago
and saw breiner
i sponsored briner last year and he was
with me he was the kid in the batman
t-shirts
and
he's been going to school and just got a
new job he's a stock stock clerk in a
jewelry company
and um how's he doing he's doing pretty
well
uh
it's it's been difficult
but he's one of the brighter ones
and had a real good start thanks to his
uh thanks to his grandfather and had
about four or five years of school in
vietnam which a lot of these kids don't
have a lot of these kids are coming out
completely illiterate
when you were here with him going to
school he just got a new job he's a
stock stock clerk in a jewelry company
and um how's he doing he's doing pretty
well
uh
it's it's been difficult
but he's one of the brighter ones
and had a real good start thanks to his
uh thanks to his grandfather and had
about four or five years of school in
vietnam which a lot of these kids don't
have a lot of these kids are coming out
completely illiterate
when you were here with us over memorial
day
we talked a lot about the same stuff and
you gave the telephone number for your
office yes
and we're going to try to do that again
today if you don't mind not at all in
case somebody wants to make this
connection what can you do for folks
that are watching this and maybe it's a
man that was in vietnam
and he sees someone he recognizes or he
has a problem he hasn't solved yet
that his daughter or son he thinks is
over there what can they do well the
first thing i did last time when i got
the calls i said i would give lists of
organizations in the united states in
the cluster sites where the admirations
go
people who are interested in contacting
those organizations to help the
americans
enter the united states and adjust to
the to the united states that's the most
difficult difficult part of course is
katie knows
uh
so that's uh
that's what we can do
right away is this number i have here
the one that uh that the 663-1031
that's that's correct
if it wasn't it is now right
the number 202 663-1031
can get to your desk right and i have
talked to uh i don't know if you want to
mention it at this point
i several people called me after the
program last last time
people who had fathered children in in
vietnam
uh most of them we we couldn't really
there was insufficient information but
we had one happy circumstance a
gentleman called me from
from florida he was a truck driver he
was down in florida his home was in
kentucky and he mentioned that he had
seen seeing the program
and his wife and he had decided they
should call me and ask me about the
child that he left in vietnam in 1970.
he knew the child was born in vung tau
on the coast and and he knew the the
name of the mother
that's only only knew and he'd been
trying over the years with without any
hope uh so i took the information and i
tried i said i would do what i i tried
to do what i could
and i checked on our computer checked
the name of the mother on the computer
we have in the refugee bureau and sure
enough the mother's name was there there
were about three of them with the same
name
and with one of them was the name was a
son born 1970 in wong tao
and they had left in 1989
so i uh it looked like a good pretty
clear match so i called the refugee data
center in new york tried to find out
where these people were resettled they
referred me to somewhere in california i
talked to the people there and they
found them
and gave me their number and i called
the woman
and asked her a little bit about her
her coming to the united states and her
son and asked what she knew about the
father and she said she gave me the
father's name which was the name of this
gentleman who had called me and she went
and got a piece of paper and spelled it
out for me too so i
i told her i think perhaps we had found
the father of her
child would she like me to
contact the father and have him contact
her and she said indeed she would
so i contacted the father and he was
somewhat excited to say the least
and called her
talk to her and talked to his son and i
guess about a month or two or three ago
the son came to live with him
in kentucky
and as a matter of fact just before i
came on the program i called
to
down there to see to tell them that this
would be on and i would probably be
mentioning their case but not not by
name necessarily
and the boy answered
speaking in very good english and uh i
just said hello and wished him well the
father was still out on a job though
so that was that just shows what is you
know little miracles can happen and it's
it's a possibility and families can get
together and
so i was happy that that happened
most of the others about more than a
dozen or so they're called it was
insufficient information and uh we were
unable to let me ask you this because
this seems to cut through an awful lot
of bureaucracy although it creates its
own kind of a bureaucracy
this is not available to to just
everybody the the way that i mean i i do
volunteer work in a saint rita's asian
center a cluster site in new york city
and
one of the two ways that we've
discovered is
is co-registering through the red cross
they're formed 1609 where the amerasian
has to fill out
a little form and the father has to
fill out a little form but unless they
both filled out the form nothing can
happen but i've always thought that what
you just talked about would be the
perfect thing if there could be an
intermediary who could plug into the
computer system i mean obviously these
things are on computers
that you know
the father might never have thought
about doing it but if a third person
calls and says we think we found your
kid
that might be the prompt or the father
the father might do it and the kid
thinks i could never do this i would
never find my father but
the key is having sufficient information
and only in that one case do we have a
full name for example we're going to
open the phones up in case you have a
question about what we're talking about
and the numbers will be on the screen
you can begin dining now our east coast
lines are filled we got a couple
open out west and the number to reach
bill fleming at the state department
where he's the deputy director of the
office of asian asian refugee assistance
is
202-663-1031 i might just like i'm
on leave all this week i'm taking my son
to college so don't call this
this week for me i'll call you next week
i have a lot of full names so uh
suggestion to you is that call and if
they want to write you a u.s state
department is there a better address
than just playing the u.s state
department well u.s
u.s department of state bureau for
refugee programs
washington dc20520
and with my name
all right we phones are open we're going
to take a call but before we do katie
kelly what's your favorite story about
all this connection stuff
from your experience and being there for
a year
i think my favorite story is is the
story of briner who knew that he had a
father in california who didn't want
anything to do with him and finally
brainerd just picked up the phone one
day and
was living in chicago and called him up
and they talked for a half hour and then
what happened
a little inconclusive but i think
they're going to be more phone calls and
maybe a visit didn't but didn't want
anything to do with him nothing to do
with him
you know you know it
he had a lot of things that he had to
work out
and a lot of people had been kind of
going through the back door to try to
get him to contact his son but he
wouldn't so briner just you know now
that he's an american kid picked up the
phone and did it for himself
spoke to his grandmother spoke to his
father
it was at least a breakthrough for him
and he can speak pretty good english yep
taught by you for a year well i think he
had a little bit of before he got to me
but
saint mary's georgia go ahead please
right i was in the central highlands for
a year and a half i lived in a mountain
yard village monteguard and i've i've
heard that the people have been to
knowledge i just want to know on
how can i
check with my old town thank you
i think he was saying that he thought
the village in the mountain yard village
was annihilated he wants to know how can
he
check that out for sure that's not quite
the same that we're talking about what
would you suggest
jim
that's hard to say i'm not sure we would
know if a village still existed or not
he could
he could write uh
he could write to me with the name of
the uh
the village and has he tried he could
try to write himself to to vietnam to
the village and see if he gets some
response at the risk of taking uh giving
the wrong suggestion you also could
contact your congressperson
who might be able to work the
bureaucracy here easier if
if it doesn't i mean i don't know that
you wouldn't normally get into this
would you
uh
not uh
not normally they may ask people in our
office because many of us had been in
vietnam and they may think we know
but it would be rather difficult but of
course a congressman would probably ask
us
directly yes
just trying to get work for him
norfolk nebraska go ahead please
hi katie i met you over at your signing
in albion nebraska oh hi yeah how are
you i try to get through it
i
talked to the little professors
bookstore in norfolk and asked them if
they would like a
review on your book
i read it a couple weeks ago we went on
a vacation and it rained for a week so i
had time to read it
and i just wondered if you would like to
hear what i had written down to see if
you thought it sounded like something
you would like
as a review they only allow us a hundred
words
to saigon through the eyes of a tourist
appear different than saigon through a
year's visit with a teacher instructing
amerasian students
conversational and academic english katy
kelly experienced both kinds of trips
but the teaching assignment
left a permanent mark on her heart
miss kelly learned the satisfaction of
involvement in the class bigger than her
own life's work in the journalism field
and she shows love and understand she
reaps love and understanding she
discovers that vietnam the choice never
discovers
what her show you or vietnam you didn't
know existed involvement in a cause
brings rewards at uncommon times katie
discovers
do you think that
well
it touched my heart thank you very much
thank you do you find people uh
uh
it's kind of a leading question but is
this an emotional issue for you still
after all these years
for me it yes
it is um
especially if i if i see there are
if before i perceive that perhaps
they're inequities in the adjudication
process or the people are not having
access to the program
that still makes my
blood boil a bit i
of course in my job i have to
maintain an even temper and try to get
things done
properly i i
although i'm not dealing with the
admiration program now it's still it
still affects me and that's why i
maintain an interest and
i'm happy to to talk about it so people
know exactly what's happening from
reading your book i gather that you got
emotional more than once oh more than
once and i tell you because you know
there is such desperation
with especially the the amerasians in in
trying to get out of vietnam
so many people suffered so much
after 1975 but the amerasians suffered
in particular
simply because of who they were and to
suffer
as a five-year-old child or an
eight-year-old child or then as a
teenager
uh briner for example was standing in
front of the old u.s embassy talking in
1985 the 10-year anniversary talking to
an american reporter just trying to get
a message out to his father
and when the american reporter left
breiner was swept up by the police and
beaten up and that's
lost all his front teeth and was thrown
in jail
and i mean these are terrible burdens
for these for these kids to bear
just
for what is considered a mistake of
birth they're americans and you uh took
uh briner and others to the dentist
oh well i mean years later when i met
this kid
you know he had lost all his teeth oh
yes took these kids to the dentist
so you know thank god for american
dentistry oh well i can tell you as
reading your book and
reading the part where
the root canal was delivered without
novocaine uh got my attention oh yeah
childhood
root canal done i had to leave i had to
leave the room it was as bad as the
child birth scene but oh
to to endure
a root canal to do or anything without
novocaine as far as i'm concerned
but he's got two beautiful teeth and i
had a thank you note for him
tampa florida thanks for waiting
yes uh i have one question for mr
flaming uh i have one problem uh
i have my mother still in vietnam
and apparently uh i was notified by the
the office that i paid for the airplane
ticket and
since night beginning in 1991
and i haven't heard anything since then
and at one point i contacted my
congressman
and he would send the inquiry and
everything and
my response from the office was
her case within transit i don't know
what it means if mr flaming can explain
to us thank you
thank you stay on the line just a second
in case he has a question i'm not
i'm not sure i
can tell you just why that happened it
may have been a medical problem your
mother had and she's undergoing extended
treatment but if you had been asked to
pay and you had already paid
then
and they say she was in transit that's
it's a little unclear what the
circumstances are if you again if you
want to write to me or call me when i
get back i'd be happy to take down the
iv number or the interview number and
just take a quick check in the computer
and tell you exactly where it stands
caller you are vietnamese yes i am and
how long you been in this country 13
years 13 years and for what reason did
you come in the first place
well i left in 1979
because my family left so back then i
was only 15 i just was gone because my
family left my father
gone and
he took us with him
okay
do you think you have enough information
to get a hold of mr fleming directly
uh well his name was very well known
through all the vietnamese i write a lot
to the uh in the bangkok thailand try to
work on my
mother problem for the past 13 years do
you know your the iv number of your case
yes i do i have all those information
could you give it to me i'm sorry i
don't have them okay
okay if you could call me a right then
i'll see what i can do thanks tampa and
that number is 202-663-1031
fort smith arkansas go ahead please
yes i was wondering uh what steps could
be taken for somebody possibly adopting
these amerasian children with no ties
say blood ties
katy kelly
well i think the one thing you have to
realize is that most of these these kids
are are older now they're
older teenagers are young adults and
you know they are they aren't they
aren't small babies uh beyond that i
don't know what the problem would be
with adopting them i mean sponsorship is
is the most
uh usual and regular thing to do right
that's that's true most of them are
young adults now and if they are
amerasians they're all going to come to
the united states in any case so it
would not be a matter of adopting them
in order to help them get to the united
states because if they're amerasians
they're they're qualified
did you ever live in vietnam
yes how long
two four years
72 to 74.
norfolk virginia you're next yes
hi you're on the air hello all right go
ahead please uh yes i have a question
from william
go ahead please um
i'm trying to get i'm vietnamese i'm
married to american
and um i tried to get my sister my
sister come to the united states i went
down to uh federal building in norfolk
virginia
and they told me that the wait
for time for a period of time is eight
to ten years i didn't want to know is
any way i can get her here sooner
will you have to are you a u.s citizen
uh yes sir and you filed a petition for
her yes sir when did you file that
uh about six months ago okay well then
that is true it's pr unfortunately it's
probably more than eight or ten years
because uh
for brothers and sisters of u.s citizens
that's the longest weight since there
are so many of them throughout the world
and since you filed just uh this year it
may very well be more than it could be
10 to 15 years before
she could come under the
immigration program i'm sorry but that's
the situation with many many families
how what's the longest period you know
you went over there to vietnam on a
tourist visa the number of tourist visas
how many did you have to get oh i don't
know i kept having to get them renewed
and extended and everyone periodically
i'd have to leave the country and come
back in and
because it was just a tourist visa
and did they know what you were doing
over there yeah because
i kept a very low profile and they
didn't bother me and i was i was
prepared to just be booted out at any
time you kept the low profile but as you
write when you would walk around the
town like a pied piper it's a little
hard to keep a low profile you know
this this hair i was on total hair alert
for one solid year with that humidity
and yeah
and in fact i had someone from a a
tourist office come and tell me that you
know maybe i should cool and not hang
around downtown for a few weeks because
things were getting a little hot and so
i did did they ever arrest you for any
reason
i did get castle i did get stopped at
the airport once i had gone out out of
the country and gotten a new visa and
come back in
and i did it the way i'd always done it
but they stopped every american that was
on that flight
kept kept us in a room put us in a van
took us to a hotel which turned out to
be a lot more
than my 10 night kim doe held us
overnight charges 75 in processing fees
and let us go
los angeles go ahead please yes my
question to your panel is i'm curious
about the
amerasian children of african-american
descent how are they being treated and
uh are their fathers seeking them out
and are they being repatriated back into
the united states thank you thanks
well f
caucasian children and
hispanic they're all
being processed
through
through the amerasian program
i guess it is a fact that
african-american children perhaps
face a greater degree of discrimination
in vietnam why
it's
it's well it's the same problem we have
in our society it's
in in in asian societies often uh afro
black uh africans americans it's just a
uh
a distinction and unfortunate
distinction they make
and then it's very clear discrimination
it's it's one of those unfortunate facts
of life that it uh
it's not good to deny but to address
them katie kelly who's this
um
oh that's that's my friend uh trang on
the left and on the left is her mother
long that was the
the mother and the daughter who had
gotten
separated and the husband wasn't allowed
to come and the mother wasn't allowed to
come and that's the one i wrote to bill
about they're living in hartford
connecticut now the two of them are yeah
all of them the whole family yeah now
what about african-american kids versus
the others it was my feeling that the
african-american admiration suffered
if it was possible even more
than than the other kids
and i had the feeling that if a kid was
going to be abandoned you stood a better
chance of being abandoned if you were an
amerasian
african-american male
there are no statistics on this but i
just had that feeling that
that that this is how it ended up
but on the on the plus side of that uh
there were some buddhist monks in the
western part of uh out near uh
tainin
who made it a point of of rescuing
the african-american americans and in
fact their orphanages were filled with
them
i might add that there is no
discrimination in choosing and getting
two african-american amerasians in
vietnam the vietnamese government is
cooperating fully and letting us have
access to all all amerasians
maywood new jersey go ahead please
yes i'm just curious about um
i know how the
men that were in vietnam had started
families over there and i realized a lot
of them must have stayed there
um
how did how do you know if they did or
how do you know if they're pows or mia
or they're back here you're saying a lot
of the american men stayed there yes
was that your experience
stayed in vietnam yeah did you see many
americans i didn't see any anywhere well
i saw american veterans coming back but
nobody living there no from america
looking for their children but i i saw
none living there
your experience that
almost never happened
sometimes they would live with their
children before 75
but after 75 no one stayed
stayed behind under the new government
just to be with their family or very few
that we
none that i know of and there certainly
have not been stories of those lexington
kentucky
uh yes i was calling to ask if there is
any agency that oversees our department
of immigration i'm a retired teacher and
i've had so many of the youngsters
either vietnamese or
iranian
who are i would think really harassed
and abused by our department of
immigration when those families have to
go
and report i don't know if it's for
review or what they will sit for hours
sometimes the young ladies of ninth
grade students are asked some very
embarrassing questions
and i did go through the immigration
years and years ago when
my ex-husband was
trying to become a resident citizen of
this country so i know the stories are
true i called my congressman and they
said oh well you know we have to do that
because
you wouldn't be surprised at some of the
types of people that are trying to get
into our country how many vietnamese do
you have out in your area
oh my goodness i wouldn't know i've had
over the years i would say as
students um
probably
15 20 families and of course being a
foreign language teacher i didn't have
all of the students that were enrolled
in the school okay thanks mr fleming
well i'm not sure if she's mentioning
specifically how they're being treated
here or in the process of coming uh i
think she's talking about after they're
here well after they're here i mean the
question of
long waits and such is that's not
i mean that's not unusual because of the
the large numbers of people and i also
don't
doubt that many uh vietnamese iranians
and others
are not treated with the total courtesy
i mean that happens in every in every
bureaucracy but i think
more and more the u.s government
officials are trying to emphasize uh
to treat everybody with the certain
sensitivity because that's
that's what they do to them as human
beings and it's it's it's productive in
getting the information you want also in
your book when you talk about the
bureaucracy in vietnam you compare it to
the internal revenue service here in the
united states
what was your point well part of it is
don't make waves
and part of it is that it's just it's
impossible to confront
i mean if we think it's difficult to
confront a bureaucracy here in america
certainly we all do and we do it every
day to confront the bureaucracy in
vietnam is impossible because you won't
get any answers and also it's hard
because there are no telephones
and you get you get stopped right now
how many people had televisions
um there were more coming into saigon
but oddly enough what would happen is
one family would get one and a vcr
and then they'd they'd rent you know
they'd charge admission for people to
come in and watch movies entrepreneur
spirit still alive san jose california
hello hi
my name is kung fu i have a question for
bill fleming
right ahead sir
uh mr fleming
i'm a
u.s citizen now
i'm from vietnam i have a cousin who was
admitted to the united states under the
humanitarian operations program
and
during the interview
by
some u.s official three of his children
were rejected from his case file
and i would like to
help him
file for an appeal or what should i do
and to whom should i address the appeal
well you you can address anything to the
orderly departure program in bangkok the
america the american embassy in bangkok
thailand
but uh for the you're speaking about the
the interview program for the former
re-education
center
detainees
and
for family members to accompany them if
any of the sons and daughters of these
re-education people are married they can
get interviewed but they both married
and single they have to show that they
have been part
of the family
over time because the idea is to keep
the families together if perhaps they
had married and gone off and lived on
their own or if single sons and
daughters had not lived with a family
for some time perhaps that is
one of the reasons
that they might not have been allowed to
to accompany the mother and father do
you have a follow-up question san jose
i understand that but these three
children they are with the family they
are unmarried are they how old are they
they they are over 20 years old yeah so
they're basically adults too
uh
well i guess again i don't know without
looking at the case but i know in in
instances like this if it has been
determined that they have not
if perhaps there is insufficient
evidence that they have lived with a
family over time a very new family
register for example or something that
was said during the interview i mean
there are indeed cases where families
are put together quickly this may not
have been the case at all in the case of
the family you're mentioning but it's it
may be part of the explanation the only
thing you can do is if you're to write
to odp
explain
explain the situation and see if that
that makes a difference we're going to
watch a woman teach an english class a
vietnamese woman teach an english class
in ho chi minh city at the university in
just a moment when you were teaching
english to vietnamese amerasians
what was the most effective tool that
you had to teach well i i taught
absolutely no frills english we had no
textbooks and once i
got into jim's house no
chalkboard and no chalk if you could see
it
point to it or do it it got taught
but you know there wasn't a lot of room
in there for uh
for aesthetics um
i used everything everything was a
teaching tool i used menus
i happen to have a root map that i stole
from united airlines that became the
geography map
i had a calendar that my insurance
company had given me
scenic america
and i mean they just they went bananas
over that i had postcards scenic
postcards from south dakota oh they
loved it
columbus ohio you're next go ahead
please hi hi um i'm the sister of
a veteran who was killed in vietnam
and this was the only male in our family
[Music]
how would i go about finding out if he
had any kids when he was there
how what what year was he killed
in 67 boy um you had this one before
gee to find out if there were any
children that's
i
i can't imagine i'm trying to think
quickly how one could
try to prove that something did not did
or did not happen
i'm afraid i have no immediate
suggestions unless you have some
information about
is having a relationship with someone
and if you have a name for example then
you could send that to me or call me if
you have some information of that nature
then maybe we can find out something
caller do you have any reason to believe
that your brother did have children yeah
oh you do okay i mean i don't nothing
other than he was a very very young man
and
it would be abnormal for him not to
engage so and you know it's just hopeful
on my part but i think that it's a real
good possibility
now what
do any of the mothers over there give
names of fathers
i mean couldn't you just look up and see
if there was a woman over there that
said that this man was the father
well first of all i'm not sure it's
abnormal not to engage a lot of people
didn't and that's why they're not as
many children as there are uh sometimes
the people who are interviewed give the
names of fathers but we don't we'd have
to check each case file to see what they
said during the interview that's not
kind it's not kept on a computer for
example
you have a little bit of criticism for
men in your book about uh what they left
behind over there if i'm if i remember
right well i had i had to exercise an
awful lot of self-control not to get
terribly angry but then i would keep
remembering fathers like like kim's dad
who did go back and and try to find out
try to find their kids
and keep reminding myself
that this was such a terrible
time and place and it was the late 60s
and the early 70s and a lot of us
didn't know a lot of things back then
last call for this segment myrtle beach
south carolina go ahead please yes hello
hi um i'd like to know what should be
done in the future uh what do they feel
should be done in the future to further
improve the um education of
[Music]
not motherboards sure if that wasn't
pulling our leg or what happened there
uh
i didn't hear the the punchline i was
just well thanks for the call anyway uh
how much activity
in your office now compared to the last
couple years are you busier now than you
have been or
with the american problem
well that's again that's the office near
mine that's not what i deal with now
myself but the we're continuing to
emphasize
interviewing all of the amerasians and
getting access to them and we expect by
and perhaps mid-year next year we get
the bulk of them
uh interview those we have names
you know the liz we have lists of names
for those others perhaps a
year or two or three into the future
probably some will still be coming
in
isn't there still a particular
difficulty in that all the interviews
are still done in saigon and so many of
these kids are
often other countries are often other
cities and often the boondocks and also
don't have the transportation money to
get down to saigon definitely that's
that's very true and that's the reason
and then once they get there have no
place to stay and no way to support
themselves this is really
you know one of the one of the pervasive
problems right that's what has to be
continually addressed that was why the
american transit center was created and
it did deal with some of those problems
but you're absolutely right having it
centered in one area and relying on
local governments throughout vietnam to
find the amerasians it's difficult for
the vietnamese government and
so
we would hope perhaps when we normalize
relations that perhaps
can have greater access to those that
may remain because the infrastructure
within the vietnamese
government and within the country i mean
with no phones no facts no xerox
machines out in the boonies and
it's extremely difficult yes how many uh
vietnamese born people are here in this
country now
vietnamese born
natives i've heard different uh maybe
about perhaps eight hundred thousand or
so and more than a million or so from in
from old into china and your wife's
vietnamese yes married her what year
merited in 1974. how many children three
children we're out of time for this
segment mr fleming thank you very much
for joining us thank you and once again
uh bill fleming can be reached uh a week
from today
uh
meaning monday 202 663 tuesday labor day
next month that's right 202 66310
is the telephone number and if you want
to write the u.s department of state
washington d.c 20520 bureau for refugee
programs bureau for refugee programs u.s
department of state washington dc
dc20520 right thank you very much for
joining us thank you thank you
and uh this book is katie kelly's book
she's going to be with us until the end
of the day which is another two and a
half hours i might know i've three and a
half hours what is it 2 30 to 6 is
yes thank you uh and her book is in the
bookstores called a year in saigon
she'll tell us more about her
experiences as we continue to look at
what was originally a trip to vietnam on
the part of c-span back in april of this
year we first ran this whole series of
hours of 30 hours of programming over
memorial day weekend at your request
we're repeating it during this august
recess
and next up
we go to
a
university of ho chi minh city classroom
where we join them for about 30 minutes
and you're going to
meet no tea or not te fung tian who is
the teacher
and
when what you'll see is an actual
english being taught
but first we want to give you the full
schedule on
what's coming up for today and the rest
of the week
as we said ho chi minh university 230
jacqueline pham story at 3 30. she's a
c-span employee who went back to see her
home for the first time since she was
age nine when she left there in 1975.
then the three american students are
studying up in hanoi at 4 30 east coast
time
vietnamese students in the u.s at 5 15.
tomorrow meeting tuesday is m.i.a.p.o.w
day
we start again at noon east coast time
tomorrow
you will see john mccain senator from
arizona former prisoner of war other
former prisoners of war senator john
kerry the head of the m.i.a.p.o.w select
committee in the senate
deputy assistant secretary of defense uh
patak will join us for phones
and more phone calls and scenes of
vietnam throughout the entire afternoon
from noon until 6 east coast time
wednesday
visit to the ho chi minh mausoleum
the tudo obstetrics hospital
prosthetic research center
fred downes and tran van ka will join us
and then more phones throughout the day
thursday
james clad who's with the carnegie
endowment for
peace
will be here for an hour to talk about
the economics of that part of the world
in southeast asia which includes
singapore and malaysia and vietnam and
cambodia and thailand
u.s vietnam relations vietnam economics
and again more phone calls and on friday
that's the day we return via videotape
to the mekong delta for about two and a
half hours with john kerry and bob smith
senators from the
pow mia select committee and a visit
with to the ho chi minh prison
i'm sorry the hanoi prison the army
museum tour all with the senate select
committee
and that's it for this week as we go
continue through vietnam revisited and
now as we said earlier to the university
of ho chi minh city
had a chat with your mother
i see right um would you like to come
and visit the class say hello to them
because i think they will be very
excited to have an american crew this is
the first time but we had you know
different crews like bbc so i'm sure
that this time it's still very exciting
for them to have america we'd also like
to watch you teach the classroom yeah
sure i think you are welcome i i would
like to tell you please come in okay
they are third year students and their
major is english
and now the the class deceptive please
sit down this afternoon the class is
about british culture and society
so this is a
course that they have to study for about
a semester
and
they like to study about different
topics uh subjects um for example
british culture and
did you study last time do you remember
for the first semester what was it about
baby
the political institute institution of
which country
of england okay and then after that what
we did we studied education yeah what
else
parliament okay parliament is one part
of the political institution right
a drug addict right remember we studied
the problem about the
the the drug uh problem in britain the
youth right what the hell did we study
do you remember
what was it
okay the social system and the social
club system in in britain
and did you tell do you remember what we
said about how can you make the
distinction among people what what what
magnetos
that's right the way that the appearance
though what else
so what is the uh the standard accent do
you remember what we said last time
company is
[ __ ] class accent and how about the
rp what is the rp4
that's right receive to pronounce here
pronunciation which is the standard
extended one then what did we study last
time you remember you listen to the take
what was it about the difference between
the years
is it the gap generation remember last
time did we study that
the youth and the old generation so what
what would it what did uh what was the
difference between the two
yeah
young people probably have much class by
much money than the old ones okay so
first of all the young generation can
spend much more more money they are more
they are more independent that's why
they are more independent what else and
better education that's right the young
generation is more educated than they
used to used to be and wow how do
you remember who said that the old
generation should learn from the young
what should they learn from
that's right how to enjoy enjoy life
right remember we said that why why why
do you think that the
the old generation should learn from the
young nation how to enjoy life
why
because
what we were saying was saying that the
old generation is always thinking of
what thinking about the past events
foreign that's good too right what else
you violence to solve problems okay
sometimes they use more uh violent means
to solve
problems
that's right they think more about
material life why the young generation
prefer to relax and to enjoy remember we
said clothing what was the clothing
about
the way they did they um
the dress
how do they dress
the young prefer to to beat
be fashionable okay certainly
fashionable the alternative think about
it
what else what is the
the goal of life you remember what did
you say
do you do you agree with the author
because it was you know um
the point of view of the after right so
how about your opinion what do you think
do you do you agree or how about the
vietnamese if you compare you know
between the western way of life and the
vietnamese way of life do you share the
same opinions
better accept a lot
but people just think that
they have
they have experienced something in the
past so
the younger must study what they have
but they have experience for example and
i think
in this case
the young people
will be
much
much influenced about the past event and
they don't have much time to improve
themselves okay do you think that in
vietnam yeah because we respect the old
people we learn experiences from uh from
all generations but we also uh think
more independently that's what you think
and what else could you give me another
example to compare with between the
western way of thinking and the
vietnamese way of thinking
i mean
there's the same point between the two
countries for example
the output real person in vietnam always
think of the past events
so i think that is the familiar that's
the same point
the first difference
which is familiar okay so you think that
the both generations think of it after
the past events and also they always
complain and they always complain
i'm sorry they're always complaining
about the youth oh okay you see that the
old generation always complain about the
youth why why did you complain about the
youth
because they look they look grown up
more than a real person
yes and
some opinions some ways of life the way
of life is
certainly certainly the way of life is
season now today the lesson is about men
and women right the the challenge of new
roles so group one could you come and
present the
briefly
so what what is the topic uh you want to
present to the class right could you
come over and explain to the class what
would you like to do
the assignment so i gave you this
article right and this article is from
which magazine you know
yes
you do whatever you like you know you
have um you are free just go ahead
talking about men and women
especially in the british society okay
and maybe i can summarize what i
want to take some information from this
yes
first
this is a challenge of neurons between
men and women
and
you should know the causes of this event
you see
there are three main causes
first because of the industrial
revolution
happened in between the 18th and 19th
century
that lead to
receive many labor labor saving devices
in the home that make
and that's the one and
next the ideas on women liberation
you said in the 18th and 19th century so
you cannot mix up right women sleep is a
more recent modern
movement so when did it occur the
women's liberation when did it happen
so when do you think that the the
women's sleep
happened yeah when
in which yeah tell me
what
maybe after world war ii after world war
ii
why do you think it is it was after
world war two
just yes i just guess
so yes no no
i argue my mother why yes why do you
think after the second world war
you have this idea of women's liberation
because
because after the two world war
where why the men have to go to the
field to fight and women at home
take the work on the farm and on
factories which
previously
are done by men and they can do it well
so the society view to women strong
change and
women there then they see their own
potential too
with what she said
do you agree with this
can you give other other reasons
can you give other reasons so that's
right so you have this is the idea of
economic independence right because as
she said women before state are at home
and then after the second world war uh
they started to think that they should
be more indifferent and have their own
own jobs and also
bring a
what else
now
i come to the part of the process of the
development between
now between the two roles of two sexes
yes
you see
as we say
the industrial revolution is one of the
causes
so
in my opinion
then the challenge of neuron begin with
the revolution
industrial revolution oh yes
do you agree with her
in this case i have one idea okay give
tell me your ideas
because in the last century the women
they wanted to improve that they can
they could have some position as well as
make the bank
for example they can get a high vision
as the others and they want to share the
position and the roles between them and
the others and want to be likely to be
equal okay
you see in my opinion women's role in
society have begun to change with the
event of the industrial revolution
because at that time
there are many
technological
invention
and so many labor saving devices that
type the you see that can
replace replace the wrong of the women
at home so she can go into work okay so
you you actually i think you are mixing
up you see because the industrial
revolution occurred in the 18th and 19th
century while you are talking about
labor safety saving devices and the
labor saving devices what are they can
you give me examples of labor saving
devices like
that's right washing machine what else
washing machine what else
huh
yeah
thank you vacuum cleaner right what else
ordered
with the labor saving devices you have
the
that's right they can be more
independent so they can go out and and
work for themselves and they can bring
money home you know it's not only the
role of man that's why we're talking
about that okay
[Music]
of course certainly because now uh
economically not only because women want
to be economically free but they also
want to bring their own share
right because men cannot work alone they
have certainly i agree with you yeah do
you agree with her i do
yes do you think that a woman should
share
the
financial expenses of the family or she
should stay at home
i don't how about men can you tell me
yes i think it's right so men and women
have the same role of grandchildren
yes and they have to share they have to
share you know the
wages the wages their income
yes
i think that assures the happiness of a
family the more the family
how about the ladies in our class what
do you think
yeah you haven't told you haven't said
anything so far so
you should say
question financial
to help them to do business and to
support the family and how about the
other way around do you think that men
should help women to do the housework
what do you say
certainly
but how about our vietnamese society
how about our vietnamese society do you
think that men help a lot in the family
no
so this is your duty all of you girls
and mega revolutions you make a
revolution
you think that men and women have
because they have also to
have a job right and also to share
the housework
yes but the important thing is the man
is the man both families and he has much
influence on them
do you think that man has more influence
than women
i say
men back home but women make fun
men make house but women back home
the father has much to do on their
journey well i think that children may
be
more terrified by the father of course
she was the one terrified she said that
the children are more terrified by the
by the uh the fathers but they love the
mother they listen to the advance of the
mother much more ah okay do you agree
with that
yes okay
all right so
can you develop your ideas now yes
and now i continue
you see first uh
so as so so far previously women are
just carers carers and family home care
home care
what
oh i see more about the family why for
the house housewife do you think that it
take care more of the housework of the
or what yes what would you want to say
[Music]
more spiritual spiritual
idea well
i think
we when we use a world housewife we just
refer to
household
households of rice that's called health
care
do you want to ask any questions to your
friend to your classmates
not yet oh okay not yet you want to
finish your presentation okay
you see
we mean at first
i employ a very low price
but even though they are cheap labor but
they feel some amount of independence
so you see they are so
they go to work even though the the
price and the wages the wages
is very low lower than much lower than
men and how do you call this now women
are
asking for what if you say that they
have the same job yeah
no they have the same job but they're
not the same pay how do you call this
now they want to get the e because they
politics
and now we come to the next step of the
development you see
the two world war happens
and then at that time as we already said
men have to go to the battlefield
so i women at home
because lack of the shortage of flavors
they have to work on the farms and
factories which is previously
managed by men and then they can do it
all right so
the society view to the women's strong
women's potential ability of working
change and then
women themselves can recognize
their own potential too okay so okay i
think thank you very much for your
presentation you go back to your place i
would like to ask you so this is the the
causes how do you think that
in britain
the government
decided to have any measures
to have women to have the equality can
you tell me about the
the measures of the government or laws
that were passed by
by parliament
see the law the law gradually
acknowledged the women's right
and then they make what kind of right do
they did they get
what kind of right did you get
group one you were supposed to prepare
it the marriage women's property x
starting in 1870 enabled women to only
post of their property yes because
before before they get what happens when
they get married they have to pass their
um
that's why their properties to their
hearts to their husbands so with this
act they are allowed to work too
long to what
to hold their properties for them for
themselves
good how about their
let me ask you first uh where did you
study your english
well i i studied my english first first
of all here in vietnam and i graduated
and after a while
teaching here i thought that it would be
good to well to further on my studies so
australian government gave you know not
only myself but other teachers a
scholarship so i went to australia and i
did a diploma in tesol in 1987.
after a while i came back and i i was
specialized in the teaching british
culture and society to the third year
students
so i got the scholarship to go to
britain and in britain i did my me
degree at the university of warwick and
i just came back well four or five
months ago so i'm back to the university
in my new position
as the acting chair of the english
department
i'd like to ask you some of your
students why they're studying
british culture or why do you know
english so well
so anyone can answer
yeah it's gone
yeah it's difficult yeah
can you tell me about your country yeah
why why are you interested in english at
all what what purpose
uh we we we are
at the at age at the age of 12
we can learn english at high school and
from then on we continue and if you are
interested in english and you try new
universities or you can enter into
universities
after the exam
how old are most of you
how old are you 21 21 20
and how how much more school do you have
to go
before you graduate from university
and what kind of a degree will you have
when you graduate
bachelor's degree in what
in english all of you in english yes so
what are you going to do with it once
you graduate interview text interpreters
any kind of job
will you all stay here in vietnam yes
yes
where would you like to study
where would you like to study
no i don't think so but maybe
in prison or in australia is all right
because there are
english-speaking countries have any of
you in this country ever travel to an
english-speaking country
not yet
no not yet we don't have
what do people in vietnam think of the
united states now
what do you think of the united states
now i think it's a prosperous country
for me i have the relations between two
countries are connected
so i hope
the day will come
so i think that's the best
i think that's the right course for
for the development of our country i
think is
the benefit of not only for our
countries but
for united states too
what is there any bad feelings about the
war i know most of you
it's even being 20 you that with 20
years ago would be 1972 you don't even
remember it
but uh
so it doesn't matter the war doesn't
matter
what do you think somehow
instead of saying yes some of us are
influenced by the world caused by
because father or mother yeah work
in their own relation
did anyone in this room lose a mother or
a father because of the war yes
yes
where was your mother
was she here in saigon yes
so that obviously affects the way you
feel about it
that affects the way you affect the way
you feel about the united states or just
about war
what do you feel
since you lost your mother during the
war do you feel bad about did you ever
know your mother
no not not lost my mother but my mother
have to go to the re-education for camp
maybe for a long time one year
and then they study well because at that
time we um we were too young and then
the mother had to go to where education
came
it was terrible and and when was that
back right after in 75 76
yes right after the war was over
anybody else have a parent that had to
go to the re-education camp
in here yes yes what do they what is
your what do your parents say about that
said about the uh the whole experience
yes
they talk they talk about it at all
about the wall about the re-education
camp
sorry i can't hear you
terrible it was terrible because
why economic problems the government
cannot pay you know for the re educators
so i think that's the worst the the
worst reason
economical
reason
what was the purpose of the or the
reeducation camp
why did they happen so they learned some
lessons about political lessons
do you all feel very political are you
interested in politics at all no no no
no no
there's not no difference between people
now
of the people from every education camp
or the people
tell me what you mean
i think there's some difference
for someone getting a job i'm getting
chance
17 news or something like that
to mark to mark the students when they
enter to the university for example some
are privileged
about the marks for example if you are
a son or a daughter of
a family you know our family who
have a family you know um
a family joining the war
of course they decide they take side in
the
revolution
design the revolution
revolution
soldiers
so
their children have
higher marks
extra max actual marks
you know
should i ask you all because you're
younger and we and we've traveled all
over your country in the last week
and we see lots of statues of ho chi
minh
it what do you think of ho chi minh how
important is ho chi minh to you in your
life
are you i think he's a good man he's a
good man
why was he good because um
[Music]
[Music]
who devoted all his life just for the
liberation of our country
and i think he's
going to think of the the right of the
country first
i'm sure how about over here somebody
over here have an opinion on ho chi minh
what do you think
did you learn much about him in school
yes
we will tell that ho chi minh is a good
man
a great
most created men in our country
and do you believe that i mean is that
is it is it important to have somebody
like a father figure
yes maybe
and i think that they and they were
right
they are right
what do you plan to do when you graduate
from college
i'd like to have a good job
as for example an interpreter as an
interpreter
or
a translator or something
do you all have a lot of optimism about
the future do you think things are going
to be better here in vietnam in the
world in the future
[Music]
the future in vietnam would be
very good if the united states lived
in berger
because if when when this happened
the relationship between vietnam and
united states and the other countries
can be improved and we get a lot help
from the
other countries so i think that our
country can develop
with the health from our country are you
all aware of what the embargo is yes i
think after the embargo is released
the investors will come to vietnam much
more
and our country will have much more
chance to develop economies
and
so far
many things
like
unemployment and
bad condition of life will be improved
can i tell you as we've traveled around
we've had
very friendly
people come up to us and they tell us
that they like the united states i want
to know why and you can tell me if you
don't
but i want to know why after the war
people are so friendly to people from
the united states do you have any reason
sorry i think that the people
chi minh city are most often less the
american i don't think the people in the
other province in our vietnam when i
think that people in the south of
america south of vietnam they all like
americans
they know more about americans but we
just came from hanoi and we found people
in hanoi extremely friendly and likes
america
maybe they came here after liberation a
lot and they they hear from the south
southerner
baby
what are you going to say
i think they think that it's better to
be friends with americans
maybe it's better to be friends with
americans
yes any of you in here have to serve in
the army
you have no requirement now in vietnam
to serve in the army
and when we graduated from high school
we enter the university
you automatically enter the university
how are you
able to go to the university when some
others aren't what reason did you have
to take a test
yes
[Applause]
does that school cost you any money
no
not much but just a little bit money
how many how many classes do you take
every semester
like we're talking in april every week
every week every week how many classes
do you have a week seven or eight
in different subjects and what are some
of the other subjects you're taking
besides i produce the literature from
american literature
phonology syntax morphology
who's your favorite american writing
hemingway um
[Music]
next class next time we study american
literature who's your favorite american
writer
every american writer
no way
you're very nice to visit with us we
thank you very much we don't want to
take up your class but that was very
great did you like it or did you enjoy
the way they responded they're very
english is excellent
so you have to come to the united states
and interpret vietnamese for
americans into english
so i'm sure they have a brilliant future
they are the the they're not the last
generation at all
they have a future now your mother is a
politician isn't she i think so yeah
have you ever been a politician i don't
think so i'm just a teacher and i like i
like teaching here she lived in the
united states for a while have you ever
lived there no i haven't been able to go
to the state because of the there is no
normalization
i was invited to go to the states
several times
but i thought well i prefer to wait
until we have the normalization so i can
go you know um
and help also
to the process of normalization who's
your favorite american writer oh that's
difficult to say
do you read american literature oh yes
but i i'm more specialized in british
literature and british culture and
society more because we teachers have
each person has his own specialty and
the class will go on at three with a
with the teacher who is in charge of
american literature and uh if you are if
you have time and you can come and talk
to her and you will see how she's
conducting the class is she coming in
three weeks
at three o'clock she's doing american
literature then she will talk to you
about all the others in half an hour in
half an hour
thank you very much we will let you go
on appreciate it nice meeting you
kelly you spent a year in vietnam
teaching amarey's and children what's
the difference between what this class
looked like and what your classes looked
like well for one thing that class had
been educated
most americans don't even get an
education i
as i said before i think about half of
them leave the country illiterate
the kids that i had in my class the
longest anyone had been to school was
four or five years
so they were really cheated out of an
education although i'll tell you while i
was watching this tape i mean there are
a number of things that are just so
typical i mean when they you know stood
up at the end of the hour and this great
enthusiasm and the great respect they
have for
one another and for learning
what i still can't figure out and i
never got it figured out even though i
asked the question every day in vietnam
how do some people get this far and some
people don't
now they said that it didn't cost money
and then someone else said well it cost
a little bit of money
it was my understanding that education
is not free over there and that you you
pay every step of the way and but i i
still never figured out how some kids
got educated and others didn't
this is uh
katie kelly's book called the year in
vietnam or you're in saigon
and it's how i gave up my
glitzy job in television
to have the time of my life teaching
american kids in vietnam what glitzy job
did you give up for those who are just
joining us well i had this great job at
nbc television i got paid to sit around
and watch television and go to the
movies and
be an entertainment critic are you ever
going to do that again i don't think so
i went to lethal weapon 3 this summer
didn't turn me on went to batman two
didn't turn me on no i think that's i
think that's in my past brian what are
you doing to make money besides
publish this book i'm not making any
money
you retired
i took early retirement i said well i
set up my own pension and welfare fund
and i
took early retirement are you going to
write more books about this subject well
i don't know i think that all depends on
the publishing world whether anybody is
is interested in this
i mean i'm certainly interested in it
but it just might be my
my point and maybe nobody else is you
know
having read your book i can say to the
audience a lot of vivid
scenes in here about the way of life in
vietnam and it's a little bit difficult
to tell the story but
you talk about riding the
czechoslovakian buses
and the routine
of riding a bus in vietnam is what
well riding a bus is an experience all
the buses are old czechoslovakian buses
that are practically falling apart but
at every stop
along the way
people
will get into the bus vendors and
attempt to sell you things and they do
it with such drama and such flair
and i never knew their name so i just
named them and you you know razor blade
man would come on and he'd have little
single-edged razor blades you know on
those little little coats and he'd flick
them around and then he'd sell a few
and then there'd be great books man and
he would come on with a stack of
paperback books and give a complete
review and run down and obviously just
get everybody excited and then he'd sell
his books
and then there would be food vendors and
this stop this happened every time
i'm talking about a local bus you know
new york it would have been the 10th
avenue bus every time they stopped a new
vendor set of vendors would come out and
try to try to sell you something
i called it bus theater
because they were they were so dramatic
and so flamboyant i mean i didn't need
any razor blades but i felt like buying
them because he was such a super
salesman
speaking vietnamese oh yeah
what about the uh the
disabled come on
are a lot of disabled
in vietnam for a lot of reasons
and
because the medical care
the medical system like the educational
system has just simply fallen apart
i mean the biggest tragedy in the world
or are seeing the handicapped and the
disabled because they just simply don't
have the facilities
to treat them
and you know
we have wheelchairs and we have special
you know bus lifts on the buses and we
have special crutches and special okay
none of that stuff
is available for these people i mean i
saw
a man with no legs
probably a veteran
probably a veteran
and he had no wheelchair and no crutches
what he used were two small wooden
stools that he would
put under himself and then move a stool
and move up to it and move another stool
and move up to it you know these little
stools that get you about eight inches
off the ground it was the most pathetic
thing i've ever seen in my life you also
described a gentleman that came on the
bus that had had the operation for
the
what was it would it be a cancer of the
bladder i'm not sure what the surgery
was but it was some sort of a
catheterization but there was a large
bag just implanted in the middle of his
chest it was like a large ziploc
see-through zip lock bag
and when he got on had no shirt on him
had no shirt on he got on and he was
this thing it was almost as if it had
been screwed in but the you know the
scar tissue had all grown around
and the bag was completely full of urine
nobody paid
the slightest bit of attention to this
man and i tried not to pay any attention
to this man but i mean i'd never seen
anything like this
in my life and i
found myself sneaking a glance over this
man with this
urine sloshing around in there and then
i thought katie you've got to stop that
and then i looked around
and i realized that while i was sneaking
glances at this man
the entire bus
was sneaking glances at me because to
them i was a heck of a lot more an
american woman sitting on their bus a
lot more interesting than a man wearing
a bag of you're in the middle of his
chest
katie kelly spent a year in vietnam 1990
and her book's just out in the
bookstores published by simon schuster
here's what it looks like and these kids
right here are all amerasians amerasian
kids they're mothers of vietnamese their
fathers were americans either civilians
or gi's wonderful kids wonderful kids
ashland kentucky go ahead please you're
on the line hello brian this is james
state nicely kentucky
i served as a nurse anesthetist in
vietnam in one of the military hospitals
and i've been watching your program
and i was wondering how one would go
about sponsoring
one of the people at the transition
center
good question thanks yeah i think bill
fleming started
to discuss this when he was here earlier
all of the amerasians
are coming to america we're finally
getting them registered and getting them
out and then they're coming through
something called the admiration
homecoming act
and the one thing that's good and unique
about this program is that they do not
need
specific sponsors because that could
take years and what happens is that
various mainstream religions
are acting as as sort of group sponsors
in other words catholic charities will
bring over
so many each month
lutheran family service church world
service which is the methodist
organization
and and they are acting
as sponsors and then will help them in
that transition period
from the time they get off the plane
until they kind of start to make it
into the american mainstream
by the way we've got this telephone
number for those of you want to contact
bill fleming he won't be at the office
for another week
but give him a call at
202-663-1031 at the state department
that's william fleming who's the deputy
director of the office of asian refugee
assistance
the united states state department
202-663-1031 and he would be glad i'm
sure to answer
a bunch of your questions tomorrow it's
m-i-a-p-o-w day and we'll be discussing
that subject at length all day long on
wednesday the subject will be vietnam
after the war
and we'll take a look at
a lot of interesting stuff that we shot
over there in april friday is the trip
to the mekong delta for those of you who
may have missed it back in uh
earlier this year in memorial day this
is all we're talking about katie kelly's
book which was written
and published in the last couple months
written uh what through 91
when did you finish it i finished it and
then you know did some last minute
changes right up to the first part of
this year because i was trying to update
where these kids were
the ones that i had had been working
with and
how they're i kind of left the end of
the book up in the air because there
were a couple of cases that were
unresolved so i wanted to pin down that
yes child's mother got here and yes
kim's mother got here you tell us that
you spent ten dollars a night for the
hotel room when you were there for a
year have you totaled up what the whole
year cost you i haven't but i can't
imagine that it cost
anything over five thousand dollars the
whole year the whole year that's not
including no travel no that no because i
was using up all my frequent flyer miles
from the good old days to remember when
i had all those meals you bought for
those kids and everything
it is so cheap over there and of course
cheap is relative
to someone who doesn't have a job
what what's cheap
i mean the average wage is something
like 50 cents a day
but
a hotel room
feeding the kids which is what i did if
they were hungry i fed them
if they had to go to the dentist i took
them to the dentist if they needed
glasses if they needed
shoes or clothes
i really
can't imagine that it was over five
thousand dollars
la plata maryland go ahead please
katie kelly yeah what a beautiful
testimony your book must be i'm an old
retired air force austin i was attached
to the cia in 59 61 and 64.
and it it shows the advancement of our
society this i can't wait to get your
book because something like this should
have been done after korea and after the
second world war to see if we can help
and uh i'm looking forward to getting
your book and i just i've been sitting
here like there was another retired air
force man called earlier you've had me
smiling you've had me crying why didn't
you go out to the show line area where i
had a little apartment it was very cheap
oh i did oh i did i love cholon yeah and
do you remember the sound i mean the
memories you brought back how about the
sound of the cichlid early in the
morning at 6 or 5 30 and those lovely
ladies the way they sat on the bicycles
and the sound of the bicycles oh the
sound of the bicycles the sound of the
sequels and the smell of wood smoke it's
it's it's an it's an incredible
incredible country you're right bro if
this is i'm just my mouth hanging open
i've had you on two of my tv sets let me
is the brink hotel still there i don't
think so
they've changed a lot of names
but uh the caravelle is still there and
uh the continental and the majestic the
palace the the wrecks they're all still
there is always the very plush hotel but
look at you the beautiful thing to me is
somebody is doing something that is
civilized about what happened there for
thousands of years this has happened
when a country has been occupied
although we have to believe where it
happens like in korea i was a fighter
pilot it's sad what's happened in korea
there's many many korean-americans
you know and it's uh
oh yeah there i mean as i said before
they're all over they're all over asia
but but these kids got to me
partly because of how this war had
gotten to all of us but also because
they they were doubly disadvantaged by
having to grow up when the communists
came in in 1975.
thanks a lot for the call las vegas go
ahead please yes good morning good
morning uh katie kelly thank you so much
for your book i think it's a must read
for all us vietnam veterans oh well
not only give us some bad memories but
the stuff you're doing is so good
i was so impressed with those university
students of how much they want to get
u.s and vietnamese relationships going
again
and i think the real healing thing one
of these days
will be the re-establishment of
relationships uh for their benefit and
ours both yeah and i get this from a lot
of other veterans too you're not alone
out there and feeling that tallahassee
florida you're on with katie kelly hey
good afternoon i love your c-span
comments and a question
uh first off i
always little small miracles like this
uh one little brief visit and uh
they didn't you didn't know you were
going back to be the mother of a bunch
of kids did you good heavens no
and uh and it hasn't changed your
uh opinion of of the the people and has
it
do you view all prejudices now with a
different eye
well in a sense because i've seen i mean
i've seen firsthand what these four kids
went through through absolutely no fault
of their own
and uh and saw how they survived in some
cases not well these kids are true you
know many of these young people are
troubled young people
but they come to this country
with such hope and being so positive and
all i can feel and hope is that we don't
let them down
look at that face oh look at that face
oh i'm such a sucker
this is in hanoi
as we go to panama city florida next go
ahead please
uh yes uh
ms kelly you're a remarkable woman and i
am a
i am a vietnamese american
who is
extremely bilingual
and i have free a year of free time
before entering medical school wait a
minute what town are you from
panama city florida panama city florida
oh there must there must be some
resettlement uh cluster sites down there
uh yes there are about 50 families here
and
i have a year of free time before
entering medical school
and i would like to volunteer at this
time
like what you have much like what you
have done
and how do i go about doing it well as i
said it's very difficult because there
really aren't that many programs
over there and and
because of the embargo
it's it's it's somewhat difficult there
is something called the east west
foundation which operates
out of uh san diego california and just
look them up in the phone book and call
them up and i know they have a rehab
clinic in danang caller did you say you
are vietnamese uh yes and when did you
come to this country 1975 when i was
seven
and what and where have you lived since
then
i have resided in panama city florida
for about 10 years and i
went to college in uh
at ohio state and you're an american
citizen correct have you ever been back
to vietnam uh no not yet not until the
normalization occurred did you happen to
see this program when we ran it first
back in memorial day uh yes
well coming up in seven minutes you'll
see jacqueline fahm who works here at
c-span who went back with us if you
didn't see that before we'd go back and
visit her home and her grandmother's
home and
she left when she was nine years old and
she went to the university of michigan
and she now works here full-time and
if you didn't see that before it's
coming up here in just about seven
minutes
thanks for the call by the way let's go
to arlington texas go ahead please
yes yes this is mike i'm a vietnamese
also and what i'd like to talk about is
uh
the what happened to the american when
they get here to to the united states
they
i think we need to set up some support
groups uh to get them kind of
accommodated to the the society because
i see a lot of
kids
after they get to the states they join
gangs they don't have the support that
they need and maybe
even though you don't have the uh the
sponsorship that you used to for the
vietnamese maybe uh you can get
something like that going to
to get the immigration to
live in an american home so that they'll
get the values and they'll get the the
support they need right now you just get
them over here for six months to a year
and then you throw them out on the
street and they don't really have any
kind of support and they are really you
know they have a lot of baggage that
they they carry around with them so they
really need to support it's a long-term
support instead of just a short-term
support like we're doing now stay there
just a second do you want to respond
well um
a lot of these kids are coming with
mothers or grandmothers and then of
course there are the so-called
unattached free cases the homeless kids
or the or the orphans but they are all
coming to what they call a cluster site
which would be a place in new york city
not to live
or
or chicago or san francisco which help
them with various services
but it's my belief that in addition to
helping them get to the school and get
medical services get apartments get
jobs and all of this
they need mentors
they need friends
and they need
big brothers foster uncles
to do just exactly what this young man
was talking about connor when did you
come to the united states uh i came in
75
i came along with with a
with w with an american who was my
friend my father's friend and then i
just got my parents over here about a
year ago so they're living with they're
living with us right now so through the
aodp program how old are you i'm 31.
how about prejudice in this country do
you
do you see a difference between the way
you're treated as a vietnamese native i
assume you're now american citizen yes i
am and then how an american is treated
here
i think i got accepted pretty good
because i went to
college and got a good education
from texas a m
and uh so you know at work right now i
work with a with a professional group
and get i get accepted pretty well but i
think the american even they looked
american they may have some accent and
and uh you know when they came here
it's a different story for them they
don't they don't have very much
education it's a different story and
once you get it once you have an
education you carry yourself differently
and people treat you that way but you
know if you've been beaten down beaten
down in vietnam when you come to the
states you have very low esteem
self-esteem and therefore you know they
may get discriminated against all right
he brings up a very good point for an
amerasian youngster
on the one hand in vietnam officially
now you're treated like dirt because
you're an american
as an amerasian you come to america
and you're treated like dirt because
you're just another dumb refugee who
can't speak english so you talk about
a young person who's conflicted and and
mike was absolutely right we're going to
take two calls and then go to the show
you the trip of jacqueline
jacqueline pham back to vietnam san
francisco go ahead please
yeah i just want to make a comment on uh
your book first of all miss kelly and
the work that you did over in nam
for the time that you were there
and i just want to know
are there any agency right now
who can
as far as human resources or financial
for the from the vietnamese community
that can help these people with us
thanks
it's not so much now
helping the admiration in vietnam
because
you know the the thrust is to get them
out of vietnam and get them here
the big problem
occurs when they come here
because the various programs that they
can get into
are not funded well or not funded at all
uh or just aren't even there
because when you stop to think of what
these young people need when they get
here they need it they need to learn how
to speak english they need an education
they need some job training they need
they need jobs
and all of those are either not funded
or so poorly funded el dorado kansas go
ahead please yes first of all thank you
for c-span
and miss kelly i just got home and tuned
in but i did see you on cnbc last week
and i just like to say this is a
national disgrace oh it is and it's been
a national disgrace for 20 years you
know we should have done what the french
did when they left vietnam absolutely
but i plan on writing senators dole and
casa bomb and my
representative on
dan glickman
and i think if everybody would do the
same we might get something done
well you bring up a very good point when
the french pulled out in 1954
they got their kids out made them french
citizens and that was the end of it we
waited an unconscionable amount of time
to recognize the fact that we left
children over there american children
and now we're playing
a terrible sad sad game of ketchup
we have two and a half hours to go this
afternoon and four more days during the
daytime hours between 12 noon and 6
o'clock east coast time is when you're
going to see vietnam revisited again we
first ran this memorial day and it's
your request for we planned it uh for a
couple of months to run it again during
this time when the congress is not in
session and there there are no
conventions
katie kelly's book a year in saigon is
in the bookstores right now it's
published by simon schuster it's all
about her 1990 year in saigon
teaching english to amerasian children
she's going to be with us throughout the
rest of the afternoon
but for now we have
a special treat
we think it's a treat here at c-span to
show you
a young lady that works for us and will
join us here at this table in a few
minutes to take your calls and talk
about her experience jacqueline pham is
a producer here and
she went back with us in april
and here's um
just before that we're going to show you
about two minutes or let you hear two
minutes of response from our memorial
day uh first showing of this from the
public that called in you'll hear some
of the voices of people and what they
had on their mind about the special back
in april then we'll go right to the
jacqueline farm story
i think that the senators should have
spent
all their time in hanoi meeting with the
ministers the secretary general in
particular and paving the way for the
investigators trained investigators
uh for the future by uh setting
parameters and schedules
and permits and so forth rather than
running around the countryside like
brown did which was almost like a
sightseeing tour yes i would like to
know how the members of the select
committee are chosen i'm from virginia
and i know that senator rob does not
believe that there are any live pows so
how can he do a proper job thank you
i was in vietnam twice and i believe the
colorado senator when he was up in
hanoi or rather da nang
it was obvious to me and it should be
obvious to you that he was telling the
vietnamese if you don't produce any live
pows everything's going to be great
if you do we're going to have major
problems
there's no doubt that there were pows
left over there live
well it took 20 years for the senate
select committee to make
this trip to vietnam just to ask for
bones have not heard
one
request for a live prisoner of war and
it just seems that this is just a
prerequisite to lifting the trade
embargo
we abandoned them again i've been
involved with the pow mia
issue for more than 20 years now and i
think the statement of our government
is
just what senators kerry and smith said
they are there to prove that there are
no living americans being held there
i've never been there my impression of
the place
it's prettier than the south
but it's a lot closer
as a society people are more
are not as open as down here and it's a
much poorer place because it had been
under communism for
for a longer time than the south has
been and as you can see prominent in the
streets as you were walking
people were always on the streets
selling things selling cigarettes
selling lottery selling you know
coca-cola
and people said they're more of that
down up north than down south here and
because of that because of socialism and
communism up there there is no
economy there's no trading with other
nations with uh with the west with
france with the us with uh
with the dutch which used to be big in
here with shao oil
there's none of that in the north and
it's much poorer than down here and you
can see when you come down here the
city's bigger you can see the
advertising signs for sony all the
japanese foreign singapore
from hong kong and that that was all
those that were here before 1975. you
lived in this house here for how long i
lived in this house here as long as i
can remember um i was born in 65 we left
in 75 so for about nine years why did
you leave i left because my parents left
i was too young to really uh
make my own decision to where i want to
live and where i want to go my dad
worked for the u.s uh agency for
international development which is not
too far from here and that's how we got
out of the country
were you afraid to come back um no i'm
never afraid to come back i
didn't have a lot of uh expectations
because i was
afraid that i would be disappointed
because i didn't know what to expect so
i had no expectations when i came back
here of what it would be like what the
people would be like what the government
would be like
um and the city and the people
all right a couple quick things you
moved from
saigon to the united states and went
where
uh our first stop when we left we
uh we lived in indiana and then we moved
to michigan where in indiana terre haute
indiana why did you move there we well
we moved there because
when we were
in arkansas which is a camp they put a
lot of people there you have to find a
sponsor and our sponsor was my dad's uh
old boss from usaid
uh a man by the name of barry morton who
lives in indiana and he owns a uh he has
a farm out there
and he lives there so he sponsored us
and we went there
wait do you remember being this noisy
when you live there
not this noisy because it seems like
there's a lot of traffic back and forth
not residential traffic but business
traffic as you can see people are going
back and forth with uh
produce and items
now you you moved indiana and then you
moved work to michigan what year
we moved to michigan in 1978. why
my parents just didn't like indiana and
it was just they didn't care for indiana
they moved and where they moved to they
moved to holland michigan which is on
lake michigan
um on the lakeside about two and a half
hours from chicago 45 minutes from grand
rapids
and where did you go to school i went to
school
i went to high school in holland
michigan and i went to college at the
university of michigan in ann arbor
is it me by the way or has the volume
just celebrated
exactly and as you can see look at all
these uh
business types we're riding past here
yeah it's gonna get noisier and noise
[Music]
what was your first impression when you
got back here at your home my house well
my first impressions when i left i was
very small i was about
inches and i remember everything's so
much bigger the streets so much wider
the house so much bigger and when i came
back here a couple days ago everything
is much smaller i mean this i remember
it used to be like
you know a hill i thought this was you
know this is nothing and i'm almost as
big as my house now so everything's much
smaller
and
did you have brothers and sisters that
lived here with you
my parents had five kids three girls and
two boys where did you go to school i
went to school about a few not too far
from here about a five minute walk
um from here was it a safe place to live
there yeah
you think it's a safe place to live now
safe depends on how careful your parents
are my parents
and my aunts and uncles would never let
us walk by ourselves a certain time
because a lot of there were a lot of
kidnappings going on
so they wouldn't let us walk around by
ourselves
i've never walked to school by myself we
always had our housekeeper walking us or
my mother would walk us to school or we
have somebody picked us up but never on
our own was what was your dad's job with
us
he worked in the us
he was
in the education department he
translated all documents and he
was he was a translator
[Music]
it may be advisable for us to move
because it seems that we can't get this
conversation more than half a second
along and then something comes along why
don't we move to a quieter place so that
we can we i think it's more disturbing
for the audience than anybody else
[Music]
do you remember
any of your neighbors when you used to
live in this no i remember
did you go back to your old house and
see the people that live in there now i
went back to my old house there's a man
who lives in there right now and he said
he knows my dad i don't remember his
name i he didn't write it down for me
but he says he knows my dad he's very
nice he invited us in
and unfortunately he said he's out of
town right now visiting his nephew
who returned from japan so he's not able
to
be in there so we could go and film in
the house
you know when when your parents left
were they able to sell this house uh no
uh we left very quickly and very
suddenly we knew we were leaving
and uh
my dad was at work and he said there's
always a person who's around with him to
make sure that he didn't go around
telling anybody that we were leaving
because they didn't want anybody to know
usaid didn't want anybody to know that
their employees were leaving the country
so the day we left he came back to the
house
uh three hours before he left and he
says that we're leaving in three hours
so my parents packed within three hours
and my dad i'm not sure even had time to
say goodbye to our relatives and so we
went to the airport and we spent a night
there and flew to the philippines the
next day
go back to uh
talking about
what it's like to be here
you know there are vietnamese faces
everywhere you look
what what does that feel like compared
to seeing
the different faces in the united states
well it's um
it doesn't feel like it's it's my
country anymore i left so long ago and i
left when i was
so young i'm just a visitor here a
passerby i really haven't had time to
think what it's all like coming back
here
but it's uh
you know it's fine i mean i don't
i i speak the language i think they're
very friendly people i
they probably don't think i am the same
way
but it's um it's just like living
anywhere
you get any sense that you would be
different if you lived here definitely i
think so i think a lot of people who
went to the west and live in the west
would not want to live here anymore as
my mother's cousins there are a lot of
my mother's cousins who after 1954
instead of going down south they went to
paris and when they came back they did
not think that they could live in
vietnam anymore what's it been like for
you living in the united states um you
feel at home no yeah but i must say i
lived there for 17 years and it's not
the easiest place to live for the first
10 years it's a lot of turmoil it's a
lot of getting used to your parents
getting used to because my parents are
much older people i might my dad is 67
and my mother's 12 years younger and
it's not easy for them to leave the
country when my dad was 50 and my mother
was
38. how about citizenship in your family
we're all u.s citizens is that hard
no you know that's not hard we were all
under 18 when my parents became citizens
so automatically we became citizen
now when you came back here where you
were all worried about
you know i mean i know we talked a
little bit about this before you got
ever worried about getting back out not
at all i have not heard anyone who came
back and visit and had them detained
anyone here so no would you recommend
others that may see this that have not
come back come back
sure i would recommend it because i
think it's an interesting and important
aspect of someone's life when you leave
a country
so dramatically
in a war situation that it's good to
come back and see what it's like how it
has changed
if they could deal with a 25-hour flight
i think that's the biggest uh
problem how'd you deal with it
not very well why what's hard it's a
hard sitting still for 25 hours in an
airplane no leg room
you know
it's tough
go back to uh
university of michigan you studied what
i study political science and
communication why did you want to do
that
i had always had an interest in tv when
i was young i never liked tv i i went to
school here and all my brothers and
sisters had classes in the morning and
classes were only about four hours but i
was the only one in my family who had
class in the afternoon which is about
from two to six o'clock and by the time
i got home my parents aren't home yet
and my brothers and sisters are out with
my parents so i'm in the house by myself
with the housekeeper and the only thing
that was on tv was the news so i would
sit down and watch the news half an hour
before my parents came home so that's
how i got interested in news and how did
you get the c-span i um actually i
interned for cnn when i was at michigan
and uh couldn't find a job a year after
i graduated i went to work for a design
firm in michigan and moved to washington
and start to look for a job in
broadcasting but to no avail so i went
to work for the u.s chamber of commerce
and uh interviewed for a job at c-span a
year later so how long have you been
since been now two and a half years
back to this trip
basically has it been easy for you to
communicate in vietnamese
up and down the coast
during the last week
i find people to be terribly inefficient
more so than i've ever remembered to be
the vietnamese have always been known i
think we probably took after the french
that we're late going everywhere we're
never on time uh we're terribly
inefficient a lot of bureaucracy and i
think it's worse now
when we were in the restaurant as you
can tell
you know you wait 20 minutes for your
receipts you wait uh you know 35 minutes
for your meal and and i speak the
language and sometimes they don't even
you know get the orders right so people
are i'm not sure if people are enjoying
their jobs or they're not paying
attention to what i'm saying
but you and you had orders that were
mixed up
so
where did you learn your impatience in
the united states uh actually my parents
have always been
a very anti-tardy
my dad works for the us
for the americans so they're always very
on time and they can't stand being late
or being pushed around
so
back to what it's like growing up in
this society
back to yourself how do you think you
would live differently if you never left
here what do you think your interest
would be is there any way of knowing you
know that's that's a good question
because my parents we we've talked about
this because a lot of my relatives
didn't leave
in 75 they left in 70 which is about
three years after we left and they had a
horrible time dealing with it
uh i think it's because a lot of them
went to school in the united states so
to them to think that there's no freedom
here there's you know you can't say
whatever you want to you can't go
anywhere you want to
and they've put them in re-education
camps for months on end or years
i don't think my parents could have
dealt with that
but then again it's a very different
story if you had to live here and you
have to go through the same thing that
everybody did i think you would have to
what else can you do get any sense of a
deep ideology among the people here in
south um you know i
the one thing that i really noticed
between the difference between south
vietnam and north vietnam is that
ho chi minh is a lot
more prevalent out there than here i'm
not sure how these people if you ask
them what they would say about him and i
not sure that they would like him as
much as the people in the north i mean
these people are used to having their
freedom before 1975 and after that it's
a tough life for them and i can't
imagine that they would say anything
that's positive about
what she meant here what about language
you speak fluent english you would never
know that you ever set foot in vietnam
uh was that difficult when you were
sure it's difficult i had french before
so it makes it a lot easier when you
know a language and you learn another
one it is difficult but it's much
younger when you're young
to learn another language because you
can pick it up a lot easier and faster
and of course tv helps a lot because
when you watched american tv
nothing you know there's no other
language but american but english so you
sit there and you go through it so you
pick it up much faster
a lot of places we've gone here
with our crews people always pick you
out and they say
and they'll whisper to me is she
american
why do they know that you're american
how can they pick it out i think it's
the way i dress um the way i walk i walk
much faster than most people do i'm
around some americans actually they
think you guys are french so i'm
surprised that uh they ask you if i'm if
i'm an american i think we really like
that french no i don't yeah why do they
think we're french are they think we're
russian no they don't think you're
russian they think you're french because
i think there used to be a lot of french
who live in this country
and a lot of people come back and visit
so they automatically assume you know
that
any foreigners who come here who are not
uh asian would be french
why don't we walk out there and let greg
follow us away from these folks who want
to get on with
their it seems like up and down vietnam
at least the biggest thing is the noise
is really high
uh
of course and i know they didn't have
any cars
[Applause]
[Music]
which is surprising i don't remember any
of these people and they remember my
parents
well let's see what's it been 17 17
years yeah have there been others here
in the neighborhood that remember your
friends um yeah actually the woman who
just sat here remember my parents also
there's also a woman who lives about
four doors down she left uh i think
couple days before we did she now lives
in california
but i don't remember any of these people
what about
this week let me just walk over here in
a couple minutes what about this week
what has been
what have been the most memorable things
most memorable things that i left the
city
as saigon and i came back as ho chi minh
city huge difference
it's a lot poorer nothing is kept up the
streets are not kept up the houses are
not kept up
the people are different they're no
longer the same people i remember i left
of course a lot of people who are our
friends and people that we usually
are friends with you know
are all gone these people are totally
entirely different people and what
when we talked to um
senator john kerry the other day at
breakfast and he said
i hate to be impolite but what you have
in this country now is a lot of peasants
running the country and that's what they
are they're people from the village who
are up here
running the country they're no longer
people who you know who are in politics
people who are in the pa
who are interested in running a country
people are in politics running the
country
is there something that you want to do
you haven't done yet
um
no not really i haven't i wanted to uh
go visit my uncle but when i went to his
house wife told me that he's in hanoi
and he's coming back on sunday so i'd
love to see him a couple a couple of my
dad's friends you visited with an uncle
in hanoi i visited with an uncle in
hanoi what was that like i have never
met him
he instead of going down south in 54 he
decided to stay in hanoi he was in the
army for 10 years
it was an interesting talk
very interesting person i was very
surprised to find out that after living
there for so many years that he's not
he's not
he doesn't like alcohol he doesn't like
communism he doesn't think they're
efficient
he doesn't like the way of life there
and he did come down
down here down south to visit my other
uncle who lives here and he really liked
it down here and he said that if he were
to live here he would have moved to
united states
do you think he'd ever come back after
this trip would i ever come back yeah
sure
i'm not sure i could live here anymore
but short to visit
yeah
let's take a look around the
neighborhood
[Music]
it's on a busy street it's this way
you're probably about this size when
no i doubt it i think i was about this
side really yeah
is this the same school
same name school same name
and if it were open we would go in there
saigon
zoo is the name of the street
can you remember
what this school taught you
sure a lot of math
a lot of reading
that's pretty much the four hours
there's not much to there's not much
teaching in four hours there's a lot of
homework the teacher will
you come in you do an hour math you and
then you take a little recess
and then you go to another time you know
the subject
which is usually language and reading
and
she'll lecture for an hour and she
lectures and she also requires a lot of
class participation so to make sure that
you've done your homework
and then she'll go on to science
and she'll go on to
another topic but usually
math would be the first subject what
kind of school was this it's a public
school um
it's four hours a day so kids around the
area who lives here would enroll in here
um so all the years what years were you
within school well i was here when i was
uh in third grade so it's elementary
into
fifth grade
is the school system different here than
it is in the united states well the
school system is very different here in
the united states when you enroll in a
school you're there for about six and a
half to seven hours a day here you only
you're only in school for four hours
that's not that's uh including recess so
a lot of time you spend studying is on
your own time not at school so you want
to make sure they want to make sure that
you go home and you do your homework and
it's more independent than in the united
states
where
which system has better education
i think the system has a better
education they're very tough here
they're tougher in a french school where
i also went
because education is very important you
know your parents who always stress
education
everywhere you go people stress
education
and they have a good school system here
why did the vietnamese do so well in the
united states and in schools i think
it's because they come from a very
strong
education background so you have a head
start
did your parents really uh push you into
learning sure my parents i don't i have
to say that i don't have strict parents
but where education is concerned they're
very strict
by the way what'd your parents think
when you first called them and said hey
i'm going back to excitement my parents
were very excited
i had talked to them about
me going back with my sister
for a visit for vacation
and they weren't thrilled about that
idea for some reason because they didn't
think that you know traveling to women
traveling alone is a good idea but they
were really thrilled that i wanted to go
back and i wanted to see what it's like
after 75 will they come back
i think they will uh i think after i
talk to my parents on the phone i think
they will come back have you talked to
him on this trip i talked to them for
about 10 minutes yesterday
and what'd they say what was the
reaction well they said it's very neat
they asked me you know if i remember
certain places or somebody if i can
visit somebody yet
he said we're not supposed to film this
place without permission
why why not
because he said you just can't walk into
a school and do whatever you
you want to build it yeah
it didn't make any difference it doesn't
make any difference is that something
new with this regime do you think oh i
think so huh yeah
definitely you know when we were in that
school uh the university yesterday
did you did you find any restrictions on
the part of the kids on what they could
say
well i noticed a lot of people when you
asked them about ho chi minh
some of them didn't like him but of
course they said well we think he's a
good man
i don't know why i mean i i'm sure
there's some people who don't agree with
him
but they just don't say it so i there is
the limitations
and restrictions on what they can say
this is a public school can you remember
or did you ever talk to parents about
how much money they had to spend in
order to support the schools no i don't
remember i we also my parents also sent
us to a french school which cost a lot
more
money before i transferred to the school
that's about how
big you were yeah
bye
thank you
jaclyn what's that sign say laying up
against your school that sign is a sign
that ho chi minh says strong people
lives in a strong country
and is this a sign that they put out
here just because you think because it
was a school
oh i'm not sure it was never here when i
was here but it could yeah
yeah i'm sure since the school it's
probably a way to uh now you would not
see ho chi minh's name down here before
you left would you no no never
never
and people don't even talk about him
that much
you get a sense that the young kids are
taught about ho chi minh at real early
age i think they taught
about ho chi minh at young age because
they want to brainwash the kids did you
get any sense of what he stand what
uncle ho stands for
not they wouldn't tell him specifically
what he stands for
probably not they probably tell him that
you know he's a great leader he could
mobilize the people he won the war but
beyond that what he's done for the
country besides
uniting the north and the south beyond
that there's they probably don't they
don't tell them
me
uh
what's this next stop
this is my grandmother's house her
number is 88 i always remember because
we always park
right underneath the number
is your grandmother still alive no she
died in 77.
what do you remember about your girl she
um
came with us actually
uh in 77 but she had a recurrence with
cancer and died in little rock
did you come over here when you were a
little kid yeah i came over here a lot
actually i came over here about two
nights per week
this is my grandmother's house her
number is 88 i always remember because
we always park
right underneath the number
is your grandmother still alive no she
died in 77.
what do you remember about your girl she
um
came with us actually
uh in 77 but she had a recurrence with
cancer and died in little rock
did you come over here when you were a
little kid yeah i came over here a lot
actually i came over here um about two
nights per week
and then we spent two other nights at my
other aunt's or an uncle's house this is
a little courtyard they used to park
their cars here
this is this house right here where my
uncle lived
uh it's a separate house from where my
grandparents lived my grandparents live
around the corner from here you have to
walk upstairs
does this look the same to you yeah
you walk upstairs and they live upstairs
about the paint and the all that stuff
you know the cleaning the side of this
oh it's much cleaner it was much cleaner
much cleaner yeah
what about families in vietnam family is
very important you you spend a lot of
time with your family all your relatives
only all at least all of my relatives
live in saigon so we're only about 10 to
15 minutes from each other we see each
other every week holidays
is the big
gathering with everybody not only with
your immediate family but also with your
cousins
and other people remember one of the
officials we were talking to up in hanoi
mentioned that
the united states in his opinion had
begun begun to care more about the older
people
why would he say something like that why
because in this society the oldest child
is responsible of taking care of their
parents when they grow old so it doesn't
matter if it's a daughter or a son that
person will always be responsible for
their parents that means that
their parents will live with the older
son or daughter
when they get old wouldn't this have
been an expensive place
um
it's um
well you as you can see it's bigger
it's bigger house than uh
you know where where we live
it was but they purchased it um in 54 so
it can't be that expensive but the next
house over which is number i think it's
number 90
had been fixed up and it's my mother's
cousin's house and it's a lot nicer
because they've spent a lot of money
fixing it up
but they don't really live here
the full year they live part-time in
paris and the house they just have a
housekeeper they're keeping it what
happened to this house when your parents
left to go to the states um my
grandparents my grandmother left with us
and my grandfather remained here
for uh
he just left this place he sold this
house two years ago he went to the
united states he lives in la right now
with my uh my aunt so you have a
grandfather alive in the united states
just one mm-hmm
well our trip's about over uh are you
going to be sad to leave or i think i
will be sad to leave um i i never
thought that i would be back in this
house actually when i'm looking at these
flower pots they're still the same ones
that my my dad took a picture of me of
us with my sisters in 1968
same flower pots we used to walk up here
go here twice a week go up the stairs
and they live upstairs
well thanks for uh letting us
kind of stick our nose into your life
you're welcome can we
go back out and find the van
that's the the uh
do you have a dog by the way
no
what is that the same firepower all of
these are the same flower pots
all of these
katie kelly what would be the difference
uh
between what the experience that
jacqueline has had in her life than some
of the amerasians that you taught while
you're over there well for one thing i
think jackie came from a very
stable family and a very centered family
and she had
a mother and a father and relatives and
a chance at an education
and that's certainly what a lot of these
kids didn't have i mean right off the
bat the admiration didn't have a father
and in many cases depending on whether
they were abandoned by a mother or the
mother died or the mother one of my
students mother was assassinated by the
viet cong
or even if the mother was able to to
keep the admiration
you know they grew up without a father
they didn't have the stability of a home
and they didn't have the stability of a
house and they certainly
didn't have an education
katie kelly has been with us all day and
is going to stay with us for another
couple of hours the book you saw on the
screen a year in saigon is her new book
and this was from her experience living
in vietnam in a 10 a night hotel
for a year the year being 1990 teaching
american children english
jacqueline pham what about looking back
uh four months later at your
tape of your experience over there
uh it seems like it's been so long ago
it seems almost like a year but it's
really only been four months
i had seen my parents since then they
came to visit me right after the trip
i haven't had time to go home this year
and i went out to california to visit my
mother's uh
brother and her sister out there but
didn't get to see my grandfather and
they all had seen the tape what was
their reaction are they surprised by
anything um no they weren't are they
surprised by your attitude about the
communists uh no no i'm i i think i
share some of their attitudes so i don't
think they were surprised
did you get did you get terribly
emotional when you went back to saigon
for the first time i
at first i didn't because i was with
these guys and we were working as i was
saying in the piece um but then at the
end it was because it's really hard to
leave um
i saw my dad's
brother when i was there and i and um
the thing is that i don't know when i'm
gonna go see him again um i don't know
when i'll get a chance to go over there
again it seems like when we were
traveling it was just so easy just to go
over there and we had very little
from what i remembered um
bureaucracy when we were there with the
exception of brian lamb standing at the
embassy in bangkok for three days but
you know he was doing that i wasn't so i
thought it was really easy but uh when i
was was reading the parade magazine
about two weeks ago in the washington
post
and james webb who's the former navy
secretary had all kinds of problems
going back and getting out of the
airport exactly and it's almost you know
with me bureaucracy is not a cup it's
not my cup of tea so i'm not going to go
back
anytime real soon for that
um i think i was lucky with the
journalist visa when i got out on my own
the c-span crew left on sunday and i
didn't leave into the following tuesday
and get out on my own it was pretty easy
well the thing that struck me about
about vietnam is in the bureaucracy is
that it all seems so whimsical
that
one person or one office will do do this
and one person in another office will do
that and that was kind of the joke about
getting a visa or a travel permit if
this guy said no we'll go to that guy or
go to that guy and you never knew when
they were going to strike next like
james webb couldn't get out of the
airport you had no problem i should
explain your reference to me was that i
had this took me three days in bangkok
at the vietnamese embassy in bangkok
waiting for approval of our visas in
order for us to be able to get in there
and we were traveling
kind of with the delegation not with
them and you probably applied for them
weeks before oh yeah for months and yeah
but once we got in we had would you say
not not many problems no we did and we
didn't even have to go through customs
that's the other thing
um and you heard stories about people
having to go through customs before
having you know to open up their luggage
and they check everything and i i just
can't go through with that what what was
the reaction of of people to you
realizing that you were
a vietnamese now living in america
coming back to vietnam
some people thought i was arrogant
um
not realizing that i was there to work
you know
i'm totally different person when i work
where i go on my own people just think
like i'm one of them but in a different
way because i don't live there anymore
and it's obvious
i'm in and out you know i'm not there
really to stay
i'm a tourist in there
so i i'm in that sense i'm different but
i mean i speak the language i have no
problems going around there at all but
it is it is a shock to see the country
now oh it is the poverty is just
unimaginable
we're going to take phone calls in about
three minutes in your book you write
somewhat about and you talked about it
in the interview the conditions of
things there
what works now
in vietnam
there's another way of asking that what
doesn't work nothing works
we left an incredible infrastructure
there and it's it's literally been
destroyed i mean the roads aren't there
i mean they're all potholed the
telephones don't work
there's one fax machine at the rex hotel
and every once in a while it works
the electrical system is shot the
educational system is shot the medical
system is shot
i mean i mean they had an educational
system and a medical system
par excellence and it's it's gone
jacqueline pham is going to stay with us
for 20 minutes to answer calls but
before we go to calls i've got to ask
katie kelly to tell us the story because
i don't know which day it is this week
but we visit the same hospital that you
visited for the birth of a baby
the to do hospital
hospital
it's it's a woman's hospital and it's
literally run by women doctors and you
know brilliant doctors doing work with
absolutely nothing i mean they
reuse surgical gloves they reuse
examination gloves they reuse needles
okay knock on the door one night and
it's the amerasian couple where are you
i'm in saigon in what hotel i'm in the
kimdo hotel the bats are flying outside
knock on the door and it's she's having
the baby
that sounds like a paul anka song right
outside the and i mean she's standing
there holding her stomach and i think oh
my god so we get her downstairs get her
into a sequel and go to the hospital
what's a cyclone the sequel is i keep
describing it as sort of a
bicycle-powered rickshaw the driver sits
in the back
pumping sort of a bicycle contraption
and you sit in a in the death seat i got
a picture here i'll show you go ahead
okay so anyway
they take this one this young amerasian
woman in and she's you know she's in the
final stages of labor and the husband
just literally passes out in the hallway
so they take me and then
about mother to be into the uh into the
delivery room
now the thing that we all have to
remember about this
is that the closest i have ever been to
pregnancy or childbirth has been a movie
or a tv show that i've reviewed
but of course i know everything i know
absolutely everything there is lamaze
breathing techniques the whole thing
they sit me down on a stool and to make
a long story short this poor american is
over there having her baby and i
take one look at what is going on and i
just
pass out flat on the floor every doctor
obviously leaves this poor woman in the
middle of the birth and rush over to
pick this stupid american woman up off
the floor
it was a healthy baby boy
i must say and you know when we were
there and i'm trying to find i think
it's on
should have yeah here i think it's a
show the day that uh it's on wednesday
that you'll see our visit to the to do
hospital we went right into that
that i think the same room with the
birth of the baby and they just the
doors just opened up and we were there
right in the middle of an operation
there you are but with no with no
screening with our cameras and
everything i know you'll cover this more
on wednesday were there all the
premature babies in the hospital that
when you were there
we didn't see the premiums we didn't see
the homies but we
saw
the babies that they thought were uh
infected by agent orange no no but this
was just a award filled with hundreds of
premiums you say that you had no
incubators three or four of them in the
same incubator without the incubator
being on yeah i mean because the number
one the incubators roll and there was no
electricity and it's
we've got a call river falls wisconsin
go ahead please good afternoon hi my
husband and i went to
vietnam back in february of 1990 looking
for his amerasian son
when we got there we found the mother of
the son only she had given the boy up
when he was about a year old
and there hasn't been any mention of
that at all on the program today i
wanted to mention that that the mothers
many times did give the children up for
their own self-survival
but i also want to mention too that
during the process of all this my
husband have been trying to find him for
many many years and
the bureaucracy between vietnam and the
united states is just staggering and it
gets very depressing sometimes
there is a lady from madison wisconsin
who has gone over there a couple of
different times and talked to the odp
and that type of a thing
but the only problem is is the mother
did not remember uh but the first names
of the people that she had given the
child who so were
you know it's just very very depressing
thank god i mean these
i mean this it's just tragedy upon
tragedy i mean here's a man looking for
his son and and i understand that that
women
gave their children up
sometimes for the best of reasons and
the best of intentions that that they
just simply couldn't cope with it and
couldn't deal you say that sometimes
they're sold
uh well
these days because an amerasian can lead
you out of the country there are people
who want to come around and buy your
amerasian your 18 or 20 year old
admiration and you know make them their
child um so so they could qualify to get
out of the country have you had any
experience knowing amerasians here in
this country since you've been here no i
haven't but my sister who works for
an agency in grand rapids michigan works
with american children and that agency
is actually trying to open an office in
saigon for their amerasian children it's
sort of like a nutrition center and i
think they had somebody two weeks ago
and going over there to to do a site
survey uh and they she deals with
amerasian children who are brought over
here
as foster children and she finds foster
parents for them
but personally i do not at the bottom of
the hour we're going to visit with three
students in hanoi via videotape houston
texas go ahead please yes um my wife is
amerasian and she was very lucky i mean
her mother was a wealthy vietnamese
woman and so they left in 73
and she's had no problem with education
and all that but i was wondering if the
problem with education and
and all the other problems that the
other immigrations are having in vietnam
does part of it stem from their past
economic status
it stems from there being americans
number one and they just were literally
hounded out of the educational system
in 1975 when the communists came in so
that's the first reason and the second
reason is is economic that you
despite the fact that it's a communist
country you pay for your education
and even if they could have found a
school that would would accept them
they had to pay for it and they had no
money did you get any sense that any of
your relatives that are still back in
vietnam want to come here
uh
the ones that i have left back there uh
they do not and what did they give you a
reason uh just because my uncle used to
work for the american embassy over there
and he's receiving his pension and at
one point he did want it to go but then
the the paperwork which just took
forever and now that he has the go-ahead
to go he doesn't want to go anymore he
said he's fine with his life the way it
is he's been retired uh for about 15
years now he plays tennis twice a week
also this the system has opened up so
much in the past few years not only
economically but socially right since
1986
with the
policy over there and he doesn't want to
leave and i don't blame him take this
call and then we'll watch
your encounter with the lottery salesman
los angeles california go ahead please
hello hi hi um i just want to say i'm
really happy to see this program on and
i'm a 17 year old vietnamese male in los
angeles
and i just wanted to ask because i've
been i don't know if jacqueline would
grieve me but
i haven't learned a lot about the
admiration children and
uh here we've started to see a lot
working in restaurants and everything
but
in
in vietnam are they still
treated
um
without any right rights or anything
because i've heard that
vietnamese people really look down on
the admiration children caller were you
born here or there i was born in saigon
but we escaped when i was two months old
and how are you doing out there i'm
doing really good there's still a lot of
non-education with my american friends
and they really think that it was a war
between america and vietnam vietnam
period and they just think that i was an
enemy or whatever but i think that there
should be a lot more education
is there any effort made in your high
school teaching you anything about the
vietnam war
not really there's just bits and pieces
here but
my friends really don't get it i mean
they don't get the north and south and
it's just really sad and it's very
frustrating on my part thanks for
calling back to his original question
about how the amerasians are treated
there
well now it's it's obviously a little
bit better but but they're kind of in a
limbo
time now because they are getting out
now whether it takes another year or two
there really isn't much more that that
can be done against these poor kids at
this point it's already been done katie
kelly's book looks like this if you've
just joined us she's agreed to spend the
day with us here down from new york
she used to be with nbc was a television
critic movies and broadway and lots of
other things such an easy life
compared to well compared to what these
kids and i think that was part of it i
mean i came home and just was
overwhelmed with guilt
when you look at how i had grown up and
compared to how these kids had grown up
were you taught much about the vietnam
war anywhere in your educational
experience not in high school i took a
course in college only because i went to
university of michigan as a huge school
and all the classes at michigan pretty
much most of the classes at the liberal
arts program
had about 200 students and i just
happened to talk i took a vietnam
history course only because
it's the course that i could get in i
signed up for the history of china and
couldn't get in because i was number 97
on the wait list and in the vietnam
history of course i was number 27 i
could get in so i took it
as a credit but it was really good but a
lot of high schools do not offer vietnam
history because it's just too extensive
it takes up probably a good semester to
go through the involvement over there
and there's just no time for that
a lot of colleges are offering vietnam
history and they are very popular of
course uh it's already fall it's always
full at michigan and i'm sure at other
universities would you both think as we
take this next call about what we missed
you know you were there you helped
produce this whole thing what we missed
what we weren't able to get through that
tube out there to the people that are
watching and what we miss by not being
able to be there you know what what's
lost in the translation springfield
missouri go ahead please hi brian hi
i'd just like to thank you for c-span um
the only reason i have cable is because
of it
but
i wanted to say something about the
bureaucracy i've i lived overseas i
lived in asia from the time i was about
eight until i was 18
and
i feel like what jacqueline was talking
about as much the same in most of asia i
live particularly indonesia and
my parents are missionaries and we go
through this quite frequently with
having to go from one agency to the
other agency to the other agency and
there's really no rhyme or reason to
what they're doing so i don't know if
that's just particular to vietnam or if
that's just typical
typically the way the asians uh do it
what what would you think
have you been to any other countries in
asia
uh i was in hong kong and it's just fine
but then i didn't have to deal with any
government officials i think any time
when you have to go through the
government from anything i mean for
example if you go through the defense
department here
it would be a huge bureaucracy so i
can't really say it's only in asia or
other nations i think any time when you
have to deal with the government it's
like that and you should be prepared for
it
what are we missing
not only what are we missing but what
are you missing in your book that you
can't get through that you see when
you're there well
again it's this affection that they that
all the people seem to have for the
americans and i do mention it at one
point in the book that this to me is the
one place that the the communist the
vietnamese communists really fell down
on
their current propaganda there are kids
growing up in in vietnam under the
communist regime
who don't who should be being taught to
hate americans because his network
communism is all about what are we
missing
and they're not no i i think you're
right yeah
they've never been taught to hate us
right and they don't i'm not sure they
listen to the government that much it's
really
you know that i earlier when you were
talking about there's a difference
between the vietnamese government the
vietnamese people which is true
because the the government
hates the americans but not the people
the government doesn't have it doesn't
mean yeah what about little things like
paint
it looks i mean looking at your school
there it looked nice is it i mean i
remember
you know some things look a lot better
on the tube than they do in person right
i don't want to be terribly critical
because i'm not sure that
you know you can't remember all the
details but what was your experience
well i'll tell you that
the experience along those lines is in
hanoi whereas where it's so wet and the
mildew starts creeping up and you just
see this black mildew creeping up and
all the vines that are clutching into
the buildings and no matter how much
they clean and how much they paint
they can't get rid of it and they have
no money to do it by the way i found the
name c-span in your book yes i was
reading and i want to show the audience
that were mentioned here but i want to
it's almost derogatory though katie
kelly what is it doing in this book
what i was saying they have all these
video parlors around town that play
bootleg mtv videos and everybody goes
and watches you know janet jackson and
george michael and all these people and
i was going on and on about what kind of
propaganda is this they should be
showing them america's most wanted and
you know current affairs for an affair
911 would be better than this
here's
here's a little visit to a lottery
salesman in hanoi
let's listen in
[Music]
[Music]
how much is a ticket card
[Music]
just every day
tonight
[Music]
so did you win any money no brian bought
the ticket so let's just buy any tickets
what how much could you win
10 million don which is 11 000 to the
that would be dollar a thousand dollars
or a hundred dollars quick help me out
here they play this down in saigon oh
yeah
where do they get to me what i don't
know i've near i do not understand the
flow of money but what's what strikes me
is the first time i went to vietnam
there were two thousand seven hundred
dong to the dollar and now you say it's
up to each other it's eleven thousand
yeah
in april when when we were there
that's that's wiped out a lot of savings
on the screen this is something we wanna
show the audience on the screen we kept
seeing these hats all over the place
with usa on it you got the impression
that uh you know maybe that they've been
brought over from the usa
that's a no it's in a little store in
hanoi where they stencil on
on these patches different things and i
think that may be an airline i'm not
sure it might be united airlines for all
and i mean the other one though is usa
and then you would would press them onto
a hat
and sell them you saw them everywhere
all corporate logos are up for grabs
arlington virginia go ahead please oh hi
um i went to vietnam in 1987 with a
group uh we were the first american
college students to be in vietnam since
the end of the war
um
we were very well received we both in
hanoi and in uh
ho chi minh city and hawaii um and i'm
just i'm i'm a little i just want to
bring up the point that uh seems to be
uh awful lot of criticism going on about
vietnam and what a terrible
infrastructure it is and those sorts of
things and i i think uh it's important
to consider the fact that the us um not
to mention what they accomplished during
the war uh structural damage but also
since the end of the war uh really the
us has been waging an economic war
against vietnam no foreign aid just over
the past six months
non-governmental organizations have been
allowed to take things like wheelchairs
in and whatnot
i've worked for organizations that
wanted to send a needle and a
sewing needle and some yarn
uh to make sweaters uh the government
says no you can't send those sorts of
things because that would be promoting
jobs uh in vietnam you can send the
sweater but you can't send the needle
and the
yarn and i just wondering if uh
if you all would comment on
what if you know or what you feel about
the u.s policy there and also that this
september bush can renew or not renew
the u.s trade embargo on vietnam and
i think you might see a lot of things
get a lot better very quickly if uh if
that trade embargo is not renewed teddy
kelly well everyone agrees that one of
them
you know in addition to the to the
communist another one of the major
reasons for the economic
problems in vietnam is the american
trade embargo
and and and not only that we refuse
to trade with them but we put pressure
on our own allies not to trade with them
although they kind of
kind of slip through but yes he's
absolutely right zanberry connecticut
you're next
hello hi you're on the air good
afternoon sir hi good afternoon lady
good afternoon uh i really applaud your
book and
the lady on
what's the name jacqueline
yes i'm really grateful and my name is
i come american back to 1982
and
when i look at back on the
picture on the movie back saigon or
hanoi it seemed like
a lot of different
because when they took over
south vietnam
back to 75 and
everything is horrible
caller did you say you came here this
year
uh no uh 81 82. and how old were you
when you came to the united states uh
i think about 15. and where were you
from
uh saigon what was the reason you came
here
um for a freedom
did you have your parents here or do you
have relatives
no i don't how did you get out
i escaped yet i work for somebody and i
skip out by boat
and where did you go from when you got
into the boat where did you land
uh
i landed at the philippines
then what and i stayed there for about a
year and a half and then i went to
america
and how has it been so far since you've
been in the states
uh it's great but i still miss my
country a lot
uh i wish americans can do something
to trade and get the people you know
they can go back to vietnam more easier
well right now i'm afraid to go back
there
all right thank you for the call
jacqueline pham you came in with your
parents
have you talked with many people since
you've been here and grown up here
like this gentleman who came in by boat
and they have a different experience
than you did
my aunts came in by boat in 1978
and they don't they came in seven eight
three years after we did
and they hated the condition there they
couldn't
couldn't live there anymore
i'm sure if they could they would have
but it was just unbearable for them and
it was finally time when they escaped
and they thought you know they really
thought they were going to die at sea
because it was the boat was so crowded
the condition was horrible they were
floating on a boat for a month
before they reached malaysia
and
got to malaysia and stayed in the camp
for about six months and then they came
to the u.s
[Music]
if it wasn't that bad people would still
stay there but it was really bad that
people had to get out so
i and i'm sure there are still a lot of
people who want to get out because the
condition is so horrible and there's
just no future there really
um if they if the us doesn't normalize
relations with vietnam there's very
little future left over there especially
for the kids for the adults you know um
they've been through it they've been
through
the war before from the north down south
and this is just another experience that
they've gone through but for the kids
it's difficult yeah i mean you talk
about what the conditions were like
after 1975 i mean the present
was so terrible for people immediately
after
uh
the communists came in
but now it's the future and and that's
exactly right the people just feel they
have absolutely no future and if we
don't lift the embargo they really don't
have a future candy can i what was the
hardest thing about writing this book
i don't think there was anything
difficult about it are you a natural
writer well i like to write it's the
only thing i can sort of do but it was
just kind of
reliving
uh the lives of of these kids and and
realizing how how tough it had been for
them did you take a diary or keep a
diary when you're in vienna i always
keep a diary and i i thought i was just
keeping a little travel
journal
and also some of the stories and some of
the anecdotes uh i just kept retelling
them to myself because i just couldn't
believe some of these things that were
happening so it kind of imprinted
adopted any of these children no but i
sponsored three kids
who came over last year which ones
briner cute headies in the batman
t-shirt that had his teeth knocked out
living in chicago got a job now
and um ton who was a black amerasian
came out
t-h-a-n-h
came out of vietnam completely
illiterate because she had been
hadn't even been allowed to enter the
school system
and her vietnamese half brother
lynn
and where are they they have moved on to
worcester massachusetts
and
how they doing ton
speaks english a mile a minute i don't
know if she'll ever be fluent in written
english and she's a fry cook at
mcdonald's
thank you very much
stafford virginia you're next hi um
i'm i'm really interested in getting
your book because i really like it katy
kelly thank you
yeah my mom's vietnamese my dad's
american you know all right the war
and well i was wondering um
is it hard to go over there because i
have
my grandmother there and i have half
brother who i've never met oh my god
someday i'd like to meet him he's only a
couple years older than i am now are
your mother and father together here in
the states yeah see i was born
you were born here yeah oh
and how old are you i'm 20.
and is it you're having difficulty at
all being you're not an amerasian really
are you no i'm american i'm an american
girl yeah well you you have do you have
uh are you do you look amerasian well i
kind of have my mom's eyes you know i
look sort of but then i got my dad's
height so i'm really tall i kind of look
funny
[Laughter]
what advice uh jacqueline you've been
back
what advice would you give her about
going back to
uh
or going to vietnam for the first time i
guess yeah it's tough to go over there
for the first time um
applying for visa is not the easiest
thing
um should she be able to go then visit
sure i yeah i think her big oh sure but
actually you know you can go through an
agency through bangkok that could book
your uh ticket and take care of your
visa for you or a canadian agency or a
hong kong agency or bank you have to go
through chester be reminded you have to
go through a third country to get a visa
but it is possible um i think it would
be a very emotional trip for her but i
think i mean
god forbid that i should ever give
anybody any advice but i think i think
it would be good for her
last call until we go back we're going
to visit with some students who went
over there to live and study and learn
vietnamese after we take this call from
irvine california go ahead please hi my
name is laurel van i'm
almost a little bit younger than
jacqueline and i just graduated from
college also my concern is my brother
just came back to palawan and it's an
island in the philippines where a lot of
the boat people stop on their way to
america
and the problem right now i see is that
i feel so bad for these people um
a lot of them are trying to come over
but the paperwork is just not going very
well now how long have you been here
i've been here since five years so i've
been here like about almost 20 years
in america you've been here for 20 years
yeah um
like that's when i left 1925.
um
i was watching that well my my concern
was that um
these people um
they come over
you know through the boat and everything
and um the camp situation is really bad
some of the people get really abused
they get
the people who work there the philippine
people and stuff there's a lot of racism
and i'm just concerned it's the american
people where american government where
is it are they aware of the situation in
these camps and are they doing anything
about it thanks i think they are aware
of it and and uh this is an american
camp by the way it i'm this one i i
believe all of these are united nations
camps uh and this one is down actually
down the road from where the amerasians
go
for six months but i certainly voiced my
concerns about
the the camp that the amerasians are in
and
they're better than most
they're certainly better than the ones
in cambodia and they're certainly better
than the conditions
in hong kong
but that doesn't mean that that there
aren't a lot of problems in these camps
and it's on the way that they're
administered
do you have any desire to go back to
vietnam and live
um
it's kind of hard to say that because
when i'm when i was over there i said i
could never live there anymore
um seeing the country the way it is and
the way it's run it's really
disappointing but when i'm over here
and i get bored sometimes and i think i
could go back there and live because
it's so interesting i'm always i'm
constantly fascinated when i was over
there
um
so i think i could but it would have to
change considerably and i would have to
change considerably to live over there
jacqueline when do you get bored
oh
it's so easy to get bored and you i mean
you know
you can't really do the same thing
for years and years
you can't live in the same place for you
know
20 years i could never do that
so it's a change and i think it would be
good for some people and i'm sure there
are tons of people who would love to go
and work over there because it's so
interesting and it's opening up yeah and
there's so many opportunities over there
katie kelly you're going to be with us
for another hour and 25 minutes are you
holding up okay i'm okay i'm okay
what's your last question quick question
to you about this book what's your
favorite
thing in this book
anything in particular i don't think
there's anything in particular yeah i
wish i could come up with something
witty but
you're normally yeah well sorry about
that i'll think about it do you miss
television by the way no
boy that came out fast didn't it it did
yeah but you say that in the book though
no i have my new life and it's it's
absolutely wonderful jacqueline pham
thank you
you're welcome for your time and what's
this favorite question what questions
what's your favorite thing in the book
what's your favorite story what's your
favorites have you read this book yet no
i haven't come on jacqueline
get out of here it's only 22.00 you get
a special deal over one of the discount
books hey if you're bored read this book
you know don't come whining to us
next up american students in hanoi we'll
be back in about uh i guess about 30
minutes to continue this discussion
marissa could you give us your full name
and tell us where you're from and how
you got to hanoi
um i'm marisa lau
and i'm from the university of hawaii
and i came to hanoi because the
university of hawaii has an exchange
program with the university of hanoi
here
so
everything was set up for us and we were
given some funds to come through various
organizations and that's why i'm here
are you from hawaii yes what park
honolulu how long have you been here
i've been here since october last year
so i guess about seven months
sean how about your full name
my name is sean milani
and i'm at the university of michigan
i've been here
for over two years
doing
initially doing language work
and then after that i began doing
research for my phd in cultural
anthropology
so you're in graduate work yes
yes i'm in cultural anthropology
grace how about you what's your full
name and where are you from my name is
grace chang i'm from new york city and
i'm with the university of hawaii
exchange program with noah university
also
studying mainly vietnamese language i
was here for four months last year doing
some research on traditional theater and
this this year i'm just going to do
language training
what do you think of all this
studying here or being here
i think i think it's great it's really
fun it's very relaxed and there's a lot
of things happening
what have you learned
language
about the culture
um yeah i've learned about that too
learned about how people live and
basically
different ways how they perceive life
they're different from
in our country another country
give us an example
what's
different well i mean just the concept
of space here they're
their housing is very
very sparse very small areas where large
members of people live in and it's it's
their the way they live communally is a
lot different than our concept of having
privacy and
and then also you know that that really
um reflects in their the way we deal
with them and the way they deal with us
sean what have you learned
two years a long time two years yeah
well i suspect in uh
the main thing i've learned here is that
the whole process of
vietnamese getting used to foreigners
living in vietnam is
it has only just begun and that for the
vietnamese as i think much for the same
for americans
is that many of the
coming into the anonymous american
company is even as a foreigner that
there are many preconceptions
that the vietnamese have
and
living here you see that for both sides
there's so there's still some
understanding to
to come along yet
how many foreigners are here
i would suspect somewhere
in the range of on a full-time basis
somewhere in the range of two or three
hundred including united nations
personnel and embassy personnel how many
americans
americans are probably around 30 the
number fluctuates depending on whether
students are in session or not doing
what
uh well the majority of americans here
are students
and then outside of students there are
a handful of journalists
some un personnel
and beyond that just basic
non-governmental organization people
marissa what have you learned
i would i guess i agree with sean that
it's interesting to be here because
there's so much that's that's changing
right now and both for the vietnamese
and the foreigners who are trying to
come in here
there's um it's like a
interesting period of adaptation for
both of them and there's it's
a fairly wide open period and the
vietnamese are kind of feeling their way
around trying to see what uh
possibilities there may that may be
coming in the future and us
and i guess as an american it's been
interesting for me too because i have
felt very very welcome
i've never felt any animosity from
from anyone actually that i've been in
contact with and
except for maybe some europeans but
i guess that's been i've either been
very lucky but or or it's just been
a very
interesting thing for me anyway what's
left over i assume all of you are in
your 20s
yes what's left over from the vietnam
war
[Music]
does it ever come up
yeah for me in terms of my research it
comes up it comes up constantly
i work with a number of a lot of the
people that in the village i work in
were officers in the north vietnamese
army
served in the south fighting against the
americans
and a lot of people asked
they asked me where were you during the
war
and i was three or four years old
so i can't really
i
from there end it's
it's a it's a long-standing interest of
hearing what what you were in america
during the war what was the american
state of mind like at that point what
were americans thinking
what were what was how how developed was
the anti-war movement were there because
part of the vietnamese government
education on the war during the war time
was that the war of the vietnamese was
not against the american people
but against basically against the
american government and its policies
and so to come here as an american they
want to they want to find out more about
that you know what are the american
people like
they've had enough contact with the
government
and
now
having had you know many years two
decades of edu
education or what you might want to call
propaganda about the american people
they want to find out you know what is
it like for you
and frankly in a lot of my research time
i interview extensively but i also spend
a lot of time answering questions
grace how about you do you hear much
about the war
um
only from my teachers i haven't heard
people on the streets when i talk to
them don't bring it up when they when
they hear an american
my teachers generally explain a lot of
the historical background to vietnam to
me
and
they do have a very realistic
idea about the war i mean in very
practical terms that it was the
government and that this type of damage
was done for such and such political
reasons and yeah there's very little
animosity towards myself and
um
actually for me that
my teachers haven't haven't really had
any questions about
what i felt about the war
what are all three of you going to do
with your education once you leave here
well
i'm just probably going to look for
employment in private business or maybe
an intergovernmental organization with
vietnam yeah having to deal with vietnam
sean
i'll
hopefully take an academic job
teaching teaching anthropology and
vietnamese studies
marissa well after this i'll be going to
law school and
hopefully after that i'd like to do some
sort of business law in asia
one of the things we've found
in talking to people at least to the
officials is that ho chi minh
is at least outwardly revered they say
great things about him he's a great man
do you find that among the people when
the cameras aren't rolling
100
100
yep yeah definitely
100
undeniable
tell me more about
what they what they say about ho chi
minh
well ho chi minh was in a sense he was
the man who delivered the vietnamese
from the french from colonial occupation
and it was through his leadership that
the vietnamese were able to break away
from the french and establish
a fruitful free and independent nation
and
his dedication to the revolution and his
you know he began as a revolutionary in
the early 1900s
and carried on and he was a
revolutionary until his death tonight in
the late 1960s
and
for the vietnamese
there are a number of cultural heroes
that the vietnamese have and many of
them follow the same pattern
of an individual who
helped the vietnamese
break the yolk of foreign rule in
vietnam be it against the chinese
or as in the case of ho chi minh the
french
what have you learned about the
vietnamese people that
allowed them to either win all these
wars they had or at least not be
defeated
discipline
and sacrifice
marissa
i guess what they believe about
themselves is their their tenacity and
their
determination to overcome
outside aggression
they're very proud of that do they think
that the socialism system
communism works
that's an open question
i don't know
i think
a lot of people do have critical things
to say about it
from
what i've heard but much of the much the
criticism i've heard has been economic
is that in terms of
in terms of question and then again you
have to look at the north and the south
of vietnam and here in the north it's
very it's different from the south of
course
but in terms of the north here
a lot of the criticisms i hear of
socialism are just simply economic
and if you read the if you read the all
the local papers published by the party
paper or the paper by the army because
there is a constant threat of criticism
about you know we have to
we have to work out socialism
to a vietnamese model to make it fit
with the vietnamese circumstances
and the prime
focus
of this is the economy of how to make
the economy efficient and to make it
produce up to its
capacity
marissa you're going to say something
no basically i was going to say that
the same thing that
any of the discontent here is
with the
fact that the economic reforms that are
happening now are not happening fast
enough but
um there's still i think a lot of
respect for for the government here
compared to stay in china
and
i don't think the discontent is
as great as it would be in china right
now
how do you all live
well we were very lucky uh
we're and
they've been
allowing foreign students now to live
outside of
the designated dormitories
so we were able to grace and i were able
to get a an apartment in a private home
and i think that was this might be one
of the first times they've allowed that
this year
and there are a lot more of those that
are going to be opening up
you don't have to answer this but can
you tell us how much you pay a month
uh
i think it's about works out to about
130 or 120 a month which
is uh probably going to rise
four or five dollars a day
who do you pay that to
to the woman that owns the apartment
and is that high
no no i think that's quite low for a
foreigner to be living out in the
private guest house
usually i find it's a bit higher
and sean you don't live in hanoi no i do
live in hanoi
but i i live in a uh as she said there
is when i came two years ago it was
still in the era of
basically assigned housing for foreign
students
when i arrived i was placed in a guest
house of the ministry of forestry
and i lived there for about three
dollars a day ninety dollars a month
as marissa said recently they've they've
relaxed that policy somewhat and
students are able to live independently
i asked um one of the officials here
who was uh
talking about communism in ho chi minh
and how important it all was
and i i didn't want to be nasty but i
said if communism is so successful and
so good why are you one of the poorest
countries in the world
and i won't try to paraphrase his answer
but i'd ask you the same question
well does this system work here and if
it doesn't or does
you know
just give me your your own personal
reaction
well like i said economically they
realize they know why they're poor and
they know that things have to change if
they want to improve their life their
living standard and so in that sense i
would say it doesn't work but it's not
as if it's a
an unchanging system things are changing
and it's not
things are
more flexible than they would appear
i would say
that
in addressing the issue of socialism in
vietnam you have to separate out
the
the economy from the political
and
in many ways
as i think it's been adequately shown in
this as the party realizes
it isn't
it hasn't been successful the whole
structure of
trade
of agriculture of
just the whole structure of the economy
in many ways was
just it doesn't fit with economic
reality
and
as a result of that i would say no i
don't think it
that aspect of of socialism does work
but i think on the other hand that
vietnam is an asian country it is an
east asian country and as many other
countries in the region show
that you know vietnam and the party
maintains that a one-party system in
vietnam
and
i think frankly that
it could be and it is quite viable here
that there's not uh
just as it's viable in many other
countries in east asia are you saying
it's better that it's a one-party system
than if they had choice
i don't know i don't know what sort of
choice would emerge and i don't know
what
i don't know how much uh
chaos would emerge as a result of that
and that that that is the you know the
primary concern of the party here is
that you'll have a scenario emerge like
china or you'll have a scenario emerge
like eastern europe
where the party where one party system
is so completely out of sync
with the reality of the citizenry that
it ultimately just completely loses all
prestige and acceptance amongst the
people and is overthrown
and i think the vietnamese
government here in the party in
particular has been very adept and has
been very astute
at keeping abreast of the trends of
keeping abreast of what sort of changes
need to be made and what sort of
liberalization needs to go on
and
i think that you know i i think that
frankly the party in many ways could
survive here and i don't see any type of
apocalyptic scenario as you saw in
eastern europe grace um
what do americans have that vietnamese
don't in terms of material
about just about everything we've got
larger refrigerators or refrigerators at
all and electrical appliances we've got
our private bathrooms
we have
you know we have more
uh
better types of transportation
but and communications
to the telephones and postal service
it's more efficient
but
you know on the other hand
the vietnamese they do have a lot of
dignity and they have
their
what they live with is um
they get by with it
and they're proud of what they have
and they realize that often when you go
to their house they'll say oh vietnam is
very poor
but you know they don't they don't kind
of
soup down and feel that they're inferior
because of that they just say it
let me reverse that question say what do
the vietnamese have that we americans
don't have
i would say
that the one thing that you find in
vietnamese society you don't find in
american society is that
the vietnamese are have much greater
innocent sentimental attachment to each
other than you find in in western
society the western society american
society in particular
is it's much more atomized that the role
of the individual is quite is much
stronger there
and
here in vietnam
people the support network of your
family of your neighbors and your
friends and whatnot is much stronger
and there's much there's a much greater
sense of identity within that
context of the family
or the patrilineage or whatever
associated it would be
something to add to that mercy
no i would just say
they've definitely got a greater sense
of social coherence and
i guess just from hanoi speaking about
hanoi because it is
fairly small
and people tend to know
everybody else and they know what's
going on they're very
very aware of what is happening in their
society
and i think
in a way they do tend to be a lot more
caring about their extended family as
well
one of the things i noticed of course we
have a couple of little characters
crawling all over the statue here you
see kids on the streets everywhere
and in the united states you wouldn't
see that very much
why is that so you see them on the
bicycles and they ride with the families
and is that an important part of this
way of living
yeah well like i was saying before there
isn't much space for the families
physically in hanoi and so children tend
to play out in the streets and very much
together with the neighbors and the
neighbors children
and
they don't have the type of
entertainment that we have like the toys
and television and so they they learn to
interact socially really really young
they
basically their playground is outside
with each other
i don't know whether this is a hard
question to answer or not but
undoubtedly you had an impression when
you first moved here
and then it might have changed over time
you've been here the longest sean what
changes about what changed in your
attitude about vietnam the longer you
were here
anything
uh
every
with every passing day
the atmosphere here
becomes much
more bearable it's much easier now to
live here as a foreigner and for example
when i first came materially
life is much improved than when i first
arrived and also just in terms of the
general
tenor of
life on the streets and in the city it's
much more relaxed now than when it was
when i first arrived and i was you know
for example when i was here it was only
a couple months after
i was here that
there was an american teacher that was
deported so in those days it was still
very touch and go
and being here as american and being
here as american researcher you were
always
you're always looking over your shoulder
of when
when when is the when's the ax going to
fall and they're gonna send me home
do you feel mercy that you can say and
do anything you want to hear
and if not what can't you do what can't
you say
well i wouldn't want to say anything
that i want that you know i would like
to because that would probably scare a
lot of people away from
allowing me to talk to them about my
research or you know they might feel a
little more uncomfortable but i think
within reason
they're they're very willing to discuss
and
they're uh
yeah i think they're quite open to two
ideas and they're also open to
criticizing their own system it's not as
if
i don't feel as if i have to restrict
myself very much has it changed what you
got here in october in october has it
changed much since then for you
longer you're here no even at that time
it was still uh i still felt i was quite
surprised actually that it was as open
as as i found it
i had expected it to be a lot more rigid
and bureaucratic actually before i came
here and i haven't found that to be so
much of a problem
what about the educational system have
you had a chance to look at
other than your own schooling the
high schools or the grade schools
you know much about that sean
well it's kind of a shambles
education is
in the state of crisis in vietnam
the problems ranging from no money for
for schools no money for teachers and
now
particularly in the last few years with
the economic changes
many students feel that
they can go and they can get a make a
better living
if they skip school and just go right
into business
and that's been a real challenge
particularly for higher education
in vietnam is that many people feel many
of the students feel that if i get a if
i get a university degree then the only
job awaiting me is a job in the perhaps
a bureaucracy or as a teacher or
something like this and the wages are
notoriously low
and so that is that's a real challenge
for the educational system to confront
what do they make on average a month
your average i think people say 10 or 12
a month or so
it's hard it changes all the time
and again the value of the vietnamese
dome itself fluctuates what do they not
pay for like you know we talk about
health insurance and
transportation and
all that
and pretty much you pay for everything
now
but like for instance
uh health what would they what would it
cost them for a day in the hospital you
have any idea
again it depends there are some
hospitals that are that are available
that i think there's no charge required
at all again i'm not an expert on this
like but just speaking with friends who
have experience with hospitals
but those are ones you don't have to pay
anything at all but the better hospitals
as i understand it
you frequently do have to pay i've had
friends who's who've had parents that
have been quite ill and they've been
really desperately looking for money
to
go so that their parents can get the
proper treatment
and and this has emerged that in the
last few years that
again
there's no longer a simple so
independent socialist medical system
but individual private practitioners who
can ask for fees
have emerged
and many people
like to go to those
through those doctors and feeling that
in a sense their training is better the
care will be better and there's less of
a risk of
want to wrap it up i'll ask you each
last question if you had to do over
again the decision of coming here
would you do it
definitely definitely has it lived up to
what you expected it to um
yeah and it's actually it's been more
fulfilling and more interesting than i
had expected it to be what's the most
interesting thing so far
i guess most interesting has been
the people have been really a lot more
open than i ever expected them to be and
very friendly very
able to take me in and to
to show me around and to talk to me
about their ideas and
that's been incredible sean would you do
it again
yeah i suppose
i think undoubtedly i would do it again
it's been
it's been very interesting to be here
particularly from the perspective of
i was in the first wave of people to
come here
in the
with as an american student
and to have been here for such a long
time
and to see so many changes go on and see
such
so many fundamental changes have you
gone home
certainly yes how many times
three
[Music]
three you hesitate a little bit on
whether you do it well i've been
it hasn't been easy
what's been the most hard
sorry what's been the most difficult
thing
when you live here you live under
restrictions you definitely live under
restrictions
vietnam
is
basically a very conservative society
and it's difficult
even to
socializing can be difficult you know
say for example if you go out with
friends and they're females there's all
sorts of you get all sorts of comments
and cat calls and it's kind of a
humiliating experience
for and if you're if you're seen with an
asian woman
uh that's one that's one problem uh
and also
there's
for example my guest house i live with
an 11 o'clock curfew
and
a lot of there are a lot of
other restrictions for example you
cannot travel freely in vietnam
that
in that
if i want to go anywhere outside of the
city of hanoi outside of the city limits
i have to ask permission
i'm supposed to have somebody accompany
me as well
somebody who is responsible for me
and so there are
a number of
just you come to situations where you
want to go you want to change the
scenery you just want to be able to go
and
ride and just
do something different but
you can't
because of the bureaucracy and because
of the law because of the security
situation
when you're here for a very long period
of time it's very it's very draining and
just working with bureaucracy here
that's for me has been quite exhausting
because if you come here and you have
if you come here with very modest goals
it's very it's very
it's a lot easier
however if you come here and your goals
are you know for example mine of
collecting enough data in order to write
my dissertation
then
you're fighting a constant battle
with the vietnamese bureaucracy of
getting getting your permits getting all
your papers in order and whatnot
and i think now i think now again
if somebody came and did it now it'd be
a lot easier than when i did it
because now in a sense paths are
starting to emerge trails are starting
to emerge people can see
other people's experiences and know how
to go but
grace
last question
if you had to do over again would you
and uh
what's been the most difficult part of
this
um i would definitely do it over again
um but only the way i have been doing it
i
i originally did plan to
have more in-depth research here
but i think if i did do it over again i
would have more modest goals like i do
now just kind of relax and take it easy
with the system because the bureaucracy
is really difficult and even um while i
was researching theater i i really
didn't have to go through that much
bureaucracy but with the theater
management and with you know just the
various directors of the troops and of
the physical theater itself
they they kind of get the
you they're kind of afraid to let you
come in too much
enter too far probably because they're
afraid of what um
what the government would allow them to
expose and i ran into some problems and
i really thought that the arts wouldn't
be much of a
you know there wouldn't be many
obstacles politically but it there did
seem to be quite a couple
thanks for taking the time
thank you marissa and gracer from the
university of hawaii
sean from the university of michigan
thank you
thank you
[Music]
you're watching vietnam revisited on
c-span
during the war many u.s media
organizations had bureaus at the caravel
hotel in saigon which is now ho chi minh
city
at times journalists watched as events
of the war unfolded from the famous
caravel roof
vietnam revisited continue shortly but
now more views of ho chi minh city from
the caravel
hmm
it was on that roof that our guest who
has been with us all day katie kelly
used to take a lot of her amerasian
students
to teach them english to drink cokes to
do what else up there on the roof of the
rex hotel it was a learning experience
yes to speak english it was well was
such a treat for them because they
would not have been allowed into the
hotel without me and this was a perfect
excuse but you've been on that that
rooftop terrace it is
fabulous it is a wonderful place to go
and just kind of hang out
and a lot of photo opportunities which
they love because there's a swimming
pool up at the top and flush toilets
great porcelain flush toilets never in
my life have i come to appreciate the
concept of flush toilets so for those
folks that have just joined us let me
show them what the book looks like and
tell us again
what led to this book
what led to this book was a simple
vacation where i ended up in saigon and
started seeing amerasian teenagers left
over from the vietnam war
when i got back to new york or i was
working for nbc television
and
decided i had to go back over there and
the only thing i could do was teach
english so i went back over
in a year within a year
and set up a very small tutoring program
with about 25 american kids
best thing i ever did my whole life you
stayed in a hotel that cost you ten
dollars a night in a cheap hotel i
shared the top floor with a load of bats
paid ten dollars a night for the
privilege
now you know when we first saw the
picture right there at the break the
first shot was of the saigon river and
the floating hotel the saigon floating
hotel which is 200 at least a night i
think it's 250 now
did you ever stay there are you kidding
i went into i went and i tried to buy a
coke
the coke was like five dollars
i don't i mean that does that thing work
that hotel which i guess is owned by the
japanese um i thought it was the
australians yeah the japanese stay there
oh yeah it works and it's beautiful on
the inside i walked up to the desk when
i was there and asked the i didn't stay
there i asked the uh
the the woman behind the desk who owns
it i got this story so
there's a lot of different stories about
that it was built in singapore moved to
australia for a year then move to
vietnam by the japanese that supposedly
own it and that's all i know hey
what whatever whatever works it did have
real hot disco that that
visitors like to go to
i didn't even get to the disco you write
at the back of your book on the last
paragraph of the book you say i suppose
i went to vietnam as much for myself as
for any highflown ideas of goodness and
mercy why did you feel the need to write
that in the book
well i mean i'm not a perfect person and
i don't want anybody especially myself
to think that i just went over there you
know some lady do good some lady
bountiful
and
i really do believe i went over as much
for myself i went as a human being who
felt very guilty about what we had done
to these young people as children
but i think also
there
there is that part of me that's a
journalist i went over there there was
an awful lot of curiosity
about that place
a place that that so occupied all of us
in the 60s and certainly occupied me and
changed my life in the 60s so i think
there was a lot of
personal curiosity you were born
albeit in nebraska nebraska boone county
nebraska where'd you go to school albion
high school
college university of missouri first
time i left the state of nebraska was to
go to missouri and i thought oh wow
missouri great
you taught school taught school for four
years worked for time magazine
yeah for how long seven years seven
years was a started out as a researcher
because that's all girls could do in
1966
and
in about 18 months i became a writer and
was i wrote
world and nation but mostly uh
entertainment show business this book is
in your
book stores
retails for 22
it's uh told what through the eyes of
your eyes but it's about the kids yeah
it's a first person account it's a
memoir but what i wanted to do was tell
the very personal stories of all these
amerasians that i i had met
to tell the rest of the world how they
had lived which was
pretty distressing after a couple calls
you're going to meet two vietnamese uh
they're americans they were born here i
believe no they weren't born here you'll
they'll tell you the story and we asked
them to come here after they were here
as senators high school students here as
senators with boys nation
and doing quite well in school we spent
a half hour with them taped it a couple
of weeks ago and we'll visit with them
shortly but first a call from burton
texas for katie kelly go ahead please
brian hi
uh down here in central texas uh i met a
young vietnamese family about a year ago
one was an amerasian boy
and
i've been trying to teach him english
been working with him for about a year
uh he was here for uh maybe three or
four months
and uh
and and got a job
he uh
the other day asked me what tdl meant on
a slip of paper
and i showed him that that was texas
driver's license
and
he understood that perfectly they wanted
that to identify him at the bank
he had
a balance in his account
of
600
and i said
i said tun
how did you
he he said oh i gotta have more than
that
and it was an older uh a deposit slip
and uh as he told me he'd been working
here ten months and one week
and he had over seven
seventy two hundred dollars in the bank
well these are these are hard working
kids one of the kids that i sponsored
had a job within six weeks
opened up a bank account
and had you know a couple thousand
dollars in the bank account by the end
of the summer
one of my students here in the united
states you're in the united states you
say you can't trust the banks in uh
vietnam
well there are no banks i mean they're
trying to learn how to set up a banking
system now but people had money in there
and i mean you told one story oh yeah
the the there was a huge banking scandal
where the the directors of the bank just
ran off with all the money and somebody
had deposited ten thousand and they got
two thousand two thousand dollars back
they i figured something was wrong there
but
i went up to fargo north dakota to visit
one of my students he works uh two jobs
he has
eight hours a day
he works as on an assembly line in a
small factory and then he takes a little
break and eight hours at night he washes
dishes in a mexican restaurant he's got
a lot of pictures in this book this is
my favorite oh that's chow and his
mother pearl and his mom
how long ago was this taken well i think
that was probably around 1968 and
they're both in rochester minnesota now
is the adult over here yeah yeah right
let's show what the adult looks like
right and his mom now
right there let's take a last call for
this segment from milwaukee wisconsin go
ahead please oh hi how you doing fine
that's good yeah i just this is a
marvelous program i um
i wish they would have more on about uh
about vietnam i'm a vietnam war veteran
and uh i used to just marvel at the one
nice environment my armor personnel
carrier there
it's marvel at the beauty of that
country oh isn't it it's spectacular it
is spectacular and i was up uh i was up
towards uh a little bit south of danang
a little bit inland there
and uh it's one place i always want to
go back to well it's truly beautiful did
you ever get over to the beach near
danang absolutely as a matter of fact my
last month there i was at the uh in
chula at the base camp in july and my
job was to
shuttle people up and back to the front
and my
head little house right on the beach for
my last month and it was absolutely
gorgeous isn't it the most beautiful
beach in the whole world absolutely and
you know and you know people think uh of
that country as being
you know uh you know backward and the
people being backward and they're not
they're just you know extremely
intelligent people oh yeah i mean it's
just victims of circumstance but it's a
you're right it's a beautiful country
milwaukee thanks for calling we're
running out time for this segment and
katie kelly's going to stay with us
until the last we'll have probably about
10 minutes to chat about this this next
segment
um
describe a little bit more for those
who've just joined us what they'll find
in your book
they'll find um a lot of stories
personal stories about the amerasians
that i that i worked with about their
mothers about their families about their
situations um
it's a very serious book obviously
dealing with uh vietnam and
some parts of the war and uh
the situations but it's also a very
funny book because these are very
generous gregarious people and so you'll
laugh you'll cry you'll love it will you
go back i don't know um
at the moment i don't have any plans to
i'd like to because i love the country
and i still do have some friends good
friends over there but so many of the
admirations that i worked with in in my
little tutoring program are over here so
i'm just
you know having a lot of fun catching up
with them and also i'm still tutoring
admirations
there's a whole gang of them in new york
city and an alternative high school so i
that keeps me pretty busy
we're going to have at least another 10
minutes with katy kelly and there's one
other segment the the two gentlemen
who are vietnamese americans
who are
as a matter of fact you'll see that the
president talked about him in in his
address
to them in the rose garden a couple of
weeks ago uh and they are now students
and they'll explain all that to you we
find out what it's like
two people who have succeeded quite well
already at age i think 17.
this is at your request a repeat of what
we showed some 30 hours over memorial
day weekend c-span went to vietnam took
five people with us followed the
m-i-a-p-o-w's committee the select
committee at the senate around for a
trip both in hanoi and down south
tomorrow is m.i.a.p.o.w day here 12 noon
east coast time that's on tuesday later
on this week we'll focus on
the economics of that part of the world
on thursday the trip to the mekong delta
for those that were there and can
remember bases like kento and fuqua and
others you can see that all day on
friday afternoon
but for the moment those of you that
phoned us to our viewer response line
back over memorial day were able to make
a recording about how you felt about
this whole series we're going to listen
to a little bit of that and then go
right into the interview with the two
gentlemen who were senators at boys
nation
i found the vietnam revisited
presentation very interesting
well we heard many statements from
vietnamese officials about cooperation
to resolve the power of the mia problem
i didn't see any evidence of it
i believe they had been stonewalling us
from the beginning and are still doing
so this trip was based on the fact that
uh
they were supposed to have open access
unannounced
to any place they wanted to go i see
here one woman saying that there's a
question that i'm getting into the snake
that
was having permission to do so they just
made a comment in front of senator
kerry's uh
committee to the effect that we'll show
them this place but we're not going to
show them the other place my wife's
vietnam he's and she picked that up
other 69 70 71
p.o.w 71-74
why are we
going over talking to officers and
north vietnamese regulars
why aren't they out talking to the
people and not having officers anything
around them
you're not going to find nothing
standing there on that base talking to a
bunch of nba officers
just want to let you know that whatever
you're doing in in vietnam is good but
uh be careful uh the viet uh the
companies vietnam companies it fool you
a lot of time during the world and uh
right now i believe they they they treat
you very well just because your money it
will take a collapse of communism in
hanoi to find out for the whole truth
about american prisoners and prisoners
communists will never reveal the truth
about how many may have been killed or
how many are still in prison in the
vietnam
and i i
have bad experience as communism with my
father and a lot of many members of my
family on the communist soviet union and
we cannot trust communists never only
collapse of communists as i said will
reveal the whole truth
but anyway for two of you the journey
has taken you even further
all the way from communist vietnam
and what a moving uh story
is juan lee's
neon dong nuens
uh they have a great story to tell
leaving culture and country behind
to start over
to start afresh here in the united
states of america
and your presence here today reminds us
all of america's meaning
of america's magic
juan lee that was back in july
when you were attending boys nation and
that was the president united states in
the rose garden what was your reaction
when they when he singled you out um it
was it was really an honor for me and a
privilege to have the president of the
united states mention my name and i um i
was really surprised but inside i was
very happy that he mentioned my name did
you expect it um i
wasn't at first because uh someone had
called me earlier
and asked me a little bit about my
background and he said that he wasn't
sure if my name was going to be
mentioned or not and so i was i was half
and half i wasn't really sure but i was
i was really looking forward to
listening to george bush to see if he
would mention my name nan trung yuan how
about you were you surprised
um yes i was but it was an honor to hear
my name you know spoken or mentioned
personally addressed by the president
um
i consider it a great privilege and
i think that's the highest honor you can
have is to have the president of the
united states you know the leader of
your nation
to you know mention you
where were you born i was born in saigon
vietnam what year in 1974. when did you
come to the united states 1979.
so you spent five years in vietnam do
you remember anything about it i
remember lots of things about it i was
born right before the fall of saigon
and
i would remember
how
because my my dad was imprisoned by the
north vietnamese government and i
remember how my mom would take me all
the way up to north vietnam
or or central vietnam to visit my father
over there and had a lot of memories of
my family and
my friends over there my childhood
friends that i used to play with
and
even though it was that small you know i
could remember a lot where is home now
home it's in phoenix arizona
and
i have
very i have
a lot of you know good friends over
there i like
in phoenix yes
mr lee how did you get to washington for
this boys nation thing well first of all
i attended um
boys state in my state of nevada at the
university of nevada reno can i stop you
and ask you what boys state is boys
state is uh it's a wonderful program
first of all it's sponsored by the
american legion and what it did what it
is is they um
they have certain
um
kids in high schools who attend a
week-long
kind of a week-long camp at a university
and they learn about
the government how it's run
you get to have mock elections
and after that week
at our boy state
the counselors would nominate
certain individuals who stood out or who
would
be good candidates for boys nation and
six people were narrowed down and we
were each interviewed separately by uh
by two councillors and two american
legion officers and
luckily enough i was one of the
delegates to be picked to come here to
boys nation
where were you born i was born in saigon
vietnam what year
january 22nd 1975.
when did you come to the united states
he came to the united states
in 1977.
so you were only two years old actually
i only lived in vietnam for two months
i left
four days before this fall of saigon on
april 26 1975 and then we moved to south
korea in seoul where my father lived and
we lived there uh the remainder of two
years and then we came to um the united
states of america have you been back
no i haven't
asked mr nguyen have you been back no we
i haven't been back but we are going to
come back this summer
for how long or not this summer but next
summer excellent
we're planning to stay there for at
least a month
all right now how american do you two
feel
i'm
i'm very proud to be an american and
i think that's
to serve your country to be in a country
and a great nation which gives you
freedoms
that are sometimes taken for granted
um freedoms that you know that are given
to the people and you know all the
rights that you have i mean it's just
it's just so wonderful you know once you
think about it because i came from a
communist oppressed nation
and it's
my parents came over here and they
risked everything they lived there they
risked their lives there was their
fortune in order to come over here and
in order to
to let their children have a better life
in order to start anew again
and um
america is the land of opportunity and
um
it's just great
how vietnamese do you feel
i feel vietnamese um gosh i feel a lot
more american than vietnamese um because
i'm so used to society the way things
are run
the vietnamese part of me is mainly with
my mom because um there's a lot of times
that she'll still speak to me in
vietnamese and my brother who's also
vietnamese
and that's where most of my my heritage
is is with my family and um although i
feel very american i still retain all
those vietnamese values and my korean
values because my father was korean and
so i have um both of those backgrounds
but i'm proud
of all three of being american korean
and vietnamese is your uh
uh
lost is your father still alive my
father passed away when i was nine years
old we did and you live now in nevada
yes i do what's your mother do my mom
currently is a manicurist in vietnam
she was a pharmacist where she had two
two pharmacies and
unfortunately when she came to america
there was not a pharmacy school in reno
nevada and so she went into beauty
school and then became manicurist now i
see her on this sheet
something under your name this bio sheet
says gold card recipient a 4.0 grade
point average yeah um what's wonderful
about my school worcester high school
what we have is a program where we
really reward students who are
outstanding in academics and they every
semester if you get a 4.0 grade point
average you receive a gold card and this
gold card gives you
certain
um
certain things that are really positive
one of the things is you get to have one
one day off of school
arrange with your vice principal another
thing you can you can skip two finals
and a lot of a lot of wonderful
things and i think it's a great thing
for high schools to have because
sometimes
a lot of times the academically talented
kids don't really get that type of
recognition that they deserve and so a
gold card really gives them
that extra incentive
to to continue to perform well in school
mr nguyen are you able to do as well as
your friend across the table um
not as well i have a 3.7 grade point
average
but i'm really involved in
politics in my school
that i think is one of my you know
major interests and
as far as academics i
i do pretty well but um
you know i just i just want to round
myself off
i mean i commend you know juan for for
all the things that he has achieved did
you two know each other before boys
nation no
are there any other
participants that are from vietnam
um i haven't really gotten to talk to
anyone one person from laos um and a
couple others from korea and one from
china
one of the things that we talk a lot
about on this network and in the society
is discrimination in this country um
against people who are not white
do you get any of this
um i've had my um racial encounters
but i've learned to tolerate it
and it's just i guess i'm just a
tolerant person
as far as my views towards racial
inequality and racial prejudice i think
that it's very wrong and people
shouldn't be guard you know regarded by
the color of their skin their creed
their religion
whether they're black or white or yellow
or you know polka dotted striped but um
by the the
the quality of their being by their
merit and by their personality have you
been discriminated against um i've had
my fair share of discrimination but
like none said you've gotta
just take it and then walk away because
there's some things that you have no
control over and
you know it's sometimes really tough but
i've learned to to deal with it and to
be become a better person because of it
when you do see it what how does it
what's the reason for it i mean what
what are they what kind of things happen
oh gosh basically you know the the usual
you know
words that are um very big the bigoted
words
and um
yeah the racial slurs basically is there
a lot of it how would you not a lot you
know just once in a while because um
fortunately i live around an area that's
very open-minded and very
racially tolerant how much of your
vietnamese heritage have you kept in
your family my heritage um
it's very
the vietnamese culture in my family and
my household is you know we're very
strong in that
but um
parents both alive yes
both in phoenix yes what do they do for
a living my mother works for honeywell
and my father works for a continental
circuits corporation
have in your family have there been any
adjustment problems to living in the
united states
um
at first we had to you know
when we got to the states um american
society was so different so radical from
our own
and but we have learned to assimilate
into it and i think that you know along
the way we've been able able to open our
minds you know and accept
the better part of american civilization
for me
the main thing my parents learned
and but they knew was going to happen
was wherever you go whatever country
you're going to be in hard work is what
really matters and from day one they
started working they started
planning their future already and
sometimes
it's difficult for
people to adjust to the american society
because there's so many different
customs but if you heart you work hard
and you believe it in the government um
i feel i believe that there's no way
that
you can't adjust to what america has to
offer can you both speak fluently
vietnamese i can speak for vietnamese i
cannot speak fluently but i understand a
lot and i understand when my parents
were talking bad about me so
that always comes in handy but mostly i
don't speak that much but i understand
quite a bit if you had to guess today
what would you guess you would become
professionally professionally probably a
neurosurgeon
a neurosurgeon neurosurgeon you're
always talking about that people always
use those in conversations i'm not a
neurosurgeon what is it about you
that that means that you're not a brain
surgeon and you're not
um well neurosurgeons they specialize in
you know the nervous system
and um
if i don't become a nervous neurosurgeon
i would definitely be at least something
you know in the medical field the
medical profession where do you get your
interest in this my interest basically
comes out of helping people you know um
it is such a great honor that doctors
and
surgeons you know receive you know such
prestige you know and
because you hold the balance of life and
death in your hand i think that is
the
the most
the most
that's i think that's the hardest thing
to do is to you know you have control of
life and death
next year you're going to be what you're
in high school i will be a senior where
are you going to go to college you know
i um
i'm thinking about the west or east
coast but um
i have in mind the university of arizona
in tucson tucson
what do you aspire to be do you know yet
um i would also like to
go into the medical field whether it's
becoming a family doctor or something
that i've been looking into is dentistry
either orthodontistry or family practice
your year in school senior i'm going to
be you know where you're going to go to
college i think i'm planning on
attending the university of nevada reno
boys nation
anything
that comes to mind quickly that you have
learned from boys nation itself and by
the way how many other
men are there here with you
there's a total of 96. there's a total
of 96 delegates here um two states
didn't
um come um and excluding what the
delegates from washington dc to
i think
two from each state
and how were you chosen by the way i was
chosen um
i ran for secretary of state or the
equivalent of lieutenant governor and
other states
at my um boys state and i've got elected
and from that
they chose
or they let the boys the other boys
choose who they would think would be
best to represent their state over boys
nation they chose six from that and from
the six the counselors had to interview
all six of us and then choose
the two
out of arizona
before you answer what you learned from
boys nation go back to the boys state
experience can
you tell us how i mean what was it that
you did back in high school
both in nevada and in arizona that got
you selected to go to boys state
again it was the paula you know i'm i'm
very interested in the political system
of america as well as you know all
foreign relations and foreign affairs
around the world
and
i have participated in
arizona modeled united nations
and we represented the united states of
america
and i was fascinated by all the you know
all the influential political influence
and the power
and the prestige that america has on the
world
and from then um
i i i got interviewed by my um
by my counselors and my teachers and um
they asked me um questions
that you know
like um you know who is your idol and
you know
what important event do you think
affects you the most
my idol um i don't have a particular one
idol that i focus on of course my
parents i respect a great deal because
they came from a war-torn country and
now they've given me you know new um
practically a new life
and
and basically you know artists because i
respect them for their creativity their
their individuality
what about boyce state how did you get
selected in the first place for that
first of all i was encouraged by my
cousin who went to boys state two years
ago
he said it was a wonderful experience
and an opportunity that i shouldn't miss
and also my
social studies teacher encouraged me to
go for it and
i just sent my application to the
counselors and luckily luckily enough i
was one of the three delegates to be
chosen to go to boys state in my school
okay what have you learned from boys
nation the whole experience boys nation
um gosh
it's first of all i just like to say
that boys nation has been an absolutely
wonderful experience for me i'm getting
a chance to
hear mr bush president bush speak to us
also we got to listen to dick cheney um
the
the best thing i've learned is
about the
the government just how it's run
all
all the the little parts about the
government that i i really wasn't um
clear of before a lot of people in the
country are cynical about the government
are you
um
i believe that the government right now
is
just going through a cycle and we're
just in the bad side of the cycle right
now
i still have a strong belief in what
america has to stand for the government
everything that
america
has to offer to to
any person
unfortunately a lot of people have
don't believe in what america has to
offer anymore and but i still have that
strong belief in that america is still
the greatest country mr nguyen what did
you
take away from boys nation um i learned
more about the the political
infrastructure of the united states
i've learned i've always known that you
know there are many alternatives to
democracy and there are many forms of
government but democracy in america is
the best form that we can have with the
with the uh fall of the soviet union
and um you know the failed coup d'etat
it really opened everybody's eyes and
you know the power of democracy and that
is that communism is wrong and um
and with all the capitalisms the new
capitalisms that are you know just
blossoming from all over the world you
know not just the soviet union in
particular but from eastern europe and
um
limited
not you know not
not always you know
from asia but i've seen you know little
um special sections of asia that have
been you know spurred on by capitalism
and i think that we will go far you know
in the 21st century and democracy will
prevail everywhere you know several
months ago there was a study done about
vietnamese
high school students in this country and
how well they do and i think it was done
at the university of michigan
and the study found that in vietnamese
families
there's a concentration on studying and
the family studies together around the
table at night after dinner
you two have done well in your high
school studies do you have that
experience um with my family
my mom does have that deep emphasis on
studying but she doesn't uh she she's
very busy working she has many other
activities to take care of that she
leaves it up to me and um
for me for myself i don't study with my
family but i study because i realize
that i have to work a little harder and
i have to use take advantage of this
free education system and so i i'll
usually spend maybe three four hours a
night studying
very hard on on my subjects um favorite
subject my favorite subject is math
how about in your experience in the
family a lot of emphasis there is
there's overwhelming um emphasis on
study together how many others we don't
study together because my mother and
father are usually busy as well
but she she sets her priorities on
education the first
and everything else falls in line but
education is the foremost and very
highly regarded in our house how many
kids in the family i'm too just myself
and my sister
when you think about vietnam from your
perspective
what do you think about
if you were to go back and you say
you're going back next year what do you
want to see
i want to see uh my um
my house over there you know where i
lived as a child
and i also wanted to see all the great
monuments of
of you know the past south vietnamese
government
on my views toward vietnam right now
i think that
they are trying to loosen up because
they know they're beginning to realize
that commune communism does not work you
know and they have seen an example of it
through the biggest communist state in
the world and that is russia
and i think that eventually they will
you know they will reform they will
eventually revert to democracy i'm very
hopeful of that
but um at this moment you know we'll see
do you study at all the history of it
now yes i study part of some history in
vietnam
how about the same question if you go
back there and you ever intend to go
back there what would you want to say um
i would like to go back there with my
mother and my brother um mainly to see
the the wonderful things that my mom had
she had two pharmacies she had
a very nice house but mostly i'd have to
agree i'd like to see the entire country
because leaving the country at two
months old i really don't know that much
about
the surroundings of it and i would like
to just see
the country itself and also some of my
family members that are still in vietnam
have you studied much of the history of
it
ho chi minh
looms heavy for a visitor like us when
we went over there uh
in april you see his statue everywhere
does ho chi minh mean anything to either
one of you
ho chi minh i think
that
personally i don't regard him
you know very highly because what he did
to the vietnamese people
i mean you know here we are we're one
we're supposed to be of one culture and
we have you know the same morals same
values and what he did was unforgivable
i think because he tore the nation apart
i would have to agree he took advantage
of vietnam and
although he may have been a good leader
he
took advantage of his leadership and
took vietnam in the wrong direction mr
nguyen i see here on your bio that
you're a baptist
there aren't many baptists in vietnam
how did you get to that religion if you
don't mind me asking if this is that's a
personal thing with everyone
um basically through the missionaries
that helped us when we had when we came
over here and we've gotten sponsored by
um baptist people and i've learned to
respect christianity very much and um
although i i haven't attended church as
much as i have little you know when i
was little um i still keep my baptist
ties mr you're catholic
how did that happen um my family
basically were they catholic can be in
vietnam i believe so yes
all right
to both of you uh
when you're looking ahead
to the future besides wanting to be
doctors or whatever
what else where do you want to live
what other goals do you have
and we'll let you go home
basically i would like to um
help people around the world and i think
with you know my um
if i study hard enough if i become a
doctor
there no there are limitless things that
i can do because knowledge is power
and once you have knowledge there's so
many things that you can do you know
it's just it's just the decision of
whether you want to abuse it or if you
want to serve it for the right for the
betterment of mankind
i'd also like to continue my education
uh
and then um possibly in the future i
would probably like to stay in reno i'm
very happy with where the society that
i'm living in there um perhaps also in
moving into california also now i guess
i should call you both senators right
yeah
senators senators uh
lee and senators nguyen thank you very
much for sharing your experience with us
you're welcome thank you thank you
oh what great kids i'll take a hundred
of each
anything they say surprising they
fabulous
not really i think the the immigrant and
especially the refugee immigrant and
especially the ones from vietnam
really love and appreciate this country
and i mean
what those kids said i mean really rang
true
that about democracy and about freedom
and about wanting
why they wanted to come here i uh
underlined and turned the page down on
in your book by the way if you've just
joined us this is katie kelly's new book
and it's in the bookstores
some of you may remember her from
television she used to be on nbc
television was a television critic both
movies and broadway and it's been a year
1990 in vietnam teaching american kids
english on page 239
you wrote as for their new country that
country they had dreamed of for so long
well sad to say that america probably
did not exist
why what were they dreaming of these
kids that you were teaching over there
and why did why doesn't it exist the
ones that what they were dreaming of i i
think they had this fantasy
land
this fantasy country
that
had been thinking about them
all of these years
had been waiting for them
to come here
a fantasy country that when they got
here would be standing with open arms to
welcome them
and um
i don't think that's going i don't think
that would
that exists for these kids you also
you really said nothing could be that
good it simply would not could not live
up to their dreams for their dreams were
fantasies america is not an easy country
because democracy is not easy freedom is
not easy and our own experiment in
democracy was still young still in an
infancy experiencing
terrible awful growing pains that left
us reeling and bewildered we sometimes
forgot that we were a nation of
immigrants a nation of people who had
for nearly
three centuries now shoved our personal
hopes and dreams into a series of burlap
bags and steamer trunks and plastic tote
bags and backpacks
and set off for the promised land
there's some more here but you obviously
were
venting at that point in your books the
stuff you want to get off your chest
sure i mean we are a nation of
immigrants and i remember my parents and
grandparents talking about that and how
far back does your own family go to
my great grandparents came over from
ireland during
two successive potato famines
and um
we were we were refugees
but we all all of us
forget that we're a nation of immigrants
at one time or another we forget that
um
and that every year brings us a new wave
of immigrants and i i i fear
for these kids
and what might happen to them
let's
grab a call from fort knox kentucky go
ahead please yes i like to comment on ho
chi minh
i think that uh people are misinformed
about uh
ho chi minh he how actually we made him
what he was
when he came to
truman in 54 for help
and expelling the french from the
country saying that the people were
really used by the french back in those
days and
he really all he wanted was to get the
french out of his country
and to liberate his country from the
french who were using them for material
wealth
and most people think that he was a
tyrant or what have you but
actually we made him what he was he came
for help
for democracy or what see what it
whatever it was and
ended up going to turn into the
conference for help to help expel the
french thanks
did you i've got a couple little
pamphlets here i picked this one up up
in hanoi in a bookstore uh it's actually
in english written by fam
von dong now that one i didn't get the
the official biography of ho chi minh
that i had was written by by a russian
there's a what do you think of a man's
our caller's analysis
well up to a certain point he's he's
he's correct uh ho chi minh did go to
harry truman did go to the americans
asking for help and uh
he did start out as a nationalist
certainly
wanting to get vietnam for the
vietnamese
but i also agree that he got a little
bit sidetracked
by falling into the stalinist uh
way of thinking
why i mean from your observations over
there did the amerasian kids that at
utah think about ho chi minh
the same way some of the young people we
heard in that english class earlier in
the day they were supportive of him
called him the father of the country
what did your actually they know very
little bit about him but
what they do think about him is that
he's just a direct association with the
vietnamese communists and they despise
the communists so i'm sure a little bit
of that rubs off on on ho chi minh their
whole feelings are just directed right
straight toward the communist
bureaucracy which has made their life
made their life miserable you know when
uh when you got back you wrote i mean
you wrote this book after you came back
in 1991 uh the early 91 you say here i
was sent reeling by everything from
wearing pantyhose to hot water on demand
you said the shelves in my local
supermarket stunned me
do we really need 15 different kinds of
breakfast flakes even garbage depressed
me all that waste all those things
thrown away leftover food being scraped
off plates and restaurants drove me nuts
i became sour and judgmental a loony old
lady stomping around the neighborhood
glaring at limousines
oh i did i was i went nuts i just as i
said
i had a very easy transition going from
new york city to saigon
it was coming from saigon
back to new york city that drove me
crazy
i mean i went to that supermarket and i
just i mean i just stood there
in stunned amazement
in front of the breakfast food in front
of the milk crate cartons i mean how
many different kinds of milk do we need
in vietnam did you have milk in vietnam
uh there's canned milk
and there's no refrigeration
so unless you have fresh
fresh meat or fresh fruits everything is
canned you also wrote about uh
you you keep mentioning all through the
day here the flush toilets you were glad
to have at your hotel yeah and then you
write in your book about you go to
somebody's house for dinner and the
toilet was in the corner yeah it's a
hole in the corner of the kitchen how
much of that
oh that's pretty much all over the
country
i imagine there are there are a few
flush toilets in in saigon but in saigon
it's it's a squat toilet that's made out
of porcelain
whereas out in the countryside it's just
a hole in the ground
if you went back there right now what's
the first thing you'd do if you got back
to saigon probably go to the rex hotel
and have a
glass of iced coffee cafe dendai
what was so great what is so great about
the uh rex hotel
it's
calm and cool and quiet and peaceful
i really believe it's about 10 degrees
cooler on top of the rex hotel
just nice place to chill out if you've
just joined us katie kelly has been with
us all day long and she's been talking
about her book and her experience
and her time is almost up you can go
home to new york this is what the book
looks like it's in the bookstores um let
us show you what the schedule is for
tuesday
and for those of you who have
joined us for the first time all of this
was run most of it katie kelly wasn't
with us was run
first
over memorial day and it was
a
vietnam revisited special of 30 hours
that we did back in april when we took
our cameras over there let's look at
tomorrow's schedule
at 12 30
we actually kicked things off at noon
but at 12 30
john mccain and that was recorded back
before our last series talks about being
a prisoner of war
the plantation
hanoi hilton
in
hanoi
at 125 east coast time
former prisoners of war actually two of
our guests will be from world war ii
prisoners of war to give us a
perspective on just being a pow instead
of just the vietnam war
at two o'clock east coast time pwm mia
committee staff director francis winig
will be our guest to tell us bring us up
to date on what's going on with the
study of the mia pow situation that has
to end by the end of the year when they
file their report
at three o'clock tomorrow east coast
time
we'll open the phones up on the mia pow
issue
senator john kerry live out of boston
via satellite 430. he's the chairman of
that special select committee
alan patak from the defense department
who's involved with these issues will be
our guest at five o'clock
and i think that's about it for tuesday
on
wednesday thursday and friday
we will have
more
in our special
vietnam revisited
economic issues on thursday trip to the
mekong delta which by the way is hanoi
trip to the mekong delta on
friday and on wednesday the
a lot of looking at vietnam
the non-pow mia issues like a trip to
the army museum and a trip to
the ho chi minh mausoleum where he is
supposedly lying in steak
you're not sure because they say i guess
didn't you say that
they took him to russia or something for
refurbishing but he's back
pink and
sleeping quietly you went through the
mausoleum yeah
what'd you think it was cool
i mean they had air conditioning oh very
very air-conditioned
and
in hanoi what was your high point
i think it was just um
i don't know if there was a high point i
think it was walking around i'm a real
people person but walking around and
seeing the people and seeing the
architecture and then
having the people
come and want to carry on conversations
and just i mean would just come out and
sit down and start to talk
very chatty very chatty people also i
was surprised at the openness in hanoi
i've been to other communist countries
and you certainly didn't get that kind
of openness
but of people wanting to come up and
talk or you know sitting in a bar in
your hotel and the people could in hanoi
even could come in right off the street
those who just joined us that they buy
your book they're going to
hear a lot about the kids that you
taught but how many total did you teach
the year you were in vietnam i probably
the hardcore was probably
range from 25 to 50.
and best experience of my life and how
many are you in touch with now back in
this country just about all of them
there's only one kid who's who's still
stuck in saigon he's supposedly getting
out in october and if he doesn't i think
maybe that might be my trip back to get
jim out
one more time look at this book which is
called a year in saigon how i gave up my
glitzy job in television
to have the time of my life teaching
amerasian kids in vietnam katie kelly
thank you very much for joining us oh
thank you for letting me be here and
thanks to jim mills who's our producer
for this program and shepherded this
program all the way from the beginning
it was his idea jacqueline pham who
helped him out along with richard
weinstein and greg gursky who did a lot
of the camera work in vietnam and we
also had one of those little hiats with
us so some of the stuff you've seen on
your screen was shot by the whole bunch
of us carrying them around and trying to
get as much for you for you as we could
during this trip
and
to close this off you'll get a chance to
see
everybody that's been involved putting
this together thanks for joining us
[Music]
right
huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
oh